howard
all right so we'll give one minute we'll
uh get get going here um first up is uh
house bill 1052
um i'll ask everybody who's going to
testify to please make sure on any bill
that you're testifying on that you fill
out the pink card and send it over um so
we have it
for the members one of the things i
learned in criminal justice yesterday is
these microphones if your red light is
on it could cause somebody else not to
be able to turn theirs on so when you're
not speaking please make sure that you
turn your microphone off because after i
think three of them are on the fourth
person can't turn their mic on
so remember when you speak if you push
the button on the right it'll turn it on
and then hit it again it'll turn it off
so you can uh so everybody can speak and
i'd ask all members when they're asking
questions or or
given information to please press the
button
it's okay they can't find mine either so
i'm hoping everybody knows who i am
um
so a couple minutes we'll get going here
i just want to get everybody to be able
to get their seats and have a seat where
come first up is
house bill
1052 relative to the number of rounds
allowed for hunting and reducing
for members uh one of the things i
wanted to bring up for members
if you testify on a bill
you will be allowed to come back and
return to your seat you will not be
allowed to ask any questions of any
witnesses but you can fully participate
in the any executive session or work
session that occurs so just to make sure
you're clear on that you may see a
member get up i represent spelaine's
gonna be our first one um he's gonna go
up and he's gonna introduce this bill
and and testify on it when he's done
testifying he'll come back and sit in
his seat but he'll keep his mouth shut
until that bill that public hearing is
closed
um or or we go into exec session
so that's the rule of the committee um
are there any questions the committee
not seeing any we're going to do we have
any pink cards with jim go get
i need a pink card so even members who
are going to testify need to have a pink
card so jim i need a pink card
oh yeah yeah we'll take care i'm not
all right so representative close would
you mind leading us in the pledge of
to the flag of the united states of
america and to the republic for which it
stands one nation under god
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
good
so i currently have one speaker on 1052
is there anybody else make sure you get
the public uh
hearing on house bill 1052 is open uh
the chair recognized representative
spelaine for the purpose of introduction
and testimony on the bill
thank you distinguished chair and
distinguished members of the fish and
game committee
i bring this uh hb 1052 in front of you
as a housekeeping bill uh requested by
fishing game when we clarified the
number of rounds allowed in pistols and
rifles and such last year uh there was a
request from one of the people reviewing
the bill at fish and game that we also
clarify what's been an uh
point of confusion among um hunters and
whether they could actually have a
magazine that held more rounds
or had more capacity for rounds
than was allowed to shoot and fish and
game has always allowed a magazine of
any size as long as there's only six
rounds
in your weapon
so this will be clarifying that to say
to hunters so they don't keep calling
fish and game or getting you know upset
in the field or hunting trying to hunt
down a five round magazine when they're
hard to find it'll tell them yes you can
use your magazine of whatever size it is
but you may only have six rounds in the
weapon
and
the fish and game officers will
obviously do what they've always done
which is check to make sure you're in
compliance when you're in the field
thank you representative explain uh any
questions for updates i'll explain
so jim i'll have one i want to make sure
i understood what you said and i'm going
to paraphrase it and tell me if i'm
accurate or not um so this bill goes in
alignment with the bills we adjusted
last year where we cleaned up the number
of rounds in certain handguns and rifles
and that kind of thing last year and
that this bill says that
i can have a magazine that may hold 15
rounds but if i'm hunting with that with
that firearm in that magazine i can only
allow
six rounds to be in the gun for the
purposes of hunting and that is current
law and this is just a clarification
bill is that a summary inaccurate it is
correct um you know some people handgun
hunt and there is no option but the
larger magazine they still may only have
six rounds whatever that magazine in the
handgun holds
some rifles have magazines and they're
very old and there's no other option
available that can hold 10 rounds you're
only allowed six that's it
thank you any further questions from the
committee
seeing done
thank you representative plains anybody
else who wish to testify in the house
none i'm gonna open it up for committee
discussion i haven't closed the public
hearing yet so we're entitled to have a
conversation um again i consider this a
housekeeping bill and i'd be interested
in executing this bill in the sense of
the committee if they feel the same way
we can move this forward and move it out
of the out of the committee
everybody okay with that
great
i'm going to close the public hearing on
house bill 1052 and move into exec
session on house bill 1052
um
i've looked at representative spelaine
i will move uh hb 1052 as otp
represent moved house bill 1052 otp
dottonville
king representative king seconds that
motion is there any further discussion
on this on this bill
not seeing any the clerk can call the
roll we're voting on the motion of ought
yes
i don't have a we don't have an uh a sub
for a representative we just a big
committee where we have representative
lekkas and representative johnson
sitting in for representatives
allard and
wolf
johnson
yes
we have a completely different
sorry representative dossier was removed
from our committee
correct and
we have representative lekkis subbing
for representative ballard
is that correct correct
all right
so i have two substitutions but the name
will be representative lekkis
yes
thank you
representative smith
yes
representative horrigan substituting for
representative leflamb yeah
representative dauntonville
representative king
yes
the clerk votes yes
representative egan
or he's just not here
and
representative ellis when you said here
just clarifying
all right the vote is 17-0 chairman lang
though jess
any objection to going on consent seeing
no objection this bill will be placed on
consent
close the executive session on house
next up is house bill 10 30. uh even
though representative pearl did not
recognize representative pearl introduce
and discuss the bill i can't i can't do
that
12 30.
so 12 30 is a permitting online
registrations
online presentation of dear
registrations thank you representative
pearl
have a seat
good morning members of the fish and
game committee for the record my name is
representative howard pearl from loudon
and i am here to introduce house bill
uh this is a pretty simple bill that's
going to allow online registration of
deer once they have been taken i put
this bill in at the request of fish and
game as they were working on
navigating through this process of
establishing
a program and they weren't sure whether
they needed legislation or not at the
time when we were filing so we put in
some language that
we we found out isn't going to be
exactly what they need so there is an
amendment that the chief of wildlife dan
bergeron is going to come and speak to
and
which will change pretty much change the
bill completely to what they
specifically need for the program that
they want to put in place
that's kind of as far as i'm going to go
on and i'm going to turn it over to
dan bergeron if the
chair would like to have him come up and
explain the amendment any questions
representative pearl
being none thank you representative
keith
that's okay the next person's coming up
uh
chair recognizes rep uh dan bergeron
there we go
morning chairman lang and members of the
house fish and game and marine resources
committee
so my name is dan bergeron i'm the chief
of the wildlife division for new
hampshire fish and game
as representative pearl had stated
this bill is to allow the department the
ability to conduct online deer
registration so we use biological data
that we get from
registration of deer to manage the
state's deer population
historically this was done through
businesses local businesses sporting
goods stores convenience stores the
current rsa did not allow us to do this
so this this bill would allow the
ability for us to conduct online
registration
the amendment that representative pearl
spoke to
we need the ability
to be able to require hunters to
register their deer in person
this provides us with an opportunity to
collect biological samples
from the deer more detailed biological
information so we have biologists from
the department who staff
registration stations during the busiest
days of the season
we'll collect
information on weights antler
characteristics reproduction
we'll also collect biological samples
and sometimes we'll partner with other
state agencies
a good example is recently this past
season we worked with new hampshire
health and human services and usda
wildlife avis to collect
blood samples to screen for coveted
antibodies and deer
so we need this flexibility to be able
to require that hunters at certain
points of the season
bring their deer to a physical station
and also
if there's a public health emergency
at other times we could also require
that physical presentation of the deer
not just online
so
the department
would support this bill as amended
thank you for your time
thank you any questions from the
committee representative spelaine
thank you mr chair um thank you mr
bergeron for being here um i
uh assume one of the biggest reasons we
need that ability to require the online
the in-person check-in is to ensure that
we keep a handle on chronic wasting
disease and if there's any hint that
something might have come into the state
we want to be able to take
and require that will this allow us to
require it by
wildlife management unit
as well as
tier of the state and not just do it for
the whole state at a time so for
instance if we think chronic wasting
disease might be leaking in from vermont
that we can
set up to have those along that area be
the ones that have to do it in person
while letting the sea coast by maine
still do online checkout yeah so i i do
believe that the amendment would allow
for that flexibility currently for
chronic wasting disease we collect
samples through butchers outside of the
normal registration process
just to keep the registration process
moving quickly if we were ever to get
cwd we might change that though and we
might need to collect samples at
registration stations so i do believe
that the amendment that was presented
would allow that flexibility thank
you
representative
uh thank you uh mr chair um
is there any concern that
if most hunters
switched online
that
a lot of the check-in stations may no
longer continue to be check-in stations
and then when you want to have you know
you do this emergency closure hunters
are going to have a problem finding a
place to check in yeah so that is one of
the things that we're trying to figure
out we're trying to figure out
internally the best way to still get a
reasonable number of samples so that we
get enough biological information
we did go to online registration for
turkey
kind of at the start of the pandemic and
still about 50 of hunters even after
about two years of that online
registration still choose to register
their turkeys in person
um i i assume it'll probably be somewhat
similar for deer um although you know
those i feel like those are internal
issues we need to work out
this bill kind of this bill more allows
us the ability to set up those online
systems but certainly there'll be things
we need to work out
thank you
any other questions from committee
members
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um i don't see any
fees associated with this online
will there be fees connected with it
yeah i believe there's wording in there
that would allow fees to be set up
okay would they be comparable to what we
have they would be they'd be comparable
potentially slightly more it's tough to
say until we figure out what the
contract will cost because online
registration will be done through an
outside vendor through a contract
so so it will vary but it would be
similar to
what the current registration price is
now it would not be substantially more
than what it is
all right thank you
representative khan
thank you mr dan for taking my question
uh every year
the hunting season we hear that other
states are doing it why we cannot do it
you know from most of the residents from
main reason you just mentioned that that
you want to do a lot of data that we
need for future
why we cannot follow the other state or
what other states are doing
yeah so um currently
massachusetts and vermont
both do what we're proposing to do which
is a combination of physical stations
and online stations
vermont just recently switched to that
in maine
it is
completely 100 physical registration
there's no online option
most states that have
either a fully remote options for
registering their animals are states
that have
substantially higher deer populations
than we do
so states like new york pennsylvania
where hundreds of thousands of deer are
killed in a hunting season in new
hampshire we estimate we have a total
population of just over a hundred
thousand we only harvest
10 to 12 000 deer a year so the data for
new hampshire with our low deer numbers
is very important much more so than
those states that have abundant deer
god representative sam
thank you mr chairman
um
i'm not sure if my question is going to
be able to be answered by you or not
okay but thanks for being here good
morning
does the enforcement division have any
reservations about conservation officers
in the field having access
to the online deer registration
the colonel's here so he can speak to
that but i think i can probably address
that as well
so we've had internal discussions about
this
again it'll be an adjustment from what
we currently do
but but again we've already started to
work through some of these issues
through our online turkey registration
so there is we can set up a system in
place so that officers can access any of
that information
either through their smartphones or or
laptops that they all have available to
them so
you know we're working out the bugs to
make sure they get what they need um but
but that's certainly something that we
can provide them and they should be able
to access
thank you
any further questions
cnn thank you very much for your
anybody else want to speak on house bill
seeing no testimony i'm going to open up
for discussion amongst the committee
members
you have an amendment before you that
amendment i drafted i drafted that event
it's amendment number zero zero two one
h
um that amendment was drafted in
cooperation with fish and game as the
bill was originally entered um there
were some concerns um and mainly it was
around timing we were concerned that if
we passed this law today and it went to
effect in june this november people will
be looking for online registrations we
need to get fish and game time to get
all the processes in place and
everything else so the first thing
you'll see is we put a september 1st
daytona to deal with next year's season
the second thing we did was we gave the
ability for again there was no
rule-making authority that was granted
in the original bill so he gave the fish
and game rule making authority and
allowed them to be able to create
closures as we heard about today
that allows them to close a specific
zone if for some reason they want to
collect biological data for that zone
they could take it as an emergency
closure close that zone
and make everybody register manually so
to speak versus online and then you know
all other zones could stay online um so
that's the amendment
i'm going to do the same thing we did in
that last bill this is sort of a
housekeeping bill requested by fish and
game um i i'm going to straw poll it and
see if we have uh consensus to pass this
bill or to kill this bill depending uh
my recommendation is to pass as amended
with the with amendment 21. is there any
objection to doing that today
none
thank you mr chair um
i'm concerned about the fee
if
you know a fee to register a deal right
now it's a couple bucks
how are you going to make that payment
if
you're doing it over a computer and you
don't have any
credit card or anything like that i mean
maybe we ought to look at an amendment
to put a
registration fee
in the cost of the license
and that way there
when someone registers a tier online or
even in a physical location
that money is already
representative
thank you mr chair just to clarify this
gives an option to either register
online or still go to a deer station so
if you don't have a credit card or you
don't want to use online process you can
still do that manually
that is correct as the amendment's
written and this isn't basically
enabling language who allows hunters
they can choose to still go to their
favorite deer registration place and
hang out and drink coffee while the deer
is being taken care of or they can
choose to just go online and be able to
register the deer so either option would
be available
and i'll just make a general statement
that in most instances across the
across the legislature we're enabling
more executive directors or
commissioners to set fees as necessary
and go through the rules process for
that rather than go through the
legislative process for that because of
i was just going to follow up on that by
saying that
we currently don't have any of the fees
for licenses in legislation they're all
set by the director and at any time the
director could add the registration fee
to the current license fees by going
through gel car and could take care of
that if he determined it was necessary
but
the popularity with
physical check-in for turkeys i think
you're going to see that's even more
popular with deer because people want to
have it weighed and there are a lot of
um lottery competitions at some of these
check-in stations where you sign up and
pay your ten dollars and then if you get
the biggest buck you get to take a 50-50
off the pool
there's a lot of people that play into
these and they're still going to want to
have it physically checked in i i see it
as a convenience issue for those people
who are not close to a
physical check-in station but i think
that
you're going to find a lot of people
still want to bring it in okay any
further discussion
yes
thank you mr chair um the only issue i
see with charging a fee upon license is
many people don't harvest a deer so now
they're paying for something that not
necessarily utilizing that's all
thank you all right so i'm going to go
ahead and uh close the public hearing
move into exec session on house bill
what number are we on
right well i do that in exec
um
sorry
12 30. so we're in executive session for
house bill 1230. i'm going to make a
motion of ought to pass house bill 1230
and then i'll make a motion to adopt the
amendment so i have a second to my
motion to ought to pass it's been
seconded by representative egan um on
the floor as a
as an amendment i'd introduced amendment
number two zero two two
zero zero two one h on house bill 1230
this amendment uh is
as we discussed it adds a date in the
future to allow efficient game time to
um
so i move amen i move that amendment is
there a second to that
second by representative egan
so the most the motion to adopt
amendment uh 12 30
on
has been made on the floor as the is
that motion so again go back to this
amendment
gives them time to implement and
secondarily it allows them the the
rulemaking authority to deal with the
issues around a new online registration
process and including an emergency
closure for certain zones necessary if
they need if they deem it necessary to
collect biological data
data not er that's a new england thing
um
all right representative
one clarifying question um
i think this is allowed an executive
session given there was no testimony on
your amendment we'll presume that
fishing game is a comfortable not only
with the bill but with the amendment
i think if you look at the written uh
written uh presented by fischer gaines
in the last line in support of
1233 fn as amended i did not see that i
did not get that i apologize nope it's
okay thank you sir any further
discussion
seeing none we're voting on the adoption
and we're going to just do this by a
show of hands i don't need a roll call
vote for an amendment
all those in favor of adopting the
amendment signify by raising your hand
those opposed
unanimous
so the new motion on the floor is ought
to pass as amended is there any further
discussion on the bill on ought to pass
seeing none the clerk shall call the
rule
ought to pass his amendment on with
i'm going to
see if this uh this will work
i hope i got the right names
representative close
representative spelaine
representative craig
representative johnson yes
yes
representative smith yes
representative horrigan
yes
representative laflamme yeah
representative jack yes
representative king
yes the clerk votes yes representative
egan yeah
repres oh sorry
um
and no one is still here for
representative shirtless am i correct
representative sherlock is here
representative ellis
and representative oxel
and mr chair
chair votes yes
the vote is 20 to zero out to pass as
amended
the vote being 20 to zero without
objection only go on consent
by the way fishing game if you mentioned
i was hoping we'd get through a fish and
game committee meeting without the word
covid coming up
um
all right next up is
hike safe cars jim
here's 12 23 and you can fill out the
car
next up is house
house bill uh
1323 roll of the hike safeguards and the
chair recognized representative spelaine
for the introduction and testimony about
if anybody wants to testify in this bill
please make sure we have a pink card
and give it to the clerk so she can get
thank you mr chair and members of the
distinguished committee
um
i brought this bill forward because of
uh some requests from constituents
this is there's an amendment that you'll
find to this which is uh zero zero four
seven h which essentially uh fixes some
issues that were with the original bill
um that were discovered by fish and game
this makes it an entirely enabling bill
it also removes the fee that's charged
from being in
rsa to be
set in rules by the director
so that the director may
increase or decrease that based on how
the program is going
and
allows for the director to
model this the same way as our licensing
is done so that there can be a resident
versus non-resident option in the fees
and gives them the possibility in the
future
of selling these hike safe cards at a
shorter duration um and i'll just throw
out one example i have a constituent who
gets a campsite up in the north country
all summer long they have extended
family come throughout the year and
their extended family would love to get
a hike safe card for the long weekend
while they're here but they don't want
to buy a whole season and so if the
director so chooses he may be able to
offer an option for a shorter duration
specific time period for a hike safe
card in the future but again this this
amendment makes it completely enabling
and
it just gives the director the ability
thank you everybody's planning questions
for representative splay representative
i have two different amendment documents
so i can just get a clarification on
which one applies i have a two i have a
two pager and a one pager the second
page the two pager has an amended
analysis as the second page
but the first page is the same
there should be a one-page document it
says amendment hb 1323 with uh
2022-0047 h i've realized what it is
it's someone doing
adequate clerical work making two pages
so we'll we'll discuss we'll discuss the
amendment uh if we go into exec session
for this if we decide or at the public
hearing if we decide this consensus on
this bill
any question further questions for
representative spelaine seeing none
thank you representative splain thank
you members of the committee chair
recognizes the distinguished colonel
jordan
thank you mr chair especially for the
distinguished part i don't think i've
ever been
that's a pretty impressive way to start
mine that means you're old so thank you
[Laughter]
yeah i know i know what the plan i do
have written testimony i would like to
good morning mr chairman and members of
the house fish and game committee i want
to start by thanking you for this
vigorous schedule and the willingness to
listen to all these bills this morning
and try to get through this
my name is kevin jordan i'm the current
chief of law enforcement new hampshire
fish and gang the new hampshire fish and
game commission prior to the amendment
voted unanimously to oppose this
legislation and the reason that they did
that
uh was back in for some of you that may
not remember back in
2015 we had made
for the past 20 years prior to that i
had made numerous attempts to find
better ways more substantial ways to
fund the search and rescue program the
cost of that program was climbing
dramatically and there was no funding
source available i came before this very
committee
hundreds of times it seems like looking
for better funding sources and you folks
all tried to help me get that
as a result of one of those bills 206 26
was changed a bit
to allow for
the hike safe car it was suggested that
we'd come up with a voluntary card and
we'd give hikers and and climbers
people that were not hunters of
fishermen an opportunity to to
contribute to the system if you will
and to and to
help us cover those costs those
exorbitant costs that we were
experiencing
uh history we average about 189 rescues
each year
the the cost of those rescues can run
into the the uh
hundreds of thousands of dollars we were
always short
uh quite frankly we ran a deficit at the
end of the year when we went out when we
drew from the account to pay our bills
for that for each year we were falling
short some 200 000 pretty regularly each
year we would then go into the fish and
game fund which was license fees
sportsman's dollars sports men and women
dollars and we would pull that money out
to balance out that account i always
felt that was unfair because the
sportsmen and women were footing the
entire bill for this
so the hike safe card we were hopeful
would take away some of that it in fact
has been probably one of the most
successful funding sources that we've
had at the agency so in 2015 it's it
brought us in 74 000 last year
2021 it brought in 336 000 so for the
first time in many many years
hike safe covered that deficit and that
i'm very happy about that we've climbed
every year 20 to 30 thousand dollars
in that program people like it they they
appreciate the opportunity to contribute
to it i've talked to
as you can imagine hundreds of people
and reporters regarding this because a
lot of other states are now calling us
to use it as a model to do in their
state i've never heard anyone ask for a
one-day hike safe pass they felt i've
had the opposite of that on numerous
occasions where people would would ask
that we charge more how can you do it
for 25
why isn't it more the idea of keeping it
low was so that we would encourage
people from all over
to buy it
uh i think you could price yourself out
of business quite frankly so i watch
this figure climb every year and i've
come to the realization of the or the
decision that it was a great
uh it is a great program the way it
works um to be honest with you i
appreciate the amen the amendment that
uh the sponsor uh representative splain
has brought today to enable it
but i still stand pretty firm that it
works and i don't want it messed with
it's a great program it's one of the
most successful ones we've had and i
don't want to see anything jeopardize
that we put the fee in the bill there
was a lot of discussion when we when we
set this bill up
with senator bradley and house members
who initiated this and helped us get it
through
and we felt that putting the fee in the
bill would protect people moving down
the road that it would have to go to the
legislature and give everybody an
opportunity to weigh in on it rather
than do it any other way and that's why
that fee was included
if someone i've had people call me over
the three-day weekend thing
non-residents are coming up and what i
suggested to them is we have
programs in existence now that you can
get this coverage
residents can buy a one-day fishing
license for ten dollars
so if you don't want to buy a 25 hike
safe car buy a one-day fishing license
be quite honest with you it's a better
deal because you can fish and hike
without any charge so non-residents can
buy a three-day fishing license at a
cost of 15
so these things can be met
these coverages can be met without
creating a new program and every time
that we go back to our online vendors
like we're going going to do for online
deer registration and we ask them for
program changes we pay exorbitant fees
for that uh in the twenties to thirty
thousand dollar range to set these
programs up and hike safe we work very
hard to keep those costs
the administrative costs at zero or near
zero so that the money could go directly
into fish and game so many times we get
legislated
into different processes and the
administrative cost kind of defeats the
purpose it ends up some of these
programs cost us more to operate than we
make on them hike safe that's another
place hike safe was successful on the
only fees that come out of the hike safe
money is the credit card fee when they
purchase it of 2.75
so 22 goes into the search and rescue
account and that's why it's been this
successful so i really don't want it to
change
we're very happy with it it's working
extremely well
and i don't want to see anything
jeopardize
the future of it not when you're jumping
from seventy five thousand dollars in
the first year to over three hundred
thousand so we also are meeting with our
partners amc the national forest with
our new director executive director uh
exploring ways now to advertise it
better to get some kiosks out
so that people have better access maybe
at our rest stops to try and increase
this but we're moving slowly because i
don't want it to go backwards it's been
very successful so
i'm pleading with you to leave a great
program completely alone that's what
needs to happen here so that's concludes
my testimony thanks for having me and i
will never forget that the chairman
called me distinguished this morning
when we started
i'm sure i'll call you other things
later
um so colonel i have a couple questions
for you colonel jordan if you don't mind
so have you had a chance to read the
amendment uh i did zero zero five last
night this morning yes
and i guess i'm looking for
understanding so my reading of this
amendment it becomes just enabling it
does language doesn't change anything it
allows the program that you could choose
not to do anything and leave the program
exactly identical or two years from now
this would this bill would enable you to
say hey we want to do something a little
bit different and it would allow you to
adopt that is that your understanding of
what the amendment does it is my only
concern with it i think if people see
that they're going to expect that we do
it is my concern so if they see in there
that we're able to now create a one-day
pass they would put pressure on us to
try and do that
and i don't i don't want to get in that
position i i feel like i could come back
here to do that if i needed to do that i
could come back to the legislature and
ask for the original uh law to be
amended the other problem that i have of
course as you understand i can't i
haven't had my commission voted on the
original bill they haven't seen the
amendment so i can't support it even if
i did support it
but to be honest with you
we prefer to leave it the way it is
thank you thank you
um
do you then you are against this bill or
you're for it i didn't understand i'm
sorry i we are opposed to this bill we
would like it to stand the way it is all
any further questions for colonel jordan
anybody else who wish to testify in
oh let me check my guards here
um seeing nobody else i'm gonna open up
for uh committee discussion um
yeah i i think you heard my summary at
the end i consider this enabling and
future proofing language in the bill
that allows the fish and game more
latitude to do what they want in the
future without coming running to the
legislature for a change that they need
desperately and then have to go through
a one-year legislative process or more
depending if the bill is retained so my
my inclination is to be clear as i i'd
like to be i like the bill as amended i
don't like the original bill i do like
the bill as amended because it future
proofs fish and game and allows them to
take things under their own control
rather than the legislative process
just understanding that anything they do
under their 541 authority they still
have to go to jail car and get approval
so it still has a legislative process
not just a law process so
um
that's my two cents uh let's happy to
listen to other members on the committee
to see if we have consensus to pass this
or kill this
representative
thank you mr chair one point that i
didn't hear discussed and
um i know there was a lot of discussion
over the one day or one week options but
there was not a lot of discussion over
the fact that we have the exact same
rate charged for residents and
non-residents and that's one of the
biggest beefs that i've heard from my
constituents is that they feel that
non-residents are the ones that tend to
need to be rescued more often they're
the ones who get lost more often and
that the residents should have a
discount or that the
non-residents should be charged extra
for this uh insurance that they buy
based on uh the same model that we use
for hunting and fishing licenses uh even
as you heard colonel jordan say that the
non-residents does pay more for the
fishing license if they opt to go the
fishing license route
so i think that this being completely
enabling now allows them to analyze
at any given point what the revenues are
and whether they need to increase or
decrease and whether they want to
separate out based on the number of
rescues coming from out of state versus
in-state
the
aspect of the insurance that's being
bought so that a non-resident
resident would be required to pay more
than a resident
if that's indeed what they find in their
data
we sell it like insurance but we're not
using any kind of actuary table to say
who are the more the people that are
more of a risk to the program and so i
think that enabling this allows them to
then look at their data and i would
really hope that everybody in here would
would agree that we can just enable fish
and game and let them go forward with
managing the program because it is one
of our most successful programs
further discussion representative khan
and then representative vegan
thank you mr chairman
mr chairman what i'm hearing from
colonel jordan
that
that the program is working very well
why to touch it you know uh
he's the one who implements all the laws
we create
we we are not the implementing uh body
and his uh testimony
tells us that he's just he's a strong no
it's not um
so
therefore i'm a little confused that how
i'm gonna vote i think that if this is
working why to touch it
thank you
sure and and i guess i'm gonna just
answer your question to a little bit
again i don't think we're changing the
program we're just giving options to the
program so the bro they could choose to
do nothing and leave the program exactly
identical as it is this bill requires
them doesn't require them to do anything
however it gives them the option in the
future to do something if they so choose
so i understand colonel jordan's concern
um again
my two senses i i think that this
doesn't change the program it just gives
options in the future
any uh representative you can go ahead
thank you mr chair
uh i have two points i'd like to make
one as a grafton two representative that
oversees franconia therefore franconia
state park uh this is a phenomenal
program that i do agree with colonel
jordan should not be uh adjusted i have
heard from a variety of my members uh
excuse me constituents who are also
members of the amino conservation
trust and the yamanuck
mountain club who
think that this program is running fine
as well as folks from search and rescue
in the region
fire police who volunteer on search and
rescue
and know the importance of the funds
that safe
hike safe brings as well i think colonel
jordan articulated that with a one day
ten dollar fishing
license and a three-day 15 fishing
license there is
affordability for folks that come from
out of state and visit for a day or two
and that as he said i think you can fish
and hike and be covered so i think
we do have a well run program that i
think
should stay as it is thank you sir
thank you representative
anybody else
representative craig
and then represents shirtless
if
i understand correctly
people can now currently buy a hike safe
card
at a trail head by scanning the qr codes
buy it instantly on the spot i don't
believe you can do that with a fishing
license
so um you can buy a fish and license
online i know because i did it this
summer to take my son fishing so you can
go online and buy efficiently it's not
quite as easy as just scanning the qr
code at the trailhead but you can buy
representative sherlock
thank you mr chairman i tend to agree
with the vice chair of the committee uh
i don't see the necess
necessary for this committee to pass
enabling legislation
uh fishing game or the public if they
feel something should be done they can
have a bill filed it will take care of
it
um to me it's somewhat like
coming up with a solution and now trying
to find a problem and i don't think from
what i heard from colonel jordan there
is a problem and so i'd be tending to
vote against it
thank you mr chairman thank you
seeing no further discussion the fact
that it doesn't sound like it's going to
be unanimous vote i'm going to just
close the exact exact session with no
action taken we'll take it up on the
25th to give people time to
uh represent wants to get more
information on his build and he can do
that and we'll take it up on the 25th
when we're back for work session and
exact session
representative spelaine thank you mr
chair uh may i ask that colonel jordan
bring this in the amendment in front of
the commission for an opinion before we
exec on the 25th
so with that exec sessions closed uh
public hearing and exec sessions closed
on house bill
1323 we're moving into house bill
uh 1201 relative to damage by bears and
i recognize the sponsor representative
turcotte
good morning mr chair good morning
members of the fish and game committee
my name is
representative len turcotte i represent
stratfor district 4
which is the town of barrington i'm here
to introduce and speak to house bill
1201 which would eliminate an
unnecessary rsa that was first placed on
the books in 1895.
we as representatives are always looking
for
ways to clean up the rsas
take out unneeded and outdated our
cities and i believe this is one of them
i first want to explain how i became
aware of such an obscure law
just a little under a year ago
speaker packard placed me on the finance
committee as one of the members was in
deteriorating deteriorating health
and one of the very first things i had
to look at was
that we had in committee on finance too
was a change that governor sununu had
sent over regarding
damage by bears and mountain lions again
in hb2
so i looked at that and i said what in
the heck is damaged by mountain lions
so the change
in the rsa they were looking to do was
uh they would
i guess you could say tighten up the old
1895 law
but
as we are well aware you've heard the
term lipstick
lipstick on a pig
and that's what i saw this as nothing
more as they were trying to put lipstick
on a pig it was still going to be a pig
um
i did meet and or i did uh request data
and met with the executive director
mason on this and he was very
forthcoming with some data which i'll
there are two issues that i see with the
rsa
the first one is taxpayers should not be
subsidizing
or providing insurance for damage by
bears
i'll get into towards the end it's more
of a non
maybe for this committee but
actually raised the hackles on the back
of my neck when i started digging into
some of the data
so why
why are we using taxpayer dollars to
ensure a select group of farmers against
crop damage
now we do not and we should not pay
damage for other types of damage by
wildlife as an example
i used to own many hundred christmas
trees and every year i would lose a
significant not a significant but a
great number of trees to deer for some
reason they liked uh we have a lot of
deer on our property and we lose
christmas trees every year i had no
recourse to go to the state and ask for
taxpayer money to pay for the damage to
my trees
um
livestock or other farm animals killed
by coyotes fisher cats or whatever
there's no recourse for that and there
shouldn't be
um if a deer or moose
crosses in front of my car
and my car is damaged i don't go to the
state and say you owe me for the car
damage because it was a moose
or a deer from
from the state no we have auto insurance
the vast majority of the farmers in this
state they accept damage to their crops
as being part of the business risk and
and have not submitted claims in fact i
have spoken to
at least one farmer who has had some
bear damage but didn't
uh file claim and like i say the vast
uh when i spoke with the executive
director scott mason uh one of the
issues we brought up was insurance for
crop damage and i asked if insurance was
in fact available for it he said yes
however it's very expensive
okay
taxpayers should not be the backstop for
those who fail to have insurance or
in the discussion with the farmer i
mentioned earlier uh he suggested that
here's something i would suggest if the
farmers as a whole believe
this is needed then i would suggest that
the farmers form and contribute money to
a pool
or cooperative one that all farmers are
required to fund
now my guess is those farmers
who do not have baron damage or who have
never claimed uh compensation for that
damage would be pretty opposed to having
being forced to contribute money money
into a pool that would pay for a handful
of farmers who
money for damage by bear
and just as farmers do not would not
probably want to do this type of an
arrangement
taxpayers shouldn't be on the hook to do
this
the other issue
which
is part of this
in a way
i became a little curious as to how many
farmers and how much money was actually
being paid out on this so i sent
executive direct director mason a
request for data and he he promptly sent
it to me he sent data going back about
what i did was i started entering this
spreadsheet
and as i started to do this
the first time i did it i i set up some
parameters where all right
farmers who claimed it now this the data
i had again was only over an eight year
period it only went back eight years so
i can't speak to prior to that
um as i started developing these
spreadsheets what i found
was
the first spreadsheet i did is i put
only those over an x amount of money
claimed
and those doing it say more than twice
in those eight year periods
then i fine-tuned the spreadsheet i
dropped it i raised the amount of money
and increased the number of frequencies
of claims
what became very
apparent very quickly
is over the eight year period
there were three individuals in the
state
who every year during that eight year
period
claimed a significant
amount of money from the state and the
taxpayers now again my guess is if i was
good to go back beyond those eight years
i might find that those same individuals
were consistently claiming now there
were other individuals that claimed a
few times
but
over that eight year period the the
winner in that category claimed over
thirty three thousand dollars
my question is why weren't efforts made
to mitigate the claims and why is every
year
those individuals coming to the
taxpayers
so again
we know that insurance is available but
individuals
in my opinion have used the state
taxpayers as their backup
um
i'm not going to talk about that
all right so inclu in conclusion the
scheme on new hampshire's overall but in
the scheme of things the overall amount
of money here being paid out annually
it's not going to break the bank
but what it comes down to is the
principle taxpayers in effect are
funding insurance against crop damage
for
really a select few picking winners and
losers
and the majority of farmers assume the
risk of damage as part of their business
which they should
we have an outdated rsa that requires
removal not updating
and though secondary to the primary
issue there is an apparent repetitive
repetitive abuse
by a select few that i believe looks
deserves further looking into and with
that i'll take any questions
thank you representative any questions
representative turcotte
thank you very much mr chair thank you
thank you to my fellow rep from from
stratfor county
um
bear somewhat different from the other
games
species insofar as they're actually
potentially dangerous to humans more so
and
when you this build doesn't just
so when you eliminate this 207 23a
you're also taking away a chapter from
uh
2207 222 a which
says um
they
unless you take uh take steps to
mitigate conflicts between humans and
bears on your property you you're only
eligible to one payment for damage so um
will we be losing something in public
safety without this incentive for
[Music]
farmers and
other residents
to
do what they have to do to uh
make their property less attractive to
bears and reduce the number of uh bare
human interactions
i'm not quite sure i'm understanding
your question are you
remember
you're striking uh some language that
says any person receive payment pursuant
to this rsa do you want to eliminate
shall forfeit the right to receive
payment in a future year or growing
season unless such person implements
measures to prevent or mitigate future
conflicts and barriers that have been
recommended in
writing by the uh executive director or
agent of fish and games so correct
so it seems like these payments are
an incentive
to the farmer to you know take
various measures which most of which are
common sense but not everybody does such
as securing your garbage and so forth um
in order to
i'm still a little fuzzy on the question
uh yes it does
say that they should take care of
mitigating factors and they basically
say if they
claim it one year
um yeah they have to mitigate it the
following year is that which yeah so is
that
so
there may
so uh that seems like
it seems like a potentially good policy
role sort of telling the farmer you know
like so the executive i assume fish and
game will come over questions mr horgan
thank you okay i just thought okay
that's pretty much uh
thank you mr chairman and thank you
the
paragraph
the previous representative was
referring to
is completely struck from your bill
as introduced that's correct
um
i guess i have to ask you
why you would oppose
payments
if somebody has
it basically goes back to the very
beginning i don't believe the taxpayers
under any circumstance should be paying
insurance or
covering the cost of a business risk
any further representative johnson
yes thank you for taking my question and
bear with me
so
based on what you had given us about the
data you collected
you said that there were three people
over this eight eight year period that
two of the individuals claimed every
single year
in the eight years of data i got one
individual there was one
in the middle of that eight year spread
there was no data for that so i don't
i'm not sure if he did or did not but at
least seven out of the eight
and then there were several other
individuals that claimed multiple times
okay so
[Music]
then what you're saying is
sorry follow up
so what you're saying is these
individuals still did not do whatever
they could
to mitigate the bearer issue and still
made claims
is that what i'm getting
that would be my assumption okay so the
taxpayers have paid sorry follow-up so
the taxpayers have paid for this and
they still have not done what they
should be doing based on the rsa
that would be my interpretation okay
just want to make sure i understood that
this is all new to me on some of these
so representative johnson just to be
clear because i want to make sure i
heard a little misstatement in there so
i want to be clear
that
my understanding of this program fish
and game would recommend the mitigating
mitigating factors here's what you need
to do if you want to get the pavement
again if they don't do that then they're
not entitled to payment again that's the
way the current law is written
and that's correct um thank you
i would say on that paragraph
um
it basically would in my opinion would
give the farmer
one final chance
to get it correct otherwise he would no
longer be
eligible i would also say that by
eliminating the rsa right now they're
getting that that same notice that
mitigate or you won't be getting payment
in the future
any further questions
seeing none thank you representative
turcotte
next up is the department dan bergeron
good morning chairman lang members of
the house fish and game and marine
resources committee um thank you for
allowing me to testify before you today
um so i'm testifying on behalf of the
department and the commission
who who are looking to oppose this bill
um i'll go through my testimony and i
might be able to clarify some of the
so the barrett damage compensation
payments um are not
unique to new hampshire um so there's a
number of other states that have similar
programs
for example pennsylvania maryland
delaware
west virginia wisconsin
some canadian provinces as well the the
intent of this bill
is to
is to be able to compensate farmers but
also to promote the value of bears on
the landscape and also foster an
appreciation and tolerance towards bears
bears are a very valuable resource in
the state of new hampshire
to both consumptive and non-consumptive
users in 2021 alone bear license sales
generated over 240 000 for the
department
and that money goes towards directly
towards fair management research
but also
it goes to a conflict abatement program
that department runs that specifically
addresses
bear conflicts including agricultural
conflicts
it's recognized however that bears do
have the ability to cause damage
and and sometimes that damage can be
severe and as a result oftentimes
people's tolerance
and understanding of bear behavior can
but the department feels this program is
critical in offsetting losses to
agricultural growers and safeguarding
the state's bear population
so removal of the program would likely
result in a few things it would likely
result in agricultural growers using
more lethal removal of bears because
there's a current rsa that allows
individuals to protect their property so
without the damage payments it's likely
that that would increase quite a bit
it would also likely create conflict
between growers in the department
and and cause bears to become devalued
the end result would likely be no
significant changes in damage to crops
dead and wasted bears because bears that
are typically bears that are taken and
as a result of conflict are not utilized
particularly depending on the time of
year that that happens
and again strained relationships between
landowners in the department
the current rsa
as was mentioned was previously amended
this was in an effort to keep it more
consistent with the original intent
which was to provide financial relief to
agricultural growers
who are dependent on this for their
livelihood
the department had seen an increasing
trend in what we'd call hobby farmers uh
that we're submitting claims so people
that might have a few backyard chickens
and beehives
things like that we had concerns that
that would erode the intent of what the
original rsa was
um
and and as was mentioned with those
amendments we established some
thresholds
certain income levels that farmers had
to receive from their agricultural crops
and also certain levels of damage that
had to be
met
bear damage that had to be met before we
would consider payment and before you
would qualify
so this program um with these amendments
that took place and i think it was 2021
so this is all relatively new our our
feeling is that this should reduce the
amount of those payments um
the other concern would be if we got rid
of this program it would make it more
difficult for the department to work
with agricultural growers
to to try and recommend some of these
um
so bear damage payments uh they vary
considerably on an annual basis
although on average years they typically
range between 15 and 20 000 a year
statewide that we're paying out for bear
damage
the bulk of those payments goes towards
corn
and then to a much lesser extent to
beehives and then also livestock but
but livestock and bee hive payments
typically average around two to three
thousand dollars a year so the bulk of
this is for corn damage
um
there was some discussion about
differences between how we deal with
damage by different species
bears probably
at least on an individual crop
cause very substantial damage we have
other programs
to mitigate damage for deer we have
depredation permits that can be used for
deer and other species we also have
those for bear and we do issue those
but but to somewhat of a lesser extent
so so we believe this program it
provides incentives
for landowners
to work with us to try some of these
mitigation efforts it's also
it's very easy to protect bee hives
or or livestock typically they're in
confined spaces you can electrify those
areas
it's very difficult to protect acres and
acres of corn fields so
typically the people that we see that
get these payments on an annual basis
you know there's there's not a lot of
agricultural industry in the state of
new hampshire there's a select few
people and there's there's even a
smaller amount of people that have large
agricultural
operations and those are typically the
people that we get payments made out to
on an annual basis
because there's very little mitigation
that they can do to completely protect
those crops
one final benefit of this compensation
program
is that to take part in it the land has
to be open to hunting
so this is an incentive for agricultural
growers to keep their land open hunting
and hunting is our is by far our best
ability to manage the bear population
and really appropriate management of the
population should help reduce
these these damages going forward
and also bears that are taken during the
hunting season typically get utilized as
opposed to bears that are taking as a
result of conflict
so the department feels that the current
compensation program is working well
it provides a good compromise to
accommodate agricultural growers
who depend on crops for their livelihood
but it also helps safeguard the state's
bear population
so in closing i'd like to thank the
chairman and members of the committee
and i would request that the committee
[Music]
yes thank you very much mr chairman
what i'd like to find out is i go up
north quite a bit and upstairs i don't
know how you folks are but
the beer probably population up there is
booming
and
fishing game is bringing up bears that
trap
in the southern part of the state
they're bringing them up north and
they're releasing up in
columbia colebrook
west stewartstown pittsburgh
these people are really upset about it i
went to a meeting at the restaurant up
there in colebrook and there's about 30
people they're really upset the way
they're bringing the bears up north and
releasing them up north what are we
going to do about that
yeah so
um we we so
conflict bears
typically we do not relocate anymore we
we used to relocate conflict bears
we do have a bear rehabilitation program
and some of those bears do get moved but
we have started to disperse those
throughout the state more
as we as we get more um bears that we
relocate typically um travel pretty far
from where we relocate them because they
need to find their own home range
bears are fairly territorial so
we've done studies in the past on bears
that have been relocated
they they tend to move fairly far
distances and they do not tend to become
any more
prone to conflict than any other bears
in the area so we based on research on
collared animals that we've done we
don't see any
correlation between moving animals
and increases in conflict
that said we have we have tried to
reduce the number of bears that we
relocate and typically it's only the
rehabilitated bears that were moving at
this point
we found it's it's not very successful
to try and move conflict animals around
because
um
survival is not very good if it's an
animal that has a history of conflict
that sometimes that conflict just picks
back up so the
by and large the animals that we move
now are animals that have no conflict
history they were orphaned as a cub and
follow-up guide i'm sorry
thank you
well you said research who's doing the
research on this beer program
um so it varies so
a lot of the research is done by the
department typically what we do is we
work in cooperation with the university
of new hampshire
it's been a number of years since our
last cooperative research project with
the university of new hampshire but
you know we we tag all of the
rehabilitated bears that are released
and track where those bears end up
turning up whether it's in harvest or um
roadkill so any bear that is any bear
that is that that dies in the state that
we can get our hands on we get
information from
whether it's through harvest or vehicle
collisions through
you know found found out on the road
anything so we have we got good
representative khan
thank you mr chairman
thank you mr dan for taking my question
uh the prime sponsor's testimony was
that two or three property owners
abusing this program and getting the
taxpayers money almost every year
can you address that for the you know
committee please yeah so it it it is
true that there are probably a number of
individuals who who get these payments
on an on an annual basis
but again that that deals more with the
limited scope of agricultural
um
agriculture on the landscape so there's
a there's a very few number of
individuals that have large scale
operations that that tend to be prone to
damage by wildlife
and including bears
i i wouldn't characterize it as taking
advantage of the program
um because we every
every damage claim we have we have on
staff a wildlife damage biologist who
goes out and reviews all these claims
and measures the damage
and then and then calculates a
compensation amount
and you know we distinguish between
damage
by bears other wildlife stuff that may
have just been
damaged by wind or the process of you
know
taking the crops out so
we have a specialist that goes and
calculates the actual amount of damage
that's done by bears so i i wouldn't
characterize it as as taking advantage
i'm sorry just i'm going to do a quick
follow-up to that question
just keep it on track
but that same person do they offer
mitigating strategies if there are some
and then the person would be obliged the
farmer would be obligated to follow
those and before they could do another
claim yeah yeah so that person would um
and and again that's a relatively new
part of this because again that
amendment was just made in 2021 so
we haven't but but we've historically
we've always recommended mitigation
techniques
when available even before that was on
the books
this puts a little bit more
this requires them to do it now you know
typically we would work through
cooperative agreements with people um
and and again when possible
we always let people know that the best
thing to do is mitigation because it's
your best long-term solution
because you know wildlife moves around
if you remove a bear from an area one
year it could be a short period of time
before there's more bears in the area or
other wildlife species so
um
so i think that answers thank you that's
my question
uh
representative
thank you mr chairman i have one
question for mr bergeron perhaps perhaps
a follow-up as well
um
in your testimony you say that the sale
of beer hunting
bear hunting licenses
generate approximately 242 thousand
dollars
and some of that's used for management
research
as well as a conflict abatement program
does that include any compensation
that that does not include compensation
so what that program is is we hire what
are called bear technicians
and those people are hired typically
during the busiest times when we have
bear conflict so
spring summer and early fall
and those individuals
respond directly to any bear conflicts
you know it it can be agricultural
related um typically our wildlife damage
specialist deals with the agricultural
work but sometimes our bear techs will
assist with that as well um but you know
it's bears getting into dumpsters it's
bears at
bird feeders and chicken coops
and really it's a it's it's someone who
goes out we can lend equipment to people
we can lend electric fencing we also
work cooperatively with usda wildlife
services who also hires bear technicians
um to assist with these things
throughout the state so we do
substantial mitigation work with bears
throughout the course of the year um and
and that is funded through those license
sales
um
none of that money goes to damage
reimbursement payments though
thank you um i no longer have a
follow-up okay
uh representative love you're recognized
for a question and if necessary one
follow up
does the department uh keep a list of um
farms that uh that could be readily
available to hunters in order to to to
keep the beer population down in these
problem areas
yeah so we we don't keep a list um it's
sometimes it's difficult to do that
because there's privacy issues with with
sending out information
um typically
particularly with the farms that
experience damage on a routine basis
there's i i think most of those farmers
have plenty of people they know that are
willing to hunt the property
and and we can
another thing that we do is we work with
houndsmen for example um sometimes to to
try and haze bears out of certain areas
so um we can put people in touch we
don't necessarily keep a list and again
that's largely due to privacy issues
with giving out personal information
thank you
representative smith you're recognized
for a question and one follow-up if
necessary thank you mr chairman i just
want to back up to your comment that
most damage is due to corn damage
i would imagine the mitigation efforts
on a 50-acre cornfield would be quite
difficult
i.e you can't use an electric fence for
that what mitigation efforts are
successful to ensure that this damage
doesn't continue year after year
possibly to ensure that the same people
aren't coming back for compensation
yeah so it is very difficult the larger
the operation the more difficult the
mitigation becomes um
um in part that's why it's beneficial to
have that um the requirement where they
have to keep their land open to hunting
you could certainly have situations
particularly if you're out working in
the fields a lot that agricultural
growers might decide to keep their land
posted to hunting
so one of the good mitigation efforts is
to keep that land open to hunting
to try and reduce the population in the
representative spelling for a question
and potential follow-up if you need it
thank you mr chair thank you mr bergeron
for taking my question what is the
current population of bear in the state
oh
i don't know off the top of my head i
can i can get that for i could have that
emailed to you by the end of the day i
don't know off the top of my head what
what i warn people about with population
estimates though
is
people are always interested in a number
and the thing to keep in mind is that
estimates are based off of a lot of
assumptions
typically assumptions that we violate
here and there so
when we use population estimates it's
more as an index as opposed to assuming
that we actually know the number of
animals on the landscape so
even when so a lot of species we don't
even estimate the population number we
look for
different indices to track change in the
population so
bear we do estimate a number
but i just i just hazard that you have
to take that with a grain of salt
because it's very difficult to predict
population numbers of free-ranging
animals
my follow-up to that thank you mr chair
would be
would you say that the number for bear
is
more than our population for moose but
less than our population for deer
and as such we tend to protect those
bear from
having to resort to the depredation
option
more
than deer
that's probably so in terms of in terms
of population numbers that's probably an
accurate assessment um
the
um
we have so the bear population has
increased over time and as that has
taken place we we have become
uh more
willing and and uh and and issue
depredation permits for bears much more
frequently now we actually um
in
i think it was 20 20 well the last time
we did administrative rules which i
think was 2021. um we changed our
administrative rules for depredation
permits on bears
um
to make them more similar to deer where
people who use those can utilize that
animal before the animal it would made
it very difficult to utilize it so
that's one of the things we did to try
and increase the number of people who
might use those and to make sure that
the animals get utilized
thank you
any other member
go to second round representative khan
you have a second question guide
thank you mr chairman
mr dan do you believe that the property
owners where the property damage is
happening they can buy the
individual insurance to subsidy you know
in individual insurance to
support their damages so the taxpayer
don't have to subsidize this program
um that i i don't feel like i'm
qualified to speak to
yeah i'm not sure what the i'm not sure
what the costs of those insurance
programs are so i wouldn't feel
comfortable giving a
any further questions from the committee
seeing none thank you rep thank you mr
persuade thank you
next up on house bill 1201 is john
robert johnson from the new hampshire
thank you mr chair and members of the
committee for the record my name is rob
johnson and i am here representing the
new hampshire farm bureau as a
federation's policy director
farm bureau consists of just under 2 000
family memberships and another thousand
or so
memberships business supporting members
such as that
and we are i am here in opposition to
the bill and i want to make it clear to
the committee that we do not see it as
unnecessary
outdated and it's certainly not obscure
to those that are affected and it is not
insurance
the state is paying for damage
damage that has been put on farmers by
the state's wildlife
and i think representative splain his
last question there touched on why
i want to go back a little bit um
back in the fall of 2000 we were
approached by
the uh by fish and game by the by the by
director mason
uh and we have and also by the
governor's office
they had evidently received a claim that
they questioned it was a non-commercial
claim and i thought that the law needed
to be tightened up
and we understood where they were coming
from so we again we got together with
director mason at the time it was the
wildlife division director scott
ellingwood a couple people from the
governor's office and the commissioner
of agriculture and we sat down and we
hammered out the uh law that was adopted
by you as part of house bill 2. to put
some sideboards on the existing statute
which we agreed to
it's still
included and some of this has been
mentioned previously but it removed the
remove the mountain lion piece the
mountain lions i think usually we're not
recognized by that by by the department
it also uh defined farmer and it follows
the federal definition which is which is
a a thousand dollars in sales of
agricultural agricultural products a
year or normally in cases of crop
failure
it also define products as in line with
the state definition of agricultural
products in 2134-a
it's stipulated that damage must be a
minimum of 250 dollars at wholesale
value
and we and we were the ones that
suggested it that there probably should
be some mitigation measures uh that are
were required within the statute
and and that was signed into law and
that's what we're dealing with so as far
as the mitigation piece and uh
representative johnson you asked the
question earlier that that it still was
just signed into law beginning of this
year so what that hasn't been
is it will be effective starting now
um
with with
you know with those sideboards we we we
think it was it's uh
for those that are affected it's it it's
a it's a necessary statute um
i've had over the years a couple of
farmers and you mentioned i was
mentioning here that there are three
farms that have had to have received
payments regularly a lot of reasons for
that i'm sure you know the the bear are
they're they're bright they know where
the feed is
that's part of it uh there's it's just
that area is suitable for that habitat
um
most farmers this has been do not do not
put in for payments i i've had that i'm
remembering uh two farmers in recent
years
uh that have come to me and we've talked
about the issue and uh one of them
recently said to me that they had
significant damage i mean if you haven't
if you take a i've seen pictures of an
aerial view of a cornfield and the
bearer are smart they don't damage
starting on the outside they go right to
the middle and they find a spot and it's
it's amazing it's like a huge spaceship
has landed
and it's just destruction
all around
and and and um anyway
the uh
one farmer said to me that
this is the he had been farming for
30 years and said this is the first year
that i had submitted a claim
and part of it was because milk prices
were low and the damage was significant
enough that it really affected him
and he had he had received damage yearly
up to that point and i had an again i
remember another farmer a few years back
who had said to me same thing you know i
i'd never have have put in for damage
but boy
i i had to this year it just got to be
to the point where it was affecting my
bottom line
so
it's it's not it's it's
most in most cases unless a farmer needs
it they're not putting in florida and i
want to stress again it is not insurance
it's actual damage to a commercial
producer who is feeding the state's
wildlife
mr chair i think i uh
i think i'll leave it at that i'll try
to answer any questions but great thank
you mr johnson any questions for mr
seeing none thank you very much and
thank you for your members for keeping
uh last speaker on this bill is curt and
kurt i always going to mess up your last
name from the
humane society of the united states you
can
kurt
thank you
thank you mr chairman
state director of the humane society of
the united states
we are here to
oppose this bill
bear damage payments cost our state
taxpayers an average of 27
400 but can be as much as eighty one
thousand dollars annually especially if
farmers and livestock producers have not
taken common sense steps to avoid
attracting black bears in the first
place
while we are all concerned by this
annual cost this bill could
inadvertently incentivize the illegal
killing of black bears a species beloved
by most new hampshire residents
allowing this bill as written to pass
will impose other societal costs
new hampshire fish and game department
would have to execute more law
enforcement actions which in turn
burdens our judicial system probably at
cost that would far exceed the amount
now paid in damage payments
the humane society united states would
like to suggest a friendly amendment to
the bill
because many conflicts with bears can be
minimized with preventive action we
propose limiting damage payments only to
those who have taken steps to mitigate
attracting black bears in the first
place
examples of these steps include using
electric fence around orchards beehives
and chicken coops and employing bear
resistant trash receptacles
a looming issue here that has not been
addressed is the state's wildlife
department permits hunters to bait
bait black bears
baiting wildlife comes with myriad
problems
including the poisoning of animals
creating sites where disease such as
mange or rabies can spread between
individuals and setting up small bears
for predation
most importantly baiting black bears
exponentially grows their population
beyond the land's carrying capacity
and habituates them to people
ending all wildlife baiting in new
hampshire would be a great first step in
mitigating black bear conflicts in new
hampshire
and we call upon lawmakers in the new
hampshire fish and game department to
stop the practice of baiting wildlife
it flies in the face of everything the
agency teaches people in their bear
aware efforts
such as the recommendation to take down
bird feeders between april 1st and
december 1st
we respectfully ask that you consider
amending this bill as we suggest or vote
inexpedient to legislate in its current
form
thanks for your time
happy to take any questions
thank you kurt any questions for kurt
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
so i'm going to open this up for a quick
discussion amongst committee members
that was the last speaker on that bill
um
i'll give the chairs perspective on this
i think we've heard
a significant amount of testimony about
the fact that this this keeps our new
hampshire land lands open for hunters
that the state regulates bears in that
absent this mitigation fund there's a
potential for farmers to start taking
bear out of season to protect their
crops as a mitigation factor rather than
take the uh
um rather than take the money so to
speak right so they can affect our our
herd i'm a little concerned about you
know again in the early spring planting
sows with with cubs and and
with absent the fun them taking you know
acting earlier and taking the bear
um so my but i also
response of the representatives close
comment about the
um
movement affair from the southern end of
the state to the northern the state are
moving bare into population areas that
are less wild which and open which are
by definition probably agricultural
areas um and we're
we're propagating the damage by by our
actions so my inclination on this bill
would be an interim study um and
so we could talk about the bill maybe
make some recommendations to a future
legislature legislator about uh
adding the mitigation factors and
talking about that give that time to
work and also to talk about
how this
repopulation or movement of bears are
around so again the chairs idea would be
to interim study this bill i'm open for
discussion to see if that's a consensus
of the committee
and we can go from there
anybody wants representative spelling
thank you mr chair i think interim study
is actually uh a good way to go forward
with this because i also like the idea
that that
an amendment that i would consider a
friendly one to the farm bureau would be
to
make the first visit by a wildlife
conservation officer to inspect damage
be one to request and require mitigation
and then if the person does not follow
up with the mitigation if it's possible
we know that large corn crops can't be
but uh if they don't if they are given
mitigation that they refuse to follow
then they don't apply and and cannot get
the the payout i think it makes sense to
give them a first warning of hey you
know you could have avoided this
let's fix this
and then if the bear still comes now
they can apply for their their payment
and it it keeps a balance where we're
not predating those uh bears just to
keep the crops safe thank you
representative love
yeah mr chair thank you mr chair and uh
many members um you know my uh my
comment about having a a um a list of
of uh
problem farms uh would uh for me would
go a long way in this interim study um
you know if a farmer was that took the
money would would have to give out would
have to allow 10 people
or have his have his name put out there
for 10 people because baiting is a the
number way number one way of taking bear
uh i think if you've removed the baiting
from from bear hunting uh the the the
annual take could be uh cut in half
anyway you know baiting in dogs and um
you know if you have problems with
something you have to bear that's you
know that's smart for starters you know
but if you have the problems with bear
um you know we
we have to uh attract more hunters
because uh
if you if you put up a bait station
uh you know it's it's a at least a
weekly thing probably uh every couple
days you're you're back to re uh you
know restocking it and uh you know if
you if you live in derry and you and
you're hunting up uh you know up north
uh that you know a two-hour ride just to
go up and and rebate you know re-restock
your bait um you know we we can do
something with that thank you so it's
you're in support of interim study it
sounds like yes
representative
i too would uh support an interim study
uh right across the border my district
from monroe is lying in the killem's
bear center which is a nationally known
uh program and ben kellum is nationally
recognized and i think it would be good
to
either consult with him or um through
fish and game reach out to him in better
better understanding some of these
mitigation efforts and i do um applaud
the idea that the fish that the farm
bureau talks about in terms of i think
if i'm paraphrasing you sir um
maybe folks that
have done mitigation and still have
claims
can
have their claim be more seriously seen
because they are making an effort to try
and curtail the problem so i would
support an interim study
okay thank you
any further discussion
if not it sounds like we're in consensus
for an interim study so i'm going to
close the public hearing on house bill
1201 and open
uh executive session on house bill 1201
and i make a motion of interim study
second
there any further discussion on this
bill hearing none the clerk will call
all right
uh
sorry mr advice
mr vice chair yes
representative close
representative spelaine
representative howard
representative craig
representative kittredge yes
representative
yes there's too many mics on so mine
didn't work oh sorry i can
yes
the vote being twenty to 0 for interim
study
i'll put that on consent unless there's
an objection
seeing no objection will be put on
consent
next up is house bill 1081. uh just to
let members know we have at least seven
cards to speak on this bill
1091 i'm sorry uh rattle the search
warrants for individuals engaged in
fishing uh fish and game activities
representative spelaine will speak first
it looks like i'm going to have eight
cards because the distinguished colonel
jordan is going to bring me another card
so we do have eight speakers on this
bill
thank you mr chair and distinguished
members of the committee this is i think
my third attempt at bringing
closure to
what i consider a serious loophole
in new hampshire law
and in this attempt i have an amendment
that you will see um zero zero seven
four h
which even further restricts the areas
where a search warrant would be needed
versus those areas where fish and game
can do their job without a warrant
the problem that we have and have always
had here is that there's a
simple line in our rsa that says fish
and game doesn't need a warrant at all
ever
many years ago we gave fish and game the
ability to conduct normal police
activities including traffic stops and
such and we never removed that
so my fear especially with the drug
problem getting ever more
critical in the state is that a vehicle
will be pulled over on 93 somewhere up
north fish and game will pop the trunk
find a pound of fentanyl and that
becomes fruit of the poisonous tree it
may not be then
investigated by any other law
enforcement division they turn it over
to it ends up getting thrown out and we
have to let criminals go free heaven
forbid that they pop the trunk and find
a body or evidence of child molestation
or some other
thing
it's more likely that they'll find drugs
but that being said
i would like to close the loophole that
allows fish and game to conduct all of
their activities without a warrant
but still allow them to conduct all of
their fish and game activities
with their
reasonable and articulable
suspicion and no warrant
so my amendment
further
states and brings to even further
definition that if they have reasonable
and articulable suspicion that a person
is coming to going to or coming from or
actively participating in or has any
kind of uh game animal in their
possession that they don't need a
warrant but barring those circumstances
i.e they pull over somebody in a
business suit on 93
that has no hunting paraphernalia and
was not hunting they need a warrant
this would put them in line with all of
our other law enforcement divisions in
the state which all require a warrant
and it would ensure that we are
protecting the people of new hampshire
from a drug dealer who may be trying to
bring things in or worse a murderer or
child molester or some such
and it also protects the fourth
amendment rights of the people who are
traveling on our highways
etc
and with that i'll take any questions
i've done
quite a lot of re-drafting on the
amendment so it is essentially a
complete replacement that spells out in
detail
when a warrant is not necessary for them
and for what types of activities and and
gear and vehicles
thank you represent questions
representative spelaine we'll start with
representative laflamme then we'll go to
representative close you're recognized
for a question and one follow-up thank
you mr chairman
thank you representative spelling for
taking a question
in reference you reference stopping cars
on interstate 93.
current law does current law require
that the conservation officer have
reasonable and articulable suspicion
that a violation has taken place of
efficient game law before they can
just open someone's trunk
not the way we changed it to allow them
to
uphold all of our traffic laws and
conduct regular police activities that
was passed some 10 years ago because the
north country said we don't have enough
police officers around and we'd love
fish and game to be able to stop a drunk
driver if they see one so we expanded
their police abilities to include them
to stop people who are not engaged in
fish and game activities
and this is where i have the concern
when they're engaged in fish and game
activities
i don't have any problem with the
reasonable and articulable suspicion as
the bar or them searching without a
warrant because that person
is engaged in hunting and fishing or has
been engaged or is carrying game in
their vehicle
but if they're stopping somebody who's a
drunk driver or such and they do things
without a warrant it can jeopardize the
case for any other law enforcement
division or the courts when they take it
over
thank you for clarifying that i have no
follow-up
represent representative close
yes
you know i'm getting really confused
here
a fish and game officer has full police
powers we shouldn't be making deals that
he can do this he can't do that he can't
do this
police powers are governed very strict
when this committee
10 years ago we accepted
fish and game to have police powers
it was understood they would have full
police powers
as a police officer 27 years you need
more than just a you need probable cause
to stop somebody to begin with
and just because suspicion doesn't give
you the right
to go into somebody's car you need
probable cause
i've been involved in one of the biggest
cases in manchester on probable cause
when i locked up all the politicians who
want four and i went to the supreme
court and that was on probable cause
not suspicion and that was brought out
so what i i would say
leave it alone
the police department
well the ceos have the police powers
they don't need nothing else and they've
been doing a pretty good job compared to
the old police officers that we have all
those questions
i'll get there is there a question in
there somewhere please
a question for representative spelaine
what's your question for him
okay thank you so much since that was
sort of a question mr chair may i
respond to that
i'm not sure what the question was so no
um
representative howard
thank you mr chair
thank you for taking my question
um
the line says any
illegal apparatus subject to forfeiture
what would an illegal apparatus
be is there a definition in this statute
as to what a illegal apparatus is
i will have to defer that to fish and
game to answer what their list of
illegal apparatus are
but i could tell you that it is illegal
to hunt with certain types of uh
equipment and in fact we've got some
fishing regulations that don't allow
certain jigs so i would imagine that if
you were in possession of a specific jig
used for fishing that was outlawed for
fishing that that would be an illegal
apparatus um i imagine that if it was a
um
you have arrows that are tipped with a
broadhead that is not sanctioned as one
of the ones that's allowed that would be
an illegal apparatus but i'll leave that
to fish and game to answer more fully
okay thank you
representative love and then
representative sherliff wraps them close
can you guys turn your mics off so we
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question um as i read this i it seems
to me that it's um
it's just drawing a line between the the
duties uh when uh when a conservation
officer is is performing fish and game
duties uh the there's
does uh you know the the the problem
what is the reasonable suspicion is is
the rule and uh if they're doing regular
law enforcement uh probable cause and
it's just drawing that line and clearly
defining it would that be right that is
my intent and this entirely is to make a
delineation between when they are
conducting hunting and fishing
enforcement versus when they are doing
regular law enforcement duties
thank you
representative sherlock thank you mr
chairman thank you representative
uh representative um you mentioned about
this
idea of an illegal search and seizure by
a fish and game officer
can you give us one an example of a case
being thrown out of superior court or
any court in new hampshire because of an
illegal search and seizure by a fish and
game officer
i do not have any information on that
right now what i'm hoping is to prevent
one from happening as we get more and
more drugs flooding in i think it's just
inevitable that one of the stops on the
highway
ends up being one where we have to throw
evidence out
follow
up wouldn't it be true if a conservation
officer was searching a vehicle because
of a fishing game violation and came
across some other criminal act that
would be a legal search and seizure
uh them performing a search as part of
their duties and finding another element
of a crime
yes
further questions
i have one point jim i'm sorry was there
somebody else over there
representative oregon go ahead
um thank you very much mr chair and
thank you mr representative spelaine
um i don't know if you
maybe probably possibly don't even
answer this but this appears at both uh
this
your proposal and i guess the existing
law as well also
seems to
uh
seems to treat
um
fish and game related activities that
such that uh require
usually typically require a gun or
similar weapons as a crossbow separately
from fishing so
would there be any value in giving them
more latitude
to fishing which doesn't involve a gun
i'm not sure i can answer that
thank you
i'll take my one question here so
the the section of law that you're
looking to amend isn't revolving around
my quest and i'll get to my question i
just want to set it up um
the section of law that you're you're
looking to amend to change the standard
deals with just their enforcement of and
i quote belief that any wildlife or any
legal apparatus is subject to forfeiture
is concealed upon or therein so it talks
specifically about enforcing
hunting and fishing laws and not any
other laws and any other laws that be
subject to the regular police powers and
the requirements of regular peace powers
is that accurate as as you read the law
as it sits right now
as it sits right now it is blurry to me
as to whether they are
stopping a vehicle in their capacity as
a law enforcement officer or stopping
that vehicle as part of a
conservation officer or duty
it it seems to blur the lines by
just stating flat out currently written
that
no fish and game officer will need a
warrant at all and they only need
reasonable and articulable
suspicion
if i may follow up some i want to make
sure i'm clear on this because under
those statute that you're amending it
talks specifically about
um
enforcement of fish and game laws
not dwi laws not
criminal not investigating a burglary or
stopping a robbery suspect or anything
like that we're talking strictly about
the fact that they would still need to
have reasonable and articulable
suspicion which is a pretty defined in
law enforcement statement that they have
to be able to put it in their report and
explain why
for fish and game purposes
they stopped a car or
searched somebody's creole or whatever
they were doing but it was only relative
to the fission game if that extends out
they would be subject to the regular
police powers laws and rules isn't that
not correct
i think the reason that this is blurred
is because it wasn't until the 10 years
ago that we gave them police powers but
we never
changed this area that talks about
conduct of a conservation officer so
what we've done is given them an
additional duty and responsibility
without saying that when they work under
these it still falls under this other
area
we have another area of law we've said
now fish and game officers may conduct
those stops but we haven't said but when
you do these things you need to have the
search warrant and you need to have
probable cause
we just said fish and game officers now
can do this and then their
behavior and governance for when they do
things is still spelled out here one
last question i promise i'll let you go
um jacking dear right so again
uh a law enforcement officer over 10
years experience not uncommon someone go
out and spotlight a field looking for a
deer with a gun in their car and yet the
mere spotlighting of a deer doesn't
create a law violation unless you search
and see they got a gun in the car and
they're planning on taking a deer yet
that would only be a reasonable
suspicion standard so are we going to
give up on trying to prosecute jacking
dear
no
because if they have it says in the
amendment that if they have a reasonable
suspicion that an animal
is uh concealed on the v in the vehicle
that any game animal is concealed or
that the vehicle was engaged in any kind
of hunting activity which jacking would
still be considered a hunting activity
that they do not need the the warrant
that's in the amendment um and i have
now the information you were talking
about it is section 20626 that gives all
of the uh police powers
to the conservation officer
and that section
doesn't specify
that i can see that they need
to follow all of the regular police
it does say they can execute search
warrants based on probable cause but it
doesn't say that they need to have that
or when they need to have that
thank you any other questions represent
thank you representative plain
thank you members of the committee
thank you mr chairman member members of
the committee i'm on representative
norman silber from bellamy county 2
which are the towns of guilford and
meredith
i'm not wearing a mask today because i
had covert a year ago recovered and i
have natural immunity
my concerns uh i'm in support of 1091 as
amended
my concerns have to do with
constitutional protections of our
citizens
the
the statute as written
basically undermines as i believe
undermine certain constitutional
protections that we've long assumed
exist
requiring warrants
based upon probable cause for searches
and seizures and for arrests
i have a handout of some excerpts from
the new hampshire constitution the bill
of rights the new hampshire rules of
criminal procedure and the u.s
constitution which basically
require warrants based upon probable
cause
the statute as it exists now
deals with
warrantless searches allows warrantless
searches based upon
reasonable suspicion rather than
probable cause a much lower standard
so it's to me this is a civil liberties
issue
we have four
major law enforcement agencies in the
state
we have our local police departments
we have our county sheriffs
we have our state police
and we have fish and game
there are of course other agencies that
do some law enforcement activities but
those four major ones the first three
local pd's
county
police are all governed by these
constitutional restrictions requiring
warrants based upon probable cause
fish and game under this statute as it
exists
is not subject to those things
my view is i i look back and you know
i've been a lawyer for a long time and
i've been a constitutional scholar for a
very long time
the requirements for
warrants based upon probable cause of a
long history in our country and and i
mean you know in the laws we inherited
from england as well
the 14th century
classical writer from italy
dante
in his
classical
work
on the dante's inferno
a
a sign above the door the gates of hell
it says abandon hope all ye who enter
here
under the existing law
it seems to me in fairness to our
citizens if we leave this law in place
without the amendment suggested by
representative spelaine
we should have a sign on our hunting
lands
it says abandon
your constitutional rights all ye who
enter here
so
i strongly suggest that 1091 as amended
be adopted and i'll answer any questions
i might ask i am not a
environmental or
i'm not a hunter
but i i know something about the
constitutions
any questions from the committee
representatives
uh thank you mr chairman um i'm just
curious as to why you prefer the bill
with the amendment uh maybe i'm
interpreting wrong but isn't it true
that the amendment actually broadens the
circumstances under which a warrant
i've only gotten the amendment just a
few moments ago and have not gone
through a detailed analysis of it
basically
i want to replace i want to see a bill
that replaces reasonable suspicion with
probable cause and warrantless searches
with a requirement for warrants if the
amendment does
dilutes that standard then i wouldn't be
for the amendment before the bill is
proposed
basically i want no warrantless searches
and i want to have probable cause not
reasonable suspicion thank you
any further questions
i have one for you
so uh under the um u.s supreme court
decision of terry
terry search
isn't the terry stop based on a
reasonable and articulable suspicion
standard that allows a police officer
stop and frisk
an individual i think that's true yes
no further questions thank you very much
representative thank you members of the
committee
uh next up is michael flanagan
that's fine
um correct your card come on up you can
still speak
come on up you can still speak you want
to speak in opposition to the bill
i apologize michael flanagan cry new
hampshire commercial fisherman
i'm speaking to represent myself and my
brother
uh we've both been commercial fishermen
for 66 years
we both hold 1200 trap licenses
lobstering in new hampshire
my two sons on waterfront property and
kitty they're on a buying air freight
business with a lobster fishery
my family is heavily invested i want to
support the new hampshire fish and game
department
i've never had an issue with them i
think this bill as i saw it written
is totally wrong i oppose the bill as it
was written
uh i'd like to answer any questions
anyone has
thank you mister about my history
flanagan is that right again yes so does
anybody have any questions for mr
flanagan
representative ellis go ahead do you
have a recognized for a question and a
follow-up if necessary
thank you mr speaker
chairman
um uh what part of the bill do you
oppose
making the fish and game
officers obtain a search warrant i think
it's wrong i think they're doing a great
job
my family has a tremendous investment in
the fishery basically lobster fishery
now the only protection we have is a new
hampshire fish and game department they
i've i've fished commercially for 66
years i have never had a single
fisheries violation
i've great result a great rapport
with the fisher game department they're
doing a great job but i think they're
underfunded and they're under supplied
with equipment
thank you very much any further
questions thank you very much for your
time and coming to the legislature mr
trying to get the civilians first
my name is jim taton i'm from seabrook
new hampshire and i'm a member of the
yankee fisherman's co-op
and i'm here to speak in opposition of
this bill
i believe house bill 1091 if approved
would restrict fish and game officers
from properly executing the duties of
their jobs into conservation improvement
and preservation of natural resources
i'm going to give you a couple of
examples of their their duties and
responsibilities
as part of the
fish and games normal routine fish and
game offices
routinely
head out onto the ocean
to haul lobster traps to assure
compliance with not only state laws but
federal laws
and if they're required to
obtain a search warrant prior to be
doing this i think it would be doing a
great disservice to the entire lobster
industry
uh as secondly once a boat is landed and
his lobsters get
uh
into a dealer's lobster pound
the way i read this law there is
they
fish and game officers would be
prohibited
from entering that lobster pound to
check that catch for compliance with the
laws
unless
you got a search warrant prior to that
and i i i think that's just wrong and
that
the fish and game is doing a great job
in protecting the marine resources and i
think we should um
disapprove this uh amendment to the uh
the existing law
thank you if you have any questions
thank you mr tone any questions for mr
tatum
seeing none thank you very much for your
time sir and coming from the fish and
game committee
next up is alan rice of gun owners of
america
good morning thank you mr chairman
members of the committee
i did prepare uh some written testimony
i'm not going to read it verbatim um in
the interest of time i i wanted to make
a few
a few key points ellen if you could give
it to dan and he'll again pass it down
thank you
for the record my name is alan rice and
i am a resident of bedford new hampshire
and i'm here in my capacity as the new
hampshire state director of gun owners
of america
which is a national organization
representing the interest of over 2
million firearms owners
coast to coast
we're here in support of house bill 1091
i have not had a chance to fully digest
the amendment and i certainly have not
had a chance to review it with our legal
counsel
um but the key points that we are
concerned with
is the fact that sworn law enforcement
officers
who are employed by the fish and game
department known as conservation
officers
are able to search
and sees property
without probable cause
and without a warrant
um
reasonable suspicion um which is in the
current law is a very low burden of
proof
it's an inkling it's a hunch
it's not very firm our attorneys tell me
that probable cause is known as 51
percent it's 51 percent that there's
some crime afoot
it's a very small burden
to demonstrate especially when we
consider that
local police officers deputy sheriff
state troopers
all have to demonstrate probable cause
to search
or to make an arrest new hampshire is
unique in that there's been a supreme
court decision state versus sterndale
that
new hampshire law enforcement does not
have the automobile exception
that other states have police officers
can
detain an automobile
and maintain the status quo
and then go apply for search warrant
but the current law has a carve out for
conservation officers
we don't think that's right
we are in no way in favor
of poaching or any other wildlife crime
but we're also not in favor
of
throwing away constitutional protections
in the interest of expediency
when i talk to
our members in new hampshire some of
whom
hunt and fish they tell me that
these types of laws were drafted decades
ago
when there weren't you know smartphones
and computers and cellular
communications and conservation officers
were in the field and the
the evidence would disappear
that's not the case in the modern era a
conservation officer in the field can
whip out his iphone
call the station
type out a warrant email to another co
they can get a judge to sign it while
the man or woman in the field is
maintaining the status quo and the
evidence won't leave
um
requiring cos to
obtain probable cause
and warrants would not only bring them
in line with every other law enforcement
officer in the state of new hampshire
would bring them in line with the
constitution and the practice in the
majority of other states and for those
reasons as well as what i have written
in my written testimony submitted to
this committee we would ask that you
vote
um
house bill 1091 ought to pass and i will
happily entertain any questions
questions for mr rice
i'm going to have one
mr rice you have a if i remember right
from previous testimonial you have a
background in law enforcement yes sir
you ever done a terry stop based on
reasonable articulable suspicion yes sir
next up is kyle baker kyle baker of the
new hampshire wildlife federation
good morning
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee my name is kyle baker i'm here
on behalf of the new hampshire wildlife
federation
in opposition to this bill new hampshire
wildlife federation is new hampshire's
leading advocate for the protection of
the right to hunt fish and trap as well
as the protection and access to lands to
enjoy as well as hunting fishing and
trapping
we represent approximate affiliated
membership about 50 000 sportsmen and
women around the state
and we have concerns of this legislation
i'm just reviewing the amendment this
morning but
our main concern is about creating added
confusion
into the work that the conservation
officers are doing conservation officers
are a specialized trained law
enforcement unit in new hampshire
sportsmen
and women are the
you know the regulated community here if
we're looking at the regulators being
the conservation officers
and this is not something that any of
our members have been asking for
we're confident in the current process
as it works with fish and game law
enforcement being able to use reasonable
and articulable suspicion for the work
that they're doing
and we
are proud to partner with them in their
efforts in protecting hunting fishing
trapping as well as wildlife for the
next generation to be able to enjoy so
without happy to answer any questions
you might have
questions from mr baker from the new
hampshire wildlife federation
representative vegan you're recognized
for a question and a follow-up thank you
mr chair thank you sir for taking my
question are you familiar with operation
game thief run by the fish and game
department yes follow-up
would you call that a successful
operation that exists now i would say
that's probably one of the most
successful operations run by the fishing
game department another follow-up would
you be concerned that that operation
would be
less
successful if this
bill was to pass sure um it's definitely
a possibility that uh poaching could it
could be increase
we also have a
responsibility to the wildlife along the
borders wildlife don't stop at state
borders they don't know where they exist
both our partners and i'm happy to be
corrected by the department both our
partners in maine and vermont uh use the
reasonable and articulate suspicion
definition when it comes to the
conservation efforts so um again we'd
like to see we wouldn't want to make new
hampshire an island in this case
thank you very much
thank you mr chair
any further questions for mr baker
seeing them thank you very much mr baker
for your testimony thank you for coming
for the fish and game committee
next up is
gino
marcou i think it is of the marine
thank you excuse me thank you mr
chairman members of the committee gino
marconi i am the chairman of the marine
fisheries advisory committee
211 colon 60 too many numbers there
the committee is opposed to this
amendment to the law
high valued marine species
that are highly regulated
that move around the seacoast and out of
the state
that law enforcement would be inhibited
by enforcing the regulations that are on
the books now
they've got a good working relationship
with fish and game and with law
enforcement with fish and game
and the committee's opposed to this as
written
thank you miss marconi apologizes
pronounce your name wrong is there any
questions for mr marconi
seeing none thank you very much sir for
coming for the fishing game committee
chairman
last up is our distinguished colonel
jordan again
two separate
good morning mr chairman
members of the committee thank you again
for allowing me to testify today i'm i
too am looking at the amendment uh
kind of quickly this morning we the
commission didn't take a position on the
amendment because it wasn't before the
commission so i can't
um
i really can't tell you what the
commission would do with that i do see
an issue with it that i'll bring up here
in just a moment i
i always this so just a little update
this bill or one like it has been before
the house on six different occasions
so in 2011 it was debated 2012 it was
debated
um i got to get to my notes to give you
the rest of those dates i believe this
so we have had and i couldn't begin to
guess
i couldn't begin to guess how many
courts have reviewed this law and the
procedures that resulted because of it
that being searches that officers had
done cases that officers have made
the only thing i can tell you is i'm in
my 30th year for law enforcement
and i've been using this law for every
one of those 30 years so i'm pretty
confident that i know what it says and
i'm also confident that we operate it i
operate under it correctly
and i would base that statement those
two statements on the fact that court
cases would show us otherwise
especially in the world we live in today
i don't think
i can remember a time in the last three
decades where law enforcement has been
more closely scrutinized to the point
where i've got young officers who don't
even want to do this job anymore because
they're afraid of the public uh opinion
and feeling about law enforcement today
so having said that and and to some
degree personally i don't think that's a
bad thing i think it's good that people
are watching i think it's mandatory that
we do this job carefully and correctly i
don't have a i don't have an issue with
that but having said that
i want you to think for just a moment
what would happen to a law that violates
routinely people's civil rights in the
world we live in today i would submit to
you this law would have changed 50 years
ago
50 years ago it's been tested and i'm
going to review when it was tested by
our supreme court on three different
occasions closely tested and examined
and it was upheld in all three of those
cases it's upheld in circuit courts
around the state and it's upheld in
superior courts around the state if
these guys
overstep their bounds they lose their
case folks they don't win
and the other thing i would ask you to
think about
when reach back into your memory
tell me when the last time you heard of
a fish and game officer violating
someone's civil rights when did that hit
the newspaper
when were those guys sued
when was the agency on the front page of
the manchester union or any other local
state paper saying that these guys
violated people's rights in 30 years
that i've been here not once not once
i'll read to you what confuses people
is 206 26 and i'd like to have my hands
around the throat of the person who
wrote it because i really think we could
have done a much better job
it's a it's a law that we spend days
instructing new officers on because it
is so
close to the line there has to be a good
understanding of what this law means and
i will i have sat in these chairs behind
you and heard miss statements and and i
did it again today misquotes and
misstatement saying that this law allows
for this or doesn't allow for that it's
very clear what it allows for it's very
clear
and so i'll start with paragraph two it
says to execute all warrants
so the idea that we don't have to do
warrants is untrue because that line
tells you that to execute all warrants
and search warrants based on probable
cause just like every other police
officer for the violations of laws rules
and regulations relating to all wildlife
section three serve subpoenas and i
won't go into the rest of that section
four carry firearms section five to
arrest without a warrant but based on
probable cause and probable cause was
was correctly quoted a few minutes ago
it is the courts consider that 51
standard that the person you're going to
arrest or that you seek to arrest has
committed the crime that's a pretty in
spite of what you heard that's a pretty
high standard you've got to be pretty
sure
that that person committed that crime uh
if you're going to arrest them all
police
all police
game wardens sheriffs local pd's
part-time police officers state troopers
in new hampshire this is what's unique
about new hampshire all share exactly
the same powers
they are all certified police officers
we all attend the same academy i can
take this shirt off today throw on a
state police uniform and they would need
to do nothing to put me out on the
highway to stop the next speeder coming
down interstate 93. we're all trained to
the same level that's that's a good
thing ladies and gentlemen in the state
of new hampshire because when when
uh an event occurs or a major event
occurs and all police show up there they
all are trained they're all educated in
the same way it's very important that's
why i maintain that's why new hampshire
has
fortunately been able to avoid
front-page news on some of these other
things that other cities have not across
our country i think it's because the
training level in new hampshire is
pretty good and and that's based on 30
years of watching it and and and doing
it
so we can arrest our without warrant but
based on probable cause for a crime
that's committed in our view if we find
out about a crime that has been
committed and we develop probable cause
but it didn't happen in my presence i am
required just like everybody else to go
get an arrest warrant or to go get a
search warrant there's no
that this idea that fish and game
officers have special powers is folklore
it just doesn't exist
what is unique to us and i was a police
officer for four years before i came
here so i stopped cars on the road and
it gave me a really good understanding
of of this law and how it's applied when
i was a police officer on the road if i
stopped a car there's a belief among
many people maybe some in the room today
that you must have probable cause to
pull a car over on the highway ladies
and gentlemen that's incorrect
you need articulable and reasonable
suspicion just just like a game warden
no different
when when i stopped a car i could say to
chairman lang chairman lang you were
speeding i'd like to see your license
he pulls out his license and his
registration ladies and gentlemen that's
a search
that's a search based on reasonable
suspicion i can't stop chairman lang
because i don't like him when i see him
down driving down the road and say give
me your registration your license i have
to have a reason to do that
no different than a game warden no
different than again i can't see someone
dressed in orange and say strip off
throw out all your bags because i'm the
mighty game warden's here and i'm going
to search everything you got i can do
that i'm probably going to get away with
it once and then i'm going to be in
trouble and maybe looking for work you
can't do that it's no different for
police it's articulable suspicion the
difference being and where people get
confused is we don't typically stop cars
on the highway we're stopping people in
the field or lobstermen on their lobster
boat as you as you've heard
on a lobster boat so if we i get ahead
of myself because i get so excited about
this because it's very frustrating to me
you know what bothers me the most
any time i've ever been to the
legislature is the thought process that
we've got game wardens out there
violating people's civil rights i take
that very personally because that is
just not true not the case
so
we are allowed to
stop someone who is fishing so someone
is fishing i see them casting into the
water i see them catching fish they're
reeling up fish
i've reached articulable suspicion that
that person is taking fish i am now
allowed under this statue to go up and
ask them to produce their license and to
see the fish not their cocaine i can't
go into their front pocket their watch
pocket because that's not where you're
gonna find a fish okay i can only go and
i'm gonna have to justify in a courtroom
why i looked where i looked so if i see
a creole can i justify that in a cool
room that that's where most fishermen
carry their fish i think i could
if i start searching a guy's pockets and
i don't have articulable suspicion
reasonable suspicion or probable cause
i'm not going to win that uh the
scenario that that representative
spelaine talks about the homicide is a
real
and and and i want to stress to you he
is
raising a concern that's real to him i
get that i'm not finding fault with that
but i
my problem here is i don't think he
understands it we in fact did just that
we were out enforcing fish and game laws
in the in the town of cambridge
this past year when we came across the
headless murder victim and the woman who
committed that crime or was partner in
that crime so we in fact walked in to a
homicide scene while conducting wildlife
work and i'm here to tell you there
wasn't a problem with what we did or how
we did it because we were very careful
to make sure that we followed the law we
do the same thing as all other law
enforcement do does at that moment we're
not working on a fish and game case we
readily realize or suspect that we've
just walked into a homicide and those
officers took very careful steps
including warrants calling for state
police for backup and then worked
through the entire evening along with my
board director who picked that afternoon
to ride with a local officer
which is another whole story i'd love to
share with you all
they worked very carefully in that case
was of course it's a homicide it went to
superior court it was upheld the people
were convicted or at least one was at
this point
so that exact scenario has happened
a game warden stopping when you award i
came back here a number of years ago
because my officers were coming to me
and it had happened to me we'd be
working night hunters in the field we'd
be coming home at 3 o'clock in the
morning and we'd come up behind a car
that was obviously being driven by what
we believe to be an impaired driver in
the old days if i pulled that driver
over which is what i should do to get
him off the highway before he hurts
someone i cannot or no one else can ever
prosecute him because i didn't have the
authority to do that i didn't have the
authority to pull him over that was
happening a lot and so my options are i
follow this guy in hopes that he doesn't
kill anybody and i call for a local pd
or a trooper to come and stop him so
that we can get him off the highway
that's really i used to instruct my
officers that's not what i want you to
do
our job is to get them off the highway
we lose the prosecution yes but to get
them off the highway before they kill
somebody so i came here and asked you to
give us the authority which the
legislature had never done prior to this
to do that
and i lectured my officers and i said it
here and i and i've got officer a
lieutenant here who will support this i
i beat on them constantly telling them
you are not state troopers i do not want
to see a game warden on the highway with
a radar gun okay we've got plenty to do
we've got all these wildlife laws that
we need to enforce if you see something
that is dangerous if i'm driving home
and someone runs a stoplight in front of
me i can now do something to stop that
that's the only time we use those powers
is in those scenarios i'm not going to
open a guy's trunk
as a police officer i know where that's
going to end that is just ridiculous to
think that that's going to occur if i'm
going to open his trunk i best have
probable cause and in fact a search
warrant and 206 26 lays out that i have
to do that okay it doesn't give me that
power or authority it allows me to make
that motor vehicle stop if you will for
the fishermen of the hunter that's in
the field just like i did as a police
officer it's no different to say that we
don't do that is not correct read
section 7 says to to secure and execute
search warrants based on probable cause
you can read that to any police officer
in the state of new hampshire it's
exactly the same thing they have to do
there is no difference to that
finally the unique thing about wildlife
so people will say to me or have said to
me why why did the courts and the
legislature feel that that was important
to give you to give you guys the
authority to to stop someone under
reasonable suspicion articulable
suspicion uh and to do conduct these
searches and the reason for that was
really you can look at some of the laws
and rules that this very committee has
passed things like lead lead we don't
want lead in our waters we don't want
guys fishing with or gals fishing with
lead-based lures we don't want people
using lead shot and a shotgun we want to
make sure that they're shooting steel
shot not lead and polluting or polluting
our properties and we want you to do
that we want you to make sure that
people are doing that we don't want to
we don't want to have people
commercial fishermen who you've heard
here in the back today who quite frankly
if there was ever a group who's subject
to these
inspections more
than than anyone else it is the lobster
fisherman we these poor guys back here
we board their boat sometimes twice a
week when they're out fishing they're
patient gentlemen they they're trying to
make a living with this they will give
us i've lectured my guys to get on those
boats conduct those inspections quickly
and get those boats back underway so
those guys can make their living they
want us to do that ladies and gentlemen
because if we don't do that and someone
goes out there and cleans up on short
lobsters or cleans up that resource
these guys lose money
so they're willing to tolerate that to
some degree so we have a good
understanding with them good enough so
they came today they're subject to these
checks and they're here telling you they
want to be subject to those checks one
of the laws that's important to them is
we decided as a legislature that you
cannot keep an egg-bearing female
lobster because these resources are very
precious to the state of new hampshire
in fact so precious when you created
that law you mandated that that lobster
can't even be kept for evidence it had
to immediately be released over the side
of the boat and put back into the water
i can't do that with a spotting scope
from 100 200 yards away which is what
would be required for probable cars
because if this were to pass i would no
longer be able to board that boat and
see that the only way you could see
there's an egg bearing lobster is to
hold it in your hand and flip it over
can't do that with a spotting scope
can't do that with a pair of binoculars
from a half a mile away
and one commercial fisherman said it
correctly you he could be coming in
from his days of fish fishing going to
the market and i would be powerless to
stop him unless i had probable cause
that he's gonna show up
and
i got some good people but i'm not sure
they can tell if the measurement of a
lobster through a pair of binoculars
it's just not gonna happen and so these
guys are gonna get away with doing this
and and these are the gentlemen
fishermen that are going to pay that
price those are the laws you guys voted
through this is what you asked us to do
this is what i need to do that i'm not
going to be able to do that you need to
understand that it's going to change the
face of this dramatically
probable cause is a requirement that is
the highest the highest of standard to
get these search warrants
then if i let's say that we're lucky
enough to take one of these poor
commercial fishermen coming in and for
whatever reason i developed the probable
cause now i'm going to seize his boat
and i'm going to pull him over to the
side or take him in the shoreline and
then i'm going to seek out a judge and
then i'm going to write a warrant
then i'm going to have to have the judge
review that warrant and approve it and
if i'm fortunate enough i might be able
to do that over the phone but a lot of
times you end up trying to locate a
judge and hunting him down and bringing
that warrant to him then i've got to
seize the evidence whatever evidence i
seize i have to do a receipt i have to
file a return
the fisherman's day is over they're not
making money while they're sitting on
the pier waiting for me to do all of
this as opposed to when i could board
the boat look and see he's got nothing
wrong and send him on his way
the other thing that you want to the
other factor that you want to consider
is our courts have never been in a worse
position than they are today as far as
workloads go they can't stay with the
work they're getting
adding this added burden to this
uh for any law enforcement officer
is is only going to burden our courts
and i'm not looking to do that on the
rare occasion that we can develop this
so this law has been in effect as i said
for over 80 years and and in in those 80
years i wouldn't begin to guess how many
courts have reviewed it how many
attorneys have used it how many
attorneys have filed
motions to to
suppress evidence because that's what
would happen in these cases where this
law has been debated but i can tell you
on three occasions it's been debated in
our new hampshire supreme court and
quite frankly
i'm pretty confident that if this law
violated civil rights or anyone's rights
or violated the fourth amendment that
our supreme court would have taken that
opportunity to change it because they do
it all the time thankfully i don't want
people searching me illegally either my
rights are just as important to me as
the people that i deal with so three
times that that has gone before the
court and i'm just going to read you
very quickly three quick quotes from
each one of those cases the first one
was state viva beauchemin which was a
baiting case in the state of new
hampshire with one of my officers
directly involved
and it and the court said under 206.26
one permits conservation officers to go
on any property outside of a building to
enforce wildlife rules and regulations
not criminal law not drug laws not
homicides wildlife rules and regulations
so he better be doing that when he goes
on there
goes outside of a building or to enforce
wildlife rules or regulation but does
not allow them to enter such buildings
without a warrant we can't kick the door
down on a home thank goodness
no one can do that we have to have a
warrant to do that this doesn't allow us
if permitted permits conservation
officers secure and execute warrants to
enter the buildings here the defendant's
porch is part of the property outside of
his home or his building officer brown
was therefore within his statutory
powers to go on the defendant's porch
and enforce all the laws and regulations
relating to wildlife it was pretty clear
what it thought there
state v marconi and i don't believe it
was any relation to my friend geno back
here if and it was gino you can thump me
i didn't i mean no disregard but but it
was a case on point it said we do not
read in our statutes any such
all-encompassing restraint on ordinary
patrol and inspection of lobster
fishermen nor do we find that the fourth
amendment to the united states
constitution bars reasonable inspection
of lobster boats under operated under
license from the state
and then the final one and the one that
makes me very confident that our laws
here in new hampshire are good is i i
would argue and i would argue with
anyone in the room the most liberal
state in our country today is the state
of california now that's a pretty broad
statement some may argue that that's my
own personal opinion the state of
california took this up because almost
all the states across our country have
the same law or one very similar to it
for the same reasons that's another
interesting fact it's not unique to new
hampshire it is nationwide california
reviewed this under an illegal what was
what was alleged as an illegal search
and they came down with the following
opinion it's in the state's interest
underlying a stop and demand pursuant to
section 212 which is 2012 which is the
california law is quite distinct from
the state's ordinary interest and
enforcement of its criminal law
meaning it's different
and the limited category of persons
affected by the procedure anglers and
hunters are individuals who have chosen
to engage in a heavy regulated activity
that reduces their reasonable suspicion
of privacy with regard to the type of
intrusion it goes on to say we conclude
that the the intrusion upon privacy by a
game warden stop of an angler or a
hunter to demand or display his or her
catch is relatively minor to begin with
the stops are limited to persons who a
game warden reasonably believes recently
has been hunting or fishing a person who
have voluntarily chosen to engage in an
activity that is heavily regulated to
ensure the continued existence of
wildlife in the state for the benefit
not only of future generations but for
the benefit of current anglers and
hundreds themselves if we're talking
about people's rights the other thing
that i would ask you to think about
everyone in the state of new hampshire
owns the wildlife whether you shoot it
eat it
don't do that you heart you watch it you
photograph it we we manage dan back here
and his team manages wildlife
populations and does an outstanding job
by the way
for all to enjoy
and it's important that we manage we do
our part the game ones do their part to
make sure that this wildlife and
resources do not vanish
and if we're powerless rendered
powerless to check that that is going to
happen or is in danger of happening and
i think everyone's rights would be
affected then so i think it's just as
important to understand that this is
important for everyone not just the
fishermen and the hunters
um
and i could go on for a day and a half
quite frankly no i won't the other thing
that that concerns me that that is a as
a matter of legal matter for my many
days in a courtroom i look quickly at
the amendment that representative
spelaine and i and i want to stress i
think representative splain has gone out
of his way to try to make this
uh i think he understands what we do and
how we do it i i do think that and i
think he doesn't want to affect that i
think he thinks i think he believes that
this is unconstitutional and he would be
dead wrong
so but he did try in an amendment to
make this a little bit better so we had
spoken about one of our concerns was i
said how will i stop someone
transporting a deer to a registration
station or or his residence i wouldn't
be able to do that
because it says he has to be
engaged in the act of taking and we have
a great definition under 2071 and for
deaf for taking it's chasing pursuing
worrying it's doing all of those things
we don't have one for just driving down
and transporting down the road
and the law this change would not allow
me to do that so people could load up a
bunch of illegal first transport them
for a commercial sale i wouldn't be able
to stop them to do that unless i could
develop probable cause i don't know how
i do that when a car goes by and the
trunks closed i'm not sure how we do
that you wouldn't be able to do it
um he put in here that so we we talked
about that concern and he put in his
amendment
he added the word is returning so his
feeling was a commercial boat that is
already done with their take and
returning to the pier that would be okay
to search the problem with that is there
is no definition legal definition for
returning
if i were a defense attorney the first
thing i would say is define returning
for me colonel jordan i'd be at a loss
to do that when am i returning
when am i returning there has to be a
definition for that am i returning to my
home am i returning to the pier what am
i returning from the required when you
put that stuff into a bill it becomes an
element of the offense that you have to
prove
so you have to prove all of those things
that he's got there a talisman you have
to prove he was in the act of taking or
that he was returning to to wherever i
don't know how i do that i can tell you
right now you wouldn't you wouldn't be
able to do that so um so i'm going to
stop
thank you for the opportunity and and i
hope
the other thing that i'm going to stop
with this
there's a thing out in the newspaper
it's very sad quite frankly it's called
the lorry list we called it the lorry
list those of us in police work the
lorry list is a list of officers within
our state that have committed offenses
it's
disgraceful it's people that have
violated civil rights it's people that
have committed crimes it's people whose
truth or veracity has not only come into
question but proven to come into
question
and those some of those police officers
are still working
within their agencies and we have 270
police officers on that list you will
not find a new hampshire conservation
officer on that list and i'm very proud
of that fact
so i challenge anyone who says that we
are out there violating people's civil
rights how we dodge that
i challenge you to show me that and i
challenge you to bring me the people
whose rights we've violated because i
want to see that because no one else the
attorney general's office none of our
courts no one else has put us on that
list and there's a reason that they that
we're not on that list so
show these people these officers that
you understand that and appreciate it
and don't render them powerless please
thank you
thank you kirk jordan and i like you it
was around when that loyalist was
created from the murder trial of carl
laurie in franklin so i didn't know how
that
that was established and what went on
there uh we're gonna open up for the
questions for colonel jordan any
questions colonel jordan representative
flam go ahead
thank you mr chairman and thank you
kevin uh colonel jordan
the distinguished colonel jordan
for the benefit of people who don't have
it right in front of them i'd like to
read
you
casually mentioned
chapter 206 colon 26
section roman numeral v five
uh concerning and i'm gonna read it to
you
it says to arrest without warrant
but based on probable cause an army view
any person found violating any law rule
or regulation
relating to all wildlife
take such person into before court for
trial detain the person
at the expense of intent you're a
certified police officer and i assume
that in your training you have
a reasonable amount of training
concerning probable cause
and search warrants and how to interpret
laws am i correct in interpreting that
this section says
you can arrest without a warrant
if you have
if there's a rule or regulation relating
to wildlife
am i correct in interpreting that to
mean that that does not apply to other
sections of the criminal code
so
no we all police in new hampshire all
law enforcement whether you're a game
warden a sheriff or a local police all
police have the authority to arrest
uh for a crime committed in your
presence without a warrant
so we all have that same power and
authority i think this law specifically
refers to wildlife just to make sure
that people understood that we too share
that authority but we could any law
enforcement can do that so a trooper
could arrest a night hunter eat and they
do on occasion in the north country a
trooper can if he sees a wildlife
violation he can act on it if i see a
dwi now thanks to this committee who
started it i can act on it so the powers
are all equal in in that regard it has
to be committed in your presence
if you were to tell me or i was just
would discover that you committed a
misdemeanor act outside of my presence
then i would have to get a warrant just
like a trooper a trooper or any other
police officer would so all police have
that authority quick follow-up
so i assume from what you're stating
then is that
fish and game uh
conservation officers do not have
special powers that police do not have
no they don't no i think the the 206 26
these first three or four paragraphs
convince people that we do it's
describing if you think about it it's
describing a motor vehicle stop the
police have the authority to make
without probable cause too articulable
suspicion if you were to if you were to
change the law for state police or all
police to mirror what we're trying to do
here you would have you would
essentially end motor vehicle stops they
wouldn't be able to do a motor vehicle
stop because the idea of a trooper
getting probable cars watching someone
drive down the highway is probably just
as difficult as it would be for me to
watch a lobster boat from a fire with a
spotting scope it just you just it just
ceases to exist it's not going to happen
so this empowers us to make motor
vehicle stops of fishermen and hunters
and troopers and police have that
authority on the highway it's that
simple
it's that simple
thank you thank you any other questions
for colonel jordan
thank you mr chair and thank you colonel
jordan and i never get to ask questions
anymore so i'm so happy i pre-wrote my
questions
look forward to that and i'm just i'm
just trying to understand some things i
actually have three but i'll ask in
between of the chair
um you mentioned uh that when you stop
and you ask someone for their license
that that is a search and i just want to
clarify that's you requesting to search
and then voluntarily agreeing right
which is not the same as a warrant
search where
you are doing it against their will
that's correct yes
although in a motor vehicle stop they
wouldn't have the ability to not produce
that they could be charged with that
so so you're you're you are
in the eyes of the court they view that
that's why so if i could just that's why
at the very beginning of a court case if
you can't articulate the reason for the
stop the case goes out the window at
that moment because everything beyond
that is thrown out
as it should be you've got to have
articulable suspicion or probable cause
to make that start
okay
and mr chair may ask another question
thank you
um
so and i believe you probably know the
answer to this question is there any rsa
state rsa
that
requires explicitly that offers officers
get warrants regular law enforcement
officers um or is that just kind of like
an effect of the fact that we have the
fourth amendment and therefore such
evidence would get thrown out in court
it's we all have to follow uh this is
another misnomer we all have to follow
the same constitution we all have to
abide by the same laws and rules set
forth by our forefathers thankfully
it applies to us all that's right and
that's where that we have
search warrant my that's why i brought
bob today
we have uh laws that that require that
but the basis of that the foundation of
that was uh was um
designed in the constitution or the idea
was born in the constitution yes
but it is you're about to read yes so
under under 200 excuse me 594.10 is
arrest without a warrant and it lays out
those steps and that again would be the
same for all law enforcement don't
forget all law enforcement go to the
same academy we can we i bunk with i
when i was in the academy i bunked with
a trooper we all got the same level of
training thankfully okay and i have one
final question mr chair
thank you uh colonel jordan i i've heard
and i don't ask you to
mention or speak to other people's
testimony but i've heard lots of
testimony from you and others about
the kinds of searches that have to deal
with lobster fishermen fishermen in
general people engaged in fish and game
activities um
but were those things not exempted in
the bill i i was under the understanding
that they were
so
the bill that's before you would would
not allow for any of that unless you had
probable cause you would need probable
cause for any of that okay the first
line of the change indicates that thank
you very much yep
any further representative howard
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question colonel
um it's back to my original question i
was just
wondering what an illegal apparatus
subject to forfeiture is
so under
26 we are allowed to
uh it's much like the drug law we are
allowed to seize things that are
uh used items that are used illegally in
the commission of a crime so if i were
to stop a night hunter a person out at
night shooting deer i could sue i could
seize his firearm uh theoretically i
could seize his car although none of it
that's never done
um but you can seize all of that stuff
to be used as evidence really is what it
what the purpose of that was for
so illegal illegal apparatus was kind of
a
that was kind of a that was a word that
was written many years ago and has never
changed but it but it means contraband
basically today that would probably read
contraband
relating though relating to wildlife
follow up his life
um
well that's you know if you pulled
someone over there's a hypothetical and
they had lead jigs
in their trunk
they're not engaged in fishing they just
they had led jigs in their trunk they
would maybe bring them to another state
where they're legal
would that be considered an illegal
apparatus it would be considered illegal
i don't think it's illegal to possess it
am i right bob
it's illegal
so if it's illegal to possess it in new
hampshire you couldn't have it and we
would see we would only seize it if it
were illegal to be in your possession
you're at what your point you're trying
to make would be correct if they're not
using it and it's not illegal to possess
it no you would not do anything with
that
all right thank you and you
and i want to say one other thing i
wouldn't open his trunk
until unless i felt i asked him that i
could open it and he allows me to do it
i haven't i have no authority to open
that trunk unless i have a search
warrant you can't you know that second
third paragraph of 206.26 spells that
out locked
cars how homes all of those things just
like police you have to have a warrant
thankfully
representatives i recognize for a
question and a follow-up i actually have
a question for the chair first which may
qualify whether i have a question for
colonel jordan good can
the colonel
test uh speak on behalf of other persons
testimony when it directly references
the commission fish and game
and a project that the colonel oversees
if it relates to the bill you sure
colonel jordan the gunners of america
submitted testimony and i'll read it
specifically so i can be clear the goa
leadership was horrified when we saw the
blatant fourth amendment and fifth
amendment violations displayed on the tv
show northwoods law new hampshire which
focuses on your
folks hunter's forest blah blah blah um
hunters forced to walk a conservation
officer around a kill site and answer
these questions only to get summoned
anyway
was there any legal ramifications taken
against the fish and game department in
this
person profiled in the program or was
the program do you know
legally
uh
found liable for violating fourth or
fifth amendment violations yep so good
question so
uh we did a television show as you know
for 12 years i learned a lot more about
tv than i ever wanted to know i would
sincerely request that no law is ever
written based on what you see on a
television show
based on what i now know so television
is entertainment ladies and gentlemen
and that's purely what it is i debate
internally with my my film company on
many occasions over what to show and how
much of it to show they are in tuned on
showing the entertainment part the
sensational part the gotcha moment they
they failed to show that there were
months that went up into some of those
investigations or weeks and follow-up
work and warrants done they don't show
that because quite frankly that doesn't
sell television the search warrant does
so so the answer to that would be please
don't do that and if you haven't figured
out our news is no better i've dealt
dealt with them for 30 years too so
and i know chairman lang has so it's
it's uh it's disgraceful quite frankly
so
uh to answer your question we had one
lawsuit in the 12 years of filming i get
inundated with support emails and now
i'm getting inundated because people are
angry because it's going off the air and
i'm and i'm not too disappointed about
that because it's a lot of work
so we get a lot of
way more positive feedback than negative
so we had one lawsuit in 24 years in 12
years a person brought that really
involved another police department that
we were we were assisting with they
called us in to assist the person sued
based on search uh via alleged search
violations it failed miserably
not only did it fail he ended up paying
the attorney cost for the television
company so the judge sent him a loud
message that that was a frivolous suit
so we've never been sued there's never
been an allegation made and i would say
to you that's just you know you're
seeing
one little piece of a very big picture
and and i would hope people would put
that in perspective it's a television
show
i completely appreciate your point of
view and your testimony thanks for the
question
to colonel jordan's point i'd say any
one of us have been interviewed by the
paper and spent 15 minutes talking to
them and they take one sentence out of
your entire statement and that's what's
going to be in the newspaper so and that
sentence has to be with their train of
thought they take what's what they want
representative smith
thank you mr uh chairman colonel jordan
um
i'm just gonna
try to ask a question in layman's terms
and a scenario type situation so if
there's a vehicle traffic traveling down
the road i.e in normal police duties and
he's speeding you're going to stop him
on reasonable suspicion correct
that's correct
during hunting season on a busy road
that's traveled by many hunters it's a
frequently traveled hunting area and
there's a gentleman driving down the
road not speeding doing nothing wrong
but has camouflage on will you stop him
on reasonable suspicion so in that
scenario the only way that we would do
that is if that in and there would be
have to be a more mitigating faction so
that would have to be someone dressed
or appearing to be hunting someone
traveling at a slow speed which is
indicative of someone road hunting
uh
you know searching for game from their
vehicle a person traveling down the road
at normal speed and camo gear i would
not stop unless i saw some sort of a
violation is that a hunter yep it is
but i don't have articulate suspicion to
stop him i don't know what he's doing he
may be just driving down the road with a
camo coat on so i would not stop him
follow-up absolutely god if you did stop
that suspected hunter um
and you did suspect that he was hunting
but there was no visible signs of blood
or a gun or anything but you suspect
something's in the trunk would you
require them to get a warrant
i would i would first probably we
typically ask him if we think there's
something in the trunk and we have a
reason we we relay that reason to him
and i would ask him because it's simple
for both of us can you open your trunk
and show me that there's nothing in
there and 99.9 percent of the people
will do just that if he didn't i would
need more than what you've just
described to get my warrant i would have
to see things like blood on the tailgate
blood on his clothing nervous actions on
his part those all go to the probable
cause probably cause requires a number
of things it has to be
more likely than not that the person
committed the crime that's a high
standard that's why the warrant is
required they want a judge to review
that thank you
any further questions for the colonel
i just have one clarifying one i want to
make sure i heard you crystal clear
three times this reasonable standard
this articulable reasonable suspicion
standards been
been brought before the supreme court
new hampshire supreme court and three
times has been upheld as constitutional
that's correct state v beauchemin state
v marconi and stavey kimball all three
uh involved searches under these
circumstances and the supreme court
ruled in our favor and gave very
decisive opinions that this did not
violate anyone's rights thank you thank
you thank you for letting me for
tolerating it and you're free to go your
i did miss one other person who we had a
little couldn't read the bill number uh
eric anderson uh asked to testify
opposing the bill he represents the new
hampshire commercial fisherman's
association
yeah thank you mr chairman um and
committee members uh i'll start off as
that's one tough act to follow
with
the testimony of
colonel jordan
my name is eric anderson
i've had 50 years plus experience in
marine fisheries as a fisherman
and i represent the concerns of the new
hampshire commercial fishermen
um through the new hampshire commercial
fisherman's association
i've submitted written testimony and
i'll try and
paraphrase it just for the sake of time
because i think everything that has been
said um in opposition of the bill is
very legitimate and
and um
concerning
um
we submitted this legislation to our
membership electronically
um and waited for reply
um
the written testimony that i've given
you
came back with 12
i think 12 names but since that time
that i printed it i had additional
responses and
the opposition is supported by over 25
members who reviewed it
and
i just want to make that statement clear
that from the from a majority
perspective of the commercial fishermen
of new hampshire we oppose this bill
i could go on but everything has been
said
but i will
i will state
the commercial fisherman's community
respect and value the presence of new
hampshire fish and game officers to
enforce marine
rules and regulations these officers do
it in a manner that is respectful and
it's courteous and it's professional
in every sense of the word
and um
and do not abuse their rights afforded
them to do their jobs
if there is value in the adage of it's
not broke don't fix it
this would be the prime reason to
propose house bill 1091
we have the expectation of these
officers to perform a variety of their
duties beyond their primary primary
resource function ranging from dangerous
and challenging search and rescue
operations to assisting other law
with rapidly changing environmental
conditions they are there daily to
protect our natural resources and should
be given every tool and opportunity to
do so
we join
in our opinion of this legislation with
the new hampshire fish and game
department
commission and the advisory committee on
thank you very much thank you mr
anderson is there any questions for mr
anderson
seeing none thank you sir for coming for
the fish and game committee
all right so that concludes that's all
our pink cards
i am just going to open it up for
discussion amongst the members i'll give
my opinion on this first or at least my
position i i think the testimony
actually one thing i did i haven't been
doing with the other bills i just
remembered i did ask remote testimony or
at least remote positioning is still
allowed on the on the general court
website so people can sign in and
support or oppose a bill and i have uh
the re results just understand that this
is
tentative results because that is open
until the end of the day so people could
still submit ones but as of the eight
o'clock this morning when this was
printed out there are eight people in
support of the bill and 24 opposed the
bill
so that being said i you know i guess i
i don't think i'm smarter especially
when it comes to constitutional matters
than new hampshire supreme court on
three different occasions so my
inclination is to itl this bill
at best i i could consider an interim
study if we think there's some sort of
merit in here anywhere that we want to
flesh out um but
that is my general inclination is an
ital motion or an interim study motion
so i open it up for other members to
give their opinion and see where we
stand on this
representative love
i'd like to make a motion for interim
study
okay well we're in executive session and
the motion well actually we're still in
the public session i haven't opened up
for executive yet so this is just so i
can get to the committee and the public
hearing
secondation
thank you mr chairman
uh coming from
seabrook hampton falls and hearing from
the fishermen and lobstermens and also
hearing from
colonel george connell jordan's
uh passionate testimony you know i
cannot support this uh amendment and
this bill
because the the current law existing law
is working
and you know if something working we
should not touch it and if it is gonna
the commercial fishermen
is need a lot of help you know they have
many regulations many things happening
to them we need to help them every
possible weekend
and this bill is going to harm them i
cannot support that and if we think that
the interim study is not going to do
anything so why to do interim study just
itl thank you mr chairman no problems
i've gone any further discussion
representative shirtless
thank you mr chairman mr chairman i
couldn't say it better than
representative khan has just
told this committee his thoughts and i
totally agree and i would vote for itl
on this bill and i would vote against
interim study thank you mr chairman
further discussion representative leflam
then representative egan
thank you mr chairman um i agree with my
other colleagues
i've been on this committee now for six
years
we've seen this type of bill before i
see no value in sending it to in to
interim study and i would definitely be
in favor of uh itl
representative
thank you mr chair uh given my
constituency being of the north country
with the predominance of hunters and
interaction with
new hampshire fish and game and their
conservation officers i would concur
with senator with representative khan
shirtless and laflamme that this is a
bill that does not need further study
nor is it needed on our behalf of our
state
thank you representative any further
discussion
as a
as a 45-year
sportsman and uh you know doing a lot of
hunting fishing i understand that uh our
wildlife and fisheries
uh we we walk a delegate delicate
balance line with that and uh
as has as has been stated in this
committee uh before uh new hampshire has
the best you know uh fish and game
department in the in the country uh by
none and uh you know i certainly
appreciate that and i think the problem
here is uh you know the the fact that
the the legislature gave
the um fish and game department police
powers uh to do other things like up in
the north country um
and um you know there's never been any
uh never never been anything to uh
to to really define when a a
conservation officer switches hats and
puts on puts on a police officer's hat
and uh you know i don't know if this
this bill does that as as as written i
i see some flaws in it and um you know i
that that's my reasoning for um for it
for not itl for uh for interim study uh
you know
i think it's a good idea to to clearly
define
law enforcement um you know what uh when
i when i go hunting and fishing i i have
that understanding that uh you know new
hampshire fish and game is there to
protect all of it you know
and i've seen plenty of times when
people abuse it you know you see the guy
that's walking away from a stream with
20 trout
and stuff we can't have that but
then again we can't have conservation
officers being called to a a scene uh
you know a say a state cop that can't
get a warm and
you know have a call a co
into uh to to use the the lesser lesser
standards um
you know we can't have that either and
uh you know that's that's my reasoning
behind an interim study and amending
this
further representative craig
uh thank you i have a slightly different
take
i respect the opinions of my colleagues
here i greatly respect and have great
affection for colonel jordan
we've talked a lot personally and
privately
the default state
of the human condition
is that we are free to go about our
lives without interference
and that's why the fourth amendment
guarantees
that we can do exactly that
without being stopped or interfered with
the colonel mentioned earlier
checking a phishing license and compared
it to checking your driver's license
the moment any government official with
the parent authority
tells someone that
they are not free to go
and that person has been seized under
the fourth amendment
it doesn't matter if they stand there
quietly or if they sit there in their
boat
or if they're handcuffed
they've been seized
anything that results from that
while
fishing game has general police
authority
to make traffic stops
they can't just look at random cars
going down the road and decide to pull
them over and check for a driver's
license
but they can do that with fishing and
hunting licenses
even in cases where it's not clear that
the person is
hunting or fishing if they have the
appropriate equipment
they can
perform checks such as that
they can do that with boaters for safety
checks
so i don't support interim study i think
we should take it straight up or down
i would support the bill
as amended or not
it's not because i want to make things
inconvenient for our good officers out
in the field
but it's because
it is supposed to be inconvenient by
design
under the united states and new
hampshire constitutions it should be
very inconvenient
for government authorities
to stop someone
to inquire of them to search them
it should require an extraordinary
measure to interfere with anyone going
about their lives
their work or their recreation
that's why
i supported this bill when i first heard
it being mentioned
and whether as amended or as originally
written
i would support otp
thank you representative craig
representative lekis
representative craig uh expressed my
position more eloquently than i would
have and i also agree with the comment
representative love made
that uh you know
things the issues got complicated once
i guess 10 years ago they were given
more general
police powers
and so i would support
further discussion represent horgan um
yes i spent
a few years living in the north country
i mean not just not as far north as say
represent craig lives in orford new
hampshire and
back then in the 1990s and i think it's
still the case now there are very very
few
police officers there most of the
towns either relied strictly on the
state police barracks or they might
supplement that with a few uh
part-time constables many of whom
well they probably upgraded the police
training since then but many who were
poorly were poorly trained and um you
know didn't
often didn't observe any of the niceties
of uh
reasonable suspicion versus probable
cause i think
that's one reason that i think they we
we should that enhancing the powers of
the fish and game uh
conservation officers was a good idea
because that supplements the very few uh
police officers are up there it's not
like where i live now in durham where we
have more police officers per capita
than in new york city and we're
um
so i
and this also the oppositions of bill
were mostly people who are not direct
well i mean some of them probably are
hunters and fishers but it's mostly
about the general issue of
guns in the second amendment and i
don't see a
i personally don't see a second
amendment violation in what the fish and
game officers are doing and
thank you representative appreciate that
thanks so i think the itl even though it
won't be unanimous it's probably the
right way to go and uh representative
kittrich
thank you mr chairman
this has been very illuminating sitting
here listening to these various opinions
what we haven't really discussed is
representative spelaine's amendment
so i'm in favor of interim study
but i would like to say in addition
we are giving the fish and game officers
a very difficult job
and i am very loath to put handcuffs on
them while they try to do it
at the same time i agree with my
colleagues sitting here
that our freedoms and our liberties are
very important but liberty is freedom
with personal responsibility
and i guess that's why we have policemen
because some people forget the part
about personal responsibility when they
talk about freedom
so i would like to i would i would favor
i'm sure i'll learn more when that
happens i really want to talk to some
experienced police officers
i have a little story i lived in
lived on the economy in england for
three for two out of three years of the
air force over in england
i had a girlfriend on the other side of
london
coming back at two o'clock in the
morning
i was driving my little austin van which
is like a miniature suv
black
but it was basically a tradesman's
vehicle
and two and a zip car pulled me over
and they very politely asked me out
and one asked me what i was doing at two
o'clock in the morning
in knightsbridge
because i didn't belong there
according to the
you know they they were paying attention
they knew who had vehicles in their in
there you know and they were a little
worried that i might just be a burglar
they're totally polite i was not
offended by it
they were making that neighborhood safer
there are people out here that are
seeking
outrage
at people trying to do reasonable things
this is a difficult path between our
duty to our our wildlife as fellow
citizens our liberties
and the practicalities of
necessary police work
so i favor interim study thank you very
much thank you
representative reid then representative
i'm sorry
king sorry i don't know why i keep
calling
representative go ahead thank you mr
chair um
i
first of all and i think colonel jordan
is aware of this i have just the most
respect for him and his law enforcement
officers
most of the interactions i've ever had
with
law enforcement officers at all have
been positive
but in every field there are bad actors
and while i have respect and i
absolutely don't suspect that there have
been any problems
at all i did take an oath
to the constitution and i have to take
the fourth amendment seriously i what i
would suggest is that we don't
i do not want to see this
for an up or down vote today
perhaps
either execute later or interim study
today because i think that it's
incumbent on me knowing that the fourth
amendment is a serious issue i'm not
sure i'm going to admit my own ignorance
that i don't know if the law actually
conflicts but i would like to study it a
little bit further myself so that i'm
clear if there's any kind of amendment
that could just add even just a single
clarifying sentence
to just make this issue put it to bed
then that's what i would like to see but
i would just like to understand the
i listened to the testimony offered and
learned that the supreme court has
upheld
the law as it stands
and have heard that it would impact
law enforcement that is wanted by
folks who came out of their way to give
their testimony
i see it as a bill that we should i or i
see what we're looking at is something
we should itl
i can't see how it can be
fixed and made
you know better
and more reasonable if if our supreme
court says it's okay three times
i believe it's okay
thank you sir
representative ellis
um i agree with uh
uh representative carrich on the
responsibility of your freedoms
and so i think the law enforcement
officers and the fish and game officers
all trained the same
and we don't need this
this bill i think should be itil
thank you any further discussion
so i'm gonna make one clarifying comment
and then we'll just get a sense is that
to me one of the most things that i
heard out of this out of this testimony
today was
about the regulated community we heard
from the lobstermen we heard from the
fishermen we heard from the hunters who
all said leave it alone
um the people who were being regulated
and being
subject to the stats to the statute um
all came out and said it's working don't
mess it up
we follow that up with the fact that we
had three supreme court cases all of
which have upheld the standard of
reasonable suspicion and lastly we have
a u.s supreme court case under terry
right that holds the reasonable
suspicion standard and i want to be
clear it's articulable reasonable
suspicion it's not just a hunch it's a
hunch that you can actually put words
around to define so it's not a random
just pull a car over
but it's uh i have a reason and this is
my reason i can not only do i know it i
can articulate it to the court right in
my police report so i i think the
standards have all been established
around this and and i think the probably
one place where i'd recommend interim
study is we've granted this 594 powers
over here which is the full-blown police
powers
but then we also have the 206 powers
over here which is slightly different
um from from the full-blown powers and
so
i think if anything an interim study
would allow somebody to give us give us
time to look at those two differential
statutes that govern powers of a
conservation officer and then we've
overlapped with powers of a police
officer and give us time to review that
and have the rest of the year to look at
that and recommend possible if there is
something that could clarify those two
powers laws then let's do that but i
don't think this bill does it because it
only talks about 206. it doesn't talk
about 594 at all and so that would be my
reasoning for supporting an interim
study is to allow that definition to see
if there is conflict between there to do
an interim study of that and have the
committee meet to discuss the different
differentials between those two powers
if they exist and if they do how can we
further clarify it
so
representative splain
thank you mr chair
if we were able to put this to interim
study to address the concerns that you
outlined i would
wholeheartedly invite colonel jordan to
join in to try to address the situations
that he has
pointed out himself make his training
hard and make him want to throttle
whoever wrote it originally
because i believe that consensus could
become two that would make his job
and with that we're going to close the
public hearing on house bill 1091 i'm
going to open it up into exec exec
session on 1091 and represent recognize
representative uh
love i think is going to make an
interesting study motion
i'd like to make a
interim study motion
and i'll second that myself
is there any further discussion i think
we've talked it to death uh further
there being none the clerk will call the
role the motion is on house bill 1091 to
move it to interim study to give us an
microphone
on the motion for interim study on 1091
uh
representative spelaine
yes
representative johnson
representative kittredge
representative lucas
yes
representative smith yes
representative jack
no
representative king
rep oh sorry representative clerk the
clerk will vote yes
and mr chair yes
the vote is 11 to 9.
the vote 11-9 is recommended for interim
study
considering we had a mix of republican
and democrats on the minority side
who wants to take lead on a minority
report
will there be a minority report
representative flam will do the minority
report representative level to the
majority report
and that closed the executive session
now we're going to do it we only have
two speakers so i'm gonna jump into
um
next one is
631.
we have
three speakers on this which i think
will be through representative johnson
if you want to do the introduction i'm
going to open a public hearing on house
bill 1631 relevant hunting and fishing
licenses for disabled persons i
recognize representative smith who will
be introducing the bill and speak to the
bill
thank you mr chairman and fellow
committee members so
a constituent reached out to me um and i
enclosed testimony in this email early
this morning to the whole committee
um regarding this very situation
rsa 214 13c presently allows a reduced
uh
hunting and fission licenses for a
paraplegic or permanent loss of both
lower extremities
the change going forward is going to
look to expand it to
a permanent and total disability as
certified by the united states depart
department of veteran affairs or the
united states social security
administration
the person that does apply would be
required to pay the entire license fee
for the year of application but from
that point forward the license is for
life
i also added into the bill that if a
physician who falsely certifies a
disability for the purpose of dissection
shall be guilty of a violation subject
to a 500 fine
i'm just going to read the testimony
here it's a quick email short from the
person that asked me to submit this bill
um
i have been disabled since 1989. i have
had multiple surgeries on my neck fused
from c2 to c7 multiple surgeries on my
back in the lumber area unable to work
at any capacity i always purchased a
catch and release license for many years
as fishing was something i could do to
relax that is no longer possible i am 66
years old now and to purchase a fishing
license at full price to go fishing
eight to ten times a year at best only
to catch and release is truly unfair the
disabled person and retired person
already has a decreased income the
outdoor activities that each of us can
do are limited some of us have limited
mobility the state of new hampshire has
made our love of fishing impossible to
afford i only hope that the state of new
hampshire will consider either lowering
the age for a free license or bring back
to catch a release license now i
understand that signed by william dixon
14 stone view road ossipee new hampshire
zero three eight six four
i understand with every bill there's a
cause and effect the effect is this is
gonna lower income to the fish and game
department which is which is a hardship
mean being that they run on a tight
budget every year
and i do understand at some point there
may be an amendment coming forward to
offset that revenue by another means but
at this time that is point is still up
for discussion
thank representative any questions for
representative smith
thank you
mr chairman c members of this committee
for the record my name is mark mcconkey
i hail from freedom and i represent the
good people of carol iii
the representative that spoke previous
had approached me on this i know the
individual having
lived in ospie for a number of years
i believe the legislation has merit
and i would ask that you would support
this bill with thought to pass thank you
for that thank you representatives any
questions
thank you for coming for the fish and
last up is our good friend colonel
jordan
thank you mr chairman for the
opportunity to testify on this i'm not
this is the first time i've ever reached
this table and not been comfortable to
testify
because i have some strong beliefs that
veterans deserve everything and more
than what we we are currently giving
them the problem is
we voted we being the commission voted
to oppose the bill and they did it
strictly because of the fiscal impacts
you know we're a self-funded agency
and as i said earlier in the hike safe
bill we struggle to fund everything
we currently offer these licenses to
individuals that are service connected
100 disability we follow i actually did
a little research on this when they
asked me to speak on it
we follow department of safety motor
vehicles and department of safety who
offer registrations and licenses under
the same guidelines for we offer it free
both agencies do for people that have
service connected disabilities so if
it's not service connected we don't do
it if it's 80 percent
we give them a reduced cost
so i looked at what we're trying to do
here the two two concerns i had here one
is it lists a physical disa list the
disability is just being a disability
so i would just encourage legislate all
of you to remember that that disability
could be emotional so we could have
someone with a primary back problem but
he's but diagnosed as a bipolar uh which
got him up to the 100 percent so that's
concerning to me
uh in the past it was always physical
disabilities the language in this just
says disability so we could have
emotional or physical the other concern
i have is we're asking
it's a charitable thing i think it's i
think i have a long history in my family
of
service to the military and serviced as
you could guest service the tire family
has done that so i have some
very
very strong opinions about veterans
uh and what they deserve
um i think it's a little unfair to ask
the sportsmen and women to fund it i
think it should be funded by all
citizens if we're going to give out a
benefit like this because all citizens
have benefited from their service
so with that thought process in mind i'm
going to go out on the limb here and
suggest that we do it with a number
plate and a license
and the reason i say that is it's always
bothered me that a veteran comes home as
my son did after four tours on iraq
wishing to get a veterans plate no
interest in hunting which is sad hunted
all the time with me i've never been
able to this day 20 years later been
able to get him to go back out which is
kind of sad so i i think there are a lot
of veterans out there that wouldn't take
advantage of this that in fact deserve
something like this so i thought of the
number plates and the licenses because
no matter the physical disability all
veterans have got to have a vehicle i'm
quite convinced most of them have
licenses
the department of safety at the risk
that they're going to be very angry at
me for suggesting this as a general
funded agency so be quite simple for
them to go back to the general fund the
next budget and ask for the increased
money to make up for this i think that
offers the opportunity for all taxpayers
to contribute to it instead of just the
sportsmen and women the other factor in
our our physical impacts that uh we have
had chairman language reached out to us
to try in
many ways to find out what that impact
would be fiscal impacts i talked to pam
ellis and
beat the folks over at
fiscal here
trying to come up with a reasonable
impact that that would have on us
fiscally and the problem is we don't
know what that would be because we have
a law that that allows maine and vermont
residents reciprocity so
opening this standard up would also open
up the opportunity for maine and vermont
to come in here and get this same
benefit on a new hampshire license
the monies that we lose on new hampshire
licenses
not only include the price of the
license but it includes includes a
habitat fee for fishing and a habitat
fee for wildlife management
that we use to purchase the fast ever
fast vanishing public lands that would
be lost
we use the money for federal match when
we get federal money to manage our
wildlife and our resources that would
take a hit if we're giving these
licenses out free
uh so
um and and our pr money pittman roberts
money which as you know is very valuable
to to wildlife management and our dingle
johnson money which is very valuable to
our fisheries management all are
distributed to each state based on the
number of paid licenses we would lose
some of that
or could lose some of that so for all of
those concerns
we are here in opposition of it but i i
got to tell you that's the only reason i
oppose it i think it i think veterans
deserve much more than they get to me it
just made sense to give them their
plates and their licenses because i
think they would all benefit from that
and i think all citizens would be able
to say they've now contributed to that
representative spelling
thank you mr chair question
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question colonel jordan um
i just to clarify
because you're talking a lot about
veterans you understand that the way
this bill is written it's actually
affecting anyone with a disability and i
think i would ask if do you remember
a couple of years i ushered through with
that
in fact the whole department helped
quite a bit
gave the veterans themselves the 80
percent to 99
half-price lifetime license
because we only had the 100
total disability and that also exempted
uh reciprocity from maine and vermont in
order to make that happen
and be fiscally viable
um
those things aren't in here but this
also addresses a larger population of
anyone who's disabled not just veterans
right this would open it up for a number
of people the other question i had
it strikes the language for paraplegics
and those folks with permanent loss of
the lower use of their extremities now
i'm assuming those people would go and
get that 100 percent disability
but i think it's important to understand
it would strike that benefit for them
currently the way it's written so that's
another concern i had with that and
you're right it would open the door for
many many more
to make many more people eligible for it
my follow-up uh would be
when we did the other bill for the
military veterans that were disabled
from 80 to 99
it was based on the 50 of their lifetime
license cost based on your actuary
tables
this written as it is just has them pay
the regular fee for a yearly license
once and then it expands
do you know what the difference is in
cost because i know lifetime licenses
are a lot more but as you get older they
become less and less expensive so in
some instances this could be more
lifetime license if it was written that
way in some instances it would be a lot
uh less
yes i would agree with you but like my
lifetime license would probably be 10
bucks
a 20 year old uh who they expect to live
much longer would be a lot more money so
it would that is and that was all of the
issues that we struggled with trying to
come up with a fiscal impact i don't
know that i can accurately predict it
and then my other concern i'll be very
frank my other concern is there are
numerous times that we are promised
general fund
infusions if you will or short money to
go in at budget creation and then
through the budget process that gets
pulled out so
i'm really concerned about the fiscal
impact we're at this agency's at a point
where we're struggling to make ends meet
quite frankly uh we're a self-funded
agency and i just i don't think this is
the place to be giving stuff away i just
don't know that we can do that i think
it's risky i'd i would much rather see
these people benefit from a license
plate or a driver's license that
everybody can contribute to
uh and everybody in those situations
uses
i don't think 100 there are a lot of 100
percent disabled people that would hunt
all good points thank you jordan further
questions from the committee
representative reed
thank you
thank you colonel jordan um
so
obviously i understand that if you give
a discount on a license and you have
already several discounts for veterans
and disabled people
um including some free licenses
uh that that is a loss of revenue for
those people who would have otherwise
bought
said license not obviously it's not a
loss of revenue if some of those people
could not have afforded those licenses
without the discount right so you're not
taking a hit on that so i guess my
question is
and i've offered this before before this
committee in terms passed if we were to
change the current structure which is
kind of sort of a hodgepodge of
different
discounts and license
given to veterans and disabled people
based on different criteria
got rid of that covered those disabled
people and veterans who were under a
certain income by income only so now
you're opening the doors to everyone who
currently is not
coming in sufficient game and giving you
revenue
but those disabled people and veterans
who can't afford to buy a license would
then buy a license
as i understand that that would not
impact your revenue and i guess i'm
asking you if you would understand it
the same way
well i don't know that i that i could
say it wouldn't it would would certainly
reduce the impact of the revenue i think
uh it would we
i think we'd be in the same boat uh kind
of guessing it what that would do but
you're right that would be a
better way i think than opening it up to
what this would do
i just think if we if we're going to
give money away
we and the and the and taxpayers feel
that this is viable then we all ought to
contribute to it not just the hunters or
the fishermen i think everybody should
contribute to it to be fair and the way
to do that so with that thought process
i did a little research the only way i
could see to do that was through and
they're going to hate me for it but
through department of safety with number
plates or driver's licenses that's
something all of these folks can use
and and if you just take the money you
save from registering your vehicle and
buying a driver's license you could
probably purchase a hunting license
now you know where you may not have been
able to before but just something else
representative oregon for a question and
a potential follow-up well thank you
very much mr chair thank you very much
colonel hum
um the
person
we're being asked to make law based on
an anecdote about the
gentleman from ossipee i don't know if
you've reviewed the letter but he's 66
years old and
he feels he can no longer purchase a
phishing license what would the price be
for a
senior
a
senior citizen who wants to get a
fishing license
yeah so uh a senior citizen can now buy
i think can buy that at ten dollars
gentlemen right
seven dollars
right
yeah seven dollars as a senior citizen
you know
i would buy his license if he couldn't
afford a seven dollar license i would
pay for that to get him to let the guy
fish
thank you you're welcome sir
any further discussion
all right so i'm going to give it
chairman's perspective i guess so
i i you can say there colonel in case
you have a comment uh from what i say
um
[Music]
i share the department's concern about
if the legislature keeps chipping away
at their revenue sources um it's going
to become harder and harder for their
for the department to stay stay afloat
without starting to cut services
um which which cause causes me concern i
originally when i looked at this bill
and i am a co-sponsor of the bill was i
talked to colonel jordan and director
mason about maybe we put some general
fund monies behind this to make the
department whole right for the year so
if you issue a license at a discount on
the mount they can draw from this fund
to make it the full amount and they
could
they would be a hunter as a hunter it
doesn't matter what the what the fee
goes but i i think from listen to
testimony that becomes problematic as
well um because you're
you're at the mercy of future
legislators legislatures to continue
that program and continue that to go on
um so
my inclination on this bill is itl even
though i hate to do that but that's my
inclination and i'm trying to get a
sense of the committee if they're also
along with that idea
represent sherlock
thank you mr chairman um
you know my hack goes out to the
individual philosophy is there any
chance to hold
uh this bill in advance until our next
session and may possibly in the interim
uh work with the colonel and come up
with an amendment to this bill so that
something could be done
if the committee wants to do that i'm
happy again i'm happy to do that i'm
trying to get a consensus where we are i
i think our i was trying to do that
before this meeting to get a funding
source for them to be able to put money
into a fund so again we can make them
whole so they don't start losing money
by issuing because we actually don't
know what the impact of this is going to
be so it could be one license or it
could be a thousand licenses we have no
clue just a follow-up it may be that we
do end up itl in this bill at our next
session but if there's some chance in
that interim period that something could
be worked out i'd rather keep that race
sunshine
is that the will of the committee
okay great so we will hold off executive
session on this and we will consider it
on the 25th and see any member that
thinks they have an idea feel free to
reach out to the department and see if
they can work out a solution and get
some language
i just asked to try to get any
amendments to the committee before the
25th so we have time to review them and
have intelligent conversation on the
25th thank you colonel thank you thank
you sir
all right with that we are going to take
a 27 minute break and we'll be back here
at one o'clock um for house bill
it's gonna be tight cafeteria know it
i'm gonna go over there and try to get a
there's
yes
stupid
now
yes
um
is
they're losing twice the amount because
you
we want to again get going here
representative hill did you uh submit a
pink guide
okay well just know we're a very big
stickler on rules around here so you
better get that pink card in
oh now you're right you're here
so
all right guys let's go and grab our
seats
all right i'm going to call the public
hearing on house bill 1297 into order
and the chair recognizes representative
greg hill
to introduce and speak to the bill
representative welcome to the fish and
game committee
thank you mr chairman
[Music]
so i've handed out a couple of pieces
for the record i am representative greg
hill
i represent
northfield
i am here to speak on house bill
which deals with
lobstering while engaged in recreational
scuba diving
this is the
i don't know third third time i think
i've been here we passed it three times
in the house as i recall
the senate
has played games with it a couple of
times and
the
one time it died on a table when we were
having other issues
but typically it does pretty well in the
house
and i've given you three pieces of
information one is my testimony that you
can read at your
leisure um
but i've also given you the executive
summary
from the atlantic states marine
fisheries commission
which new hampshire sends
a representative from the fish and game
department as well
this is the executive summary of a
560 page report which i didn't print out
for us
um
but it uh i did highlight a couple of
areas in here that i think
speak to
uh
very
committee room in the past
dealing uh with
um
availability of lobsters in our
gulf of maine
and the utilization of our
lobsters in the gulf of maine
and this
basically is telling you
that
current abundance in the gulf of maine
stock is at record high abundance
estimates show an increasing trend
starting in 1988 and accelerating
so it would seem to me
from their words not mine that
the stock is not depleted and
overfishing is not occurring
this has been an issue that's come up in
in this committee in the past
there's actually even a graph to show
you
the rate of increase on the last page of
that marine
fisheries commission
i've also given you
some
information specific to new hampshire
that
is one of four pages here
and
and i've highlighted the areas that i
want you to concentrate on
one is saying that our recreational
catch in new hampshire
currently is about half of one percent
of all new hampshire inshore lobster
landings
new hampshire currently allows
five traps
by
non-resid i'm sorry by resident
um non-commercial people
and and that has been claimed in in past
hearings to be sufficient to allow
equal access to uh
to all residents of new hampshire
and we've made the case that uh it's not
really equal access because uh in order
to
to satisfy those five traps you need to
have a boat you can't just throw them
off your
wharf
you need to have a boat that's
accessible to the coast
so you can access it on to to service
the
fishing gear
and you need to have the time available
from either a uh
very
thoughtful spouse or boss that lets you
every couple of days
service your fishing gear
so
if you contrast that with our current
situation where a diver perhaps could
come down out of claremont or
lebanon or somewhere and and go when it
fits
their schedule
it would certainly allow
many more people in new hampshire to
access
this natural resource
um also in the past
one
so the issues we've we've written
come into in the in past hearings were
the stock
overfishing
recreational impact
and
all of the reports are saying here that
recreational impact up and down the east
coast
is negligible and therefore ignored
new hampshire and maine are the only two
states that don't allow scuba divers or
free divers to access the natural
resource of lobsters
um
but the two issues that uh that come
about in the senate are safety and
enforcement
so i'd like to concentrate for just a
minute on those two
um
i've asked for
since we first submitted this bill back
and or i first submitted it i think 2011
for any documentation from any of the
coastal states on the east coast of the
us
where
divers and
commercial lobstermen have uh have
interacted and
that's that documentation has yet to
uh be
provided
we've done extensive research and have
not found any cases of
of it being a safety issue
that we need to be concerned about
divers are currently in that those areas
where commercial
lobstermen are currently working
now that happens
i bet it's happening right now as we
speak
so and we've not heard of any any
problems with any of that
as far as enforcement goes um i would
point out that this bill is a five-year
pilot program
it's covering only the two months of
september and october
so that we can assess whether safety is
an issue or incidents have occurred
it allows five lobsters per day limit
and the only effective change for the
conservation officer's duties
to restrict
the taking of five lobsters where now
they're able to
um enforce with existing staff
a zero tolerance um this would simply be
counting to five um and allowing
five lobsters to be taken
um the size the sex the everything
is already being enforced on all
non-commercial and commercial
bases so this would simply be
making sure what they're enforcing is
zero would now be five
and the and the lobster
and the divers would be identified by
the number on their
dive flag so
i think uh with that i'll end my
testimony i'm happy to answer any
questions i'm sure there's more than a
few pink cards that
have to be called
but
any
any questions that you have i'm happy to
uh
i'm happy to listen to those
now
thank you representative hill does
everyone know we have nine other cards
for this bill um any questions for
representative hill
i did a great job thank you
representative hill appreciate it
uh next up is
um
chris
patterson
from the new hampshire fish and game
department speak in opposition to the
bill
that's great
good afternoon is that better thank you
good afternoon mr chair and members of
the committee
for the record my name is sheree
patterson i'm the chief of marine
fisheries of the fish and game
department
and just
to clarify
that the fish and game commission has
also voted to oppose house bill 1297
in relation to
taking lobsters while engaged in scuba
diving
um the new hampshire's lobster fishery
is the state's most valuable commercial
fishery
contributing more than 34 million
annually
34 million dollars annually in revenue
to the more than
330 licensed commercial harvesters
if you add in the recreational
harvesters you're adding in another
couple hundred
certain economic models suggest the
overall contribution to new hampshire's
economy is likely three to four times
that amount
and that would equate to roughly
102 to 130 as such this is a highly
regulated
fishery tree with a variety of rules and
laws
designed to maintain a healthy lobster
resource and a robust fishery for new
hampshire's economy
while the lobster population in the gulf
of maine as the representative just
indicated is not depleted and over
and over fishing is not occurring
the atlantic states marine fisheries
commissioned 2020 lobster stock
assessment has raised concerns over the
lack of young of the year recruitment in
recent years
since in fact 19 2012 it has started to
go down and this is not just within new
hampshire waters where we sample but
also in the gulf of maine where the
other
states are involved in doing young of
so this could translate to having lower
numbers of harvestable lobsters in our
every resident of new hampshire has
access to
recreational harvest of lobsters
utilizing
so the legislature before us does not
solve the problem of providing access to
another user
recreational group
that has been not been denied access
get the lobster license and lobster
traps and
yes they can throw them off their dock
if they like or
go out in the
the department has four significant
concerns about the effects of this bill
one being enforcement
one being damage to the lobsters from
handling
degradation of marine habitat and the
increase in user conflicts
from an enforcement perspective the
presents an immense challenge for law
enforcement even now
there are reported conflicts between
lobster trap harvesters and scuba divers
if the divers are anywheres near
the
lobster traps that have been set
complaints
from this community
of scuba divers are that they've been
poaching
lobsters from these individuals traps
and this requires a considerable amount
of covert law enforcement
activity to
apprehend any sort of violators
in
enforcement observation is limited due
to issues such as but not limited to
visibility from the surface if they're
in their vessels
inability to operate vessels near divers
the current law prohibiting the
possession of lobsters by a diver has
been a sufficient deterrent to tampering
with traps in most instances
the deterrent effective of the current
law would no longer be enforced
during an open season for taking
lobsters by diving
and
the ease in which lobsters of legal size
can be found in lobster traps is
enticing
um
and it would help them select for
legal-sized lobsters
at a faster level
if this legislation is signed into law
the best evidence for a successful
prosecution would be to observe the
divers actually taking lobsters from the
traps which would require
conservation officers to be diving
in the immediate area and observing this
sort of illegal activity
in effect this would make prosecution of
a diver taking a lobster from a
harvester's trap nearly impossible
secondly we are concerned about the
effect this method of capture may
have on the lobsters themselves
while trap fishing is a passive form of
capture scuba diving is an active form
that involves grabbing and oftentimes
chasing a fleeing
lobster to catch it
a lobster will shed one or both of its
claws during this active form of capture
in an attempt to escape
scuba divers will encounter and handle
legally undersized lobsters for each
legal size lobster they incur encounter
and lobsters will eventually hate the
lost claws
effect
is a short-term loss
of any sort of
harvestability for these lobsters that
are caught within the traps
so
commercial harvesters will have what's
called cults in their in their traps
which are of
lower value economic value
in addition newly molted soft cell
lobsters hide under rocks for several
weeks until their shells have hardened
they're vulnerable to this kind of
handling a newly molted lobster body is
literally like jello
and when handled could uh sustain severe
or life-threatening damage to its uh to
its internal organs many factors control
when the lobster with will molt so it's
hard to determine
a particular
timing or season
for when
lobsters will be molting however
during our sampling we have found
molting lobsters to occur between june
next we're concerned about the negative
effect that this habit this method of
harvest would have on the nearshore
habitat lobsters spend most of their
time burrowed
mud holes wherever they can hide
after the surface floating life stages
the post larval will settle to the
bottom
in september and in october that's when
they're settling
and trying to find their their niche
trying to find their habitat
disruption to this habitat will affect
their survivability
the university of maine's lobster
institute has determined that for every
50 000 eggs only about two lobsters are
expected to survive to legal size they
need their habitat they need to be able
to
[Music]
take cover
find
find what they need to eat
in order to even get up to a decent
legal size so any sort of habitat
disruption
moving rocks to try to get to the
lobsters and such
would be
affecting their habitat in general
these habitats are not
just for lobsters but numerous species
of marine invertebrates and plants that
form the foundation to the marine
ecosystem to capture lobsters divers
would need to turn over many rocks on
every diving
trip damaging or killing marine life
that is attached to the top of them and
are rummaging through areas of eel grass
beds disrupting their
their root system the cumulative effect
of a couple hundred licensed divers
making even just one lobster dive per
year along our short
coastline is could be significant
as i mentioned earlier the lobster trap
is a passive capture device and several
rules have been implemented regarding
trap construction to
minimize their impact um on the lobster
resource in their habitat for example
all traps have what we call runners they
they lift the trap up off the bottom of
the ocean
so that there's not as much
and
in addition that the traps are required
to have escape vents to
permit escapement of the juveniles or
undersized lobsters as well as they need
biodegradable
escape panels to allow
the adult lobsters to get out of these
traps if
after a period of time the traps aren't
raised or they're lost in storms there's
ways for them to be able to escape in
the future finally i would like to
provide some insight as to why we feel
it is important for new hampshire to
continue to limit lobster harvest to
traps only
while
our states to the south of us allow
harvest by other methods including scuba
in addition to the reasons previously
mentioned relating to law enforcement
the lobster resource itself and the
habitat new hampshire is unique in
having by far the smallest coastline in
the u.s
this results in a higher potential for
conflicts between
the many users of the marine resources
in our short coastline
so the challenge to
coastline has always been to provide
access to the state's marine resources
while maintaining healthy populations of
fish lobsters
oysters
as well as their habitats
the department has worked with past
legislatures to pass laws to seek
[Music]
this accomplishment
for balancing
of lobster versus all the other user
and we have actually in the past
and currently prohibited such as
prohibiting the use of mobile fishing
gear
like autotrolls in the state of new
hampshire
again these are to prevent these sort of
in conclusion we want to emphasize that
any new hampshire resident can currently
harvest lobsters recreational in the
state
via the five-trap license
the department believes the current
system of harvesting lobsters by traps
provides a uniform enforcement
opportunity while trying to provide
balanced access to the resource
you will also hear
today from the
chair of the
advisory committee on marine fisheries
who's also opposed to this legislation
i thank you for the opportunity to
testify today and the department
respectfully urges the committee to
oppose house bill
thank you for testimony questions from
the committee representative smith
you're recognized for a question and a
potential follow-up thank you mr
chairman and thank you for your
testimony i have a follow-up to your
comment regarding the lobsters losing
claws upon handling
is that something they drop
simultaneously upon being touched or is
there a lag or is it multiple times or
how does it happen
so
as you're diving you're trying to grab
uh can you hear me okay you can trying
to grab whatever you
you can to grab the lobster right if you
grab a claw it will drop its claw if
you're gonna grab one or two you know
whatever you're gonna grab to stuff it
in your die bag
they will they will drop their claws
once they drop their claws it's going to
take a period of time for regeneration
during that period of time of
regeneration it's
several
weeks to a couple months
and there's you've lost the economic
value of that lobster for any of the
commercial fishery that's out there at
that point in time i don't know when you
go to a
restaurant or to a store
you'll see culls
and they're at a reduced price due to
the
lack of one or two claws from that
was there another question just a
follow-up on that is that i guarantee
they lose their claw or is it is i mean
is there
i'm trying to understand if it's every
time someone pulls on the claw does it
come off
maybe maybe not okay yeah okay when i
would be out diving and would do
something like that during our research
further questions from any committee
i have one question around actually two
but one around the poaching comment you
made so cur
currently are there any prosecutions for
people poaching lobsters from traps are
you i'm familiar with any uh scuba
divers have
have poached uh have ticketed or charged
somebody for taking lobsters
lieutenant when you step up to and sit
next to your colleague here and you can
both and just restate your name so the
it's gonna hit the button too there we
go now lights on
good afternoon everyone my name is
delane brown conservation officer
lieutenant with new hampshire fish and
game department i currently supervise
the seacoast district
we do not have any current cases pending
right now
or charges pending
but it does does happen in the past and
we get numerous complaints from the
commercial fishermen the lobstermen
that
are claiming that uh their traps are
getting poached but it's extremely
difficult to prove
okay and just one follow-up question so
we we heard from representative hill
talking about our community to the south
has had no reported instances of
conflict i think you called it user
conflict in in in your testimony um that
there's been no reported cases of user
conflict between lobstermen and scuba
divers where it's allowed in
massachusetts on their coastline
is that is two knowledge is that true is
that accurate or is or
are you aware of any cases where
lobstermen and fish and scuba divers
went fisticuffs
i i don't know of any information from
our colleagues in law enforcement
natural resource law and law enforcement
in massachusetts i i don't know what
they have for information i could
certainly inquire and follow up if
necessary thank you any further
questions from the committee
represent
thank you mr chairman
my question is towards the enforcement
aspect
we have only 19 miles of our sea
coastline
and some of the neighbors have 100 miles
or even more
uh the question is
do you think that uh if bill passes you
know it's gonna hurt you're gonna have a
hard time to
enforce the existing law
currently we heard that
the
is a highly regulated industry highly
so
do you think that this is my question do
you think that you're going to have to
open up a new wing of
enforcement
and within your department
thank you for your question um
right now
we're i'm sure everyone's aware we're
very short staffed um i'm currently
working with uh
three other officers in a district that
should be a total of five
um in order for us to prosecute
or to uh to cite a violation of
of uh lobsters being taken out of traps
or by hand uh we'd have to witness that
that violation um
it would be difficult unless we are
underwater uh watching the diver as as
he's doing it as uh as chief patterson
gave in her testimony
for us to approach
a diver underwater if they had their
dive flag up we have to be super super
careful with our vessels
and
getting close enough to observe a
violation of this actually happening
what is happening is is nearly
impossible unfortunately the uh the
lobsters aren't good witnesses they
don't have much to testify to
um so we'd have we'd have to prove it
with other law enforcement methods uh
interviewing the
lobster harvesters after the fact
uh or
you know
i'm not sure how else to do it it's it's
uh it's very difficult they're
underwater and limited visibility um
and uh
for other questions for a fish and game
seeing them thank you very much for your
testimony thank you um mr jim to tone uh
yankee fisherman's cooperative in
mr chairman members of the committee
thank you for allowing me to provide
testimony in the opposition of this bill
on behalf of the more than 60 members of
the yankee fisherman's co-op i
appreciate the opportunity to provide
public comment in opposition to house
bill 1297
the lobster industry in new hampshire is
a valuable economic driver for the state
however the lobster resource is
presently under a tremendous amount of
pressure
there's pressure from climate change
federal government regulations the
potential loss of rich fishing grounds
due to offshore wind
and from fishing pressure itself
sustainability of the lobster fishery
and the lobster resource has been and
will continue to be a top priority for
the lobster fishes in this state
to execute this commitment to
sustainability
lobster fishermen will expend a
substantial portion of their gross
income
on the purchases of lobsterbait
for example in 2021
of my gross lobster income went to the
purchase of lobsterbait
dr robert stennik from the university of
maine's lobster institute
has conducted studies and in his studies
he has found that lobster bait
and lobster in lobster traps
is the main food supply of lobsters and
dr stennik concluded that baited lobster
traps
may actually be the largest aquaculture
effort in the world
this research by dr stennik is evidence
that baited lobster traps are a key
element to lobster sustainability
scuba diving for lobsters on the other
hand is a deterrent to sustainability
after all with diving
it's all take and no give
if an activity such as diving does not
contribute to the sustainability of this
resource then it should be prohibited
for climate change
changing climate conditions are
affecting the water temperatures in the
gulf of maine more than any other body
of water
warming temperatures are affecting the
juvenile lobster recruitment according
to dr richard wally
executive director of the university of
maine's lobster institute
the juvenile lobster settlement
is the is peaked and will decline as
water temperatures rise above the
optimal limits
dr wally concluded this decline in
juvenile lobster settlement has raised
concerns over the future of the region's
lobster fishery
another concern with warming waters is
the migration of large breeding females
from inshore habitats to offshore areas
north and east where water temperatures
are more conducive for breeding
activities
changing climate conditions in warmer
waters have also contributed to the
northwood migration of new lobster
predators
such as
black sea bass and trigger fish
in addition
there's a higher risk with the warmer
waters of shell disease in lobster
for
pressure on the fishery in 2006
the part-time commercial license
category was enacted into law in new
hampshire allowing each holder
to fish 100 traps
in 2021 there were 223 licenses issued
in this category
being an open license fishery there is
no limit to the number of licenses which
can be issued
over the last four years there have been
21 new part-time commercial licenses out
of this category the newly introduced
traps in this category has caused
additional strain to the lobster
resource which goes unchecked
like any activity related to the lobster
industry there are unscrupulous
characters who are willing to violate
rules and regulations
scooping diving for lobsters
is no exception in massachusetts with
scuba diving philosophers is legal there
have been a number of incidences where
divers have been apprehended
with undersized egg-bearing and
v-notched females
a large egg-bearing of v-notch female
lobster has the capability of carrying
up to a hundred thousand eggs
v-notch females have the ability to
remain in the water for as many as three
to four shedding cycles
which means she'll have the ability to
produce eggs for multiple years
v-notch females and bearing females
are so important to this fishery we
cannot afford to lose any of that brood
stock
preserving the strong brood stock for
the lobster industry is critically
important
component in maintaining the lobster
resource
with all the challenges facing the
lobster industry from climate change
existing fishing pressure difficulty
enforcement lack of contribution to
sustainability of the lobster resource
i would urge this committee to consider
the continued prohibition of scuba
diving for lobsters in new hampshire
thank you for your time
thank you for your testimony any
questions from mr titon
mr i just have one question for you you
were talking about lops about scuba
divers taking
egg bearing undersize edge bearing and
undersized lobsters massachusetts there
was an event in december of 2020 where
two divers were caught what 18 lobsters
16 of which were undersized and two were
egg-bearing
to your knowledge and follow-up is to
your knowledge um if we would have that
same discussion around lobsterman do you
know how many violations there have been
can you repeat that please so if we
discuss that same topic of egg bearing
or undersized lobster given the lobster
industry do you know how many violations
have occurred
on those same two topics within the
current lobster model that i don't
but
if i had my way anybody who would be
caught with an egg-bearing female
lobsters should be banned for life from
fishing in the state
thank you very much for the time no
problem thank you sir
next up is gino marconi i got it right
representing the marine fisheries
committee
oh good morning well good afternoon once
again uh mr chairman members of the
committee uh for the record gino marconi
i'm the chairman of the marine fisheries
advisory committee it's established
under rsa 211 colon 62.
um this this
type of legislation has come before this
committee
the marine fisheries committee
several times
i'm not going to take a lot of time
because uh
chief patterson uh
summed it summed it up and that's the
same position that the committee takes
they agree with fish and games position
and the committee voted to oppose this
piece of legislation i know there are
other people that are want to talk so
i'm going to leave it at that any
questions for miss
mr marconi
being none thank you sir thank you for
your time
next up is eric anderson opposing the
bill from the new hampshire commercial
thank you mr chairman and committee
represent the concerns of the new
hampshire commercial fisherman's
association with regards to the subject
we had we've had the opportunity to
review this
legislation and union ultimately
all members of this
in our opinion that even with some of
the conditional changes that have been
submitted from different uh prior years
of similar legislation the issues that
cause concern still remain and have not
been attended to with the submission of
this host bill 1297 while other
testimony in opposition to the bill will
reveal important circumstances of the
legitimate and valid concern
this association agrees with those
issues or would like to focus its
comments on two distinct matters
safety
introducing and allowing the ability of
scuba divers to take lobsters presents a
safety issue that without doubt is
important
since the law since the commercial trap
fishery is long established as a means
of to harvest this resource for the
general public's consumption the means
and practice of scuba diving
for recreational harvesting creates an
operational conflict that can result
when both trapped fishermen and scuba
divers are in the same location
as a trap fisherman is hauling their
gear
possibly a lobster trawl of upwards to
10 traps in the same proximity of a
scuba diver the lines attaching the gear
to the traps
or in the operation of his vessels
can have a very negative consequence
consequences to the scuba diver
as in line entanglement
or serious propeller injuries if the
diver is forced to surface
while neither the trap fisherman or the
diver know the exact location of each
other or the circumstances that both are
experiencing the negative consequences
that could result without doubt create
possibilities that far outweigh the
purpose of this legislation
it would be ultimately disastrous in
hindsight to have this
legislation allow these circumstances to
unfold and in our opinion presents one
of the most important reasons to oppose
it
enforcement you've heard some of the
concerns
while previous testimony this
organization expressed its concerns over
enforcement issues the additional burden
of the new hampshire fish and game
officers to monitor compliance issues
with scuba divers in the taking of
officers presents an additional
legitimate challenge
many circumstances of enforcement
require an on-scene presence of these
officers and their ability to perform
diving surveillance on scuba diving
activity
along the shore or by the boats that
scuba divers might use in harvesting
lobsters from a logistic matter
this might be considered very
overwhelmingly
if not impossible in their capacity for
proper enforcement which is a critical
part of any legislation
placing additional enforcement
responsibility that would result in
considering these legislation dilutes
the limited enforcement capability that
currently exists and ultimately can harm
the resources
the resource for those that don't comply
these are
these are what we feel are the most
important reasons to oppose this
legislation
as said earlier
we electronically submitted this
throughout the industry and our
membership
and
our written testimony reflects 14
responses that were taken prior to
um
and and
a
response very recently until this
morning that included over 25 full-time
lobster fisherman
and so we would oppose this legislation
and hope the committee will oppose it in
any fashion
thank you thank you mr anderson any
questions for miss anderson
seeing none thank you so every testimony
and coming for the fish and game
committee
next up is michael flanagan
excuse me good afternoon thank you very
much for giving me the opportunity to
speak
as i said earlier this morning
my brother and i have both been fishing
commercially for 66 years we both hold
1200 trap licenses
my sons have a wholesale
air freight business on the waterfront
in kittery my whole family is
deeply involved
seriously financially involved in
lobster fishery
i've come to concord several times to
speak in opposition the skin diving bill
it's it's ridiculous way to harvest
lobsters the baited trap has proven
through the industry the only
sustainable way to harvest lobsters not
sparing not diving not dragging
the baited trap
you folks can relate to this our baited
traps are very similar to our bird
feeders
but we have i have five vents in my
traps
the lobster of all sizes come in feed
and swim out like the birds do hopefully
the big ones get caught that's the way
that's the way the baited trap works
i can go on all afternoon about my
experience i've been a lot of places
done a lot of things but primarily
lobstering
without getting too far afield i like to
have about 30 seconds to mention
something you people are probably aware
of you see it in the news you read about
it
it's this whale issue
it's a non-issue
i've been fishing for 66 years i've
never entangled a right whale i know
people all up and down the coast every
association every group of fishermen i
don't know of anybody that's ever
entangled a right whale
this is something that happened years
ago with paulie rope and
the
conflict where the dragons throwing up
our gear and cutting it off since we got
rid of the the paul europe has not
happened
i believe maine has not had an
entanglement of right whale in 14 years
and the national marine fisheries
service wants to shut the fishery down
it's false news
thank you very much if you have any
questions i'd be glad to answer them
thank you for planning any questions for
mr flanagan
seeing none thank you sir coming for the
fish and game commission thank you very
much thank you
next up is jeremiah harkins i believe it
is from back county
thank you for allowing me this
opportunity again my name is jeremiah
harkins i'm resident of grafton
i'm an avid outdoorsman
hunter paddler angler
today i'm speaking on behalf of new
england chapter of backcountry hunters
and anglers which i'll refer to here as
bha i'm a volunteer for the new
hampshire state leadership team
and i am commenting on behalf of our
chapter
bha is the voice of our wild lands
waters and wildlife
we seek to ensure north america's
outdoor heritage of hunting and fishing
in a natural setting by supporting land
conservation public access to hunting
and fishing areas and sound management
of fish and wildlife and their habitats
a core principle of back country owners
and anglers is to support the north
american model of wildlife conservation
this model is the world's most
successful system of policies and laws
to restore and safeguard fish and
wildlife
and their habitat through sound science
and active management
under this model wildlife is held in the
public trust and in our state we've
entrusted wildlife management duties to
the new hampshire fish and game
commission or department
we have also empowered the department
with a set of tools including the
ability to set season dates
limits bag limits length limits and
appropriate methods of take
which combined with current science and
biological evidence allow them to
effectively manage the state's game
species
hb 1297 offers an additional method of
take by eliminating a
legislative restriction
outdoor persons have expressed a desire
to have the opportunity to die for
lobsters
and we support this opportunity and
believe that it can be used to help
manage the lobster fishery
where we find find concern is that the
bill as written will remove essential
management tools from the department
the department
should be making the decisions on bag
limits
seasons and licensing
these decisions need to be motivated and
guided by biological evidence and
management needs as opposed to public
opinion and preference
for these reasons on behalf of bha
members in new hampshire we ask you to
oppose 1297 in its current form and ask
the paragraph
to be
be amended to put decision making back
into the department's controls
thank you for this opportunity to speak
i look forward to your comments
thank you mr harkins questions for mr
harkins
so i i just want to be clear on your
testimony your testimony was you would
support
scuba diver lobstering if fish and game
had the right to manage it and set the
regulations around it rather than have
next up is louis
figueroa i believe it is of
speaking for himself in support of the
bill
thank you chairman lang i appreciate the
opportunity to present
um my name is uh louis figaro i am a uh
dive master and
also serving as a dive guide for aquatic
specialties a local dive shop here in
merrimack new hampshire
and as a
dive guide i lead uh guided dives to uh
to some of the divers in the area that
are doing shore and um charter dives in
the area but i'm also
a diver in massachusetts as i have
property on on cape cod so i have a
lobster license and i have been diving
recreationally for
lobsters off the waters of cape cod and
cape ann with my family
all of my kids have open water
certifications and and have been diving
with me for lobsters as is something we
enjoy doing together
as a safe family activity
but
one of the things i wanted to talk to a
couple issues that were brought up
earlier both the enforcement and safety
one of the the conversations i had in
preparing for this hearing i did have
some conversations with the uh some of
the individuals from environmental
police in massachusetts and uh
and from the department of marine
fisheries i think that's what they're
called the dmf the dive safety officer
and
i completely understand the concerns
about enforcement and the number of
resources that we have to to uh police
police this uh one of the things that i
specifically discussed with them was
that
the
the environmental police in
massachusetts really don't allocate
specific amount of time for
uh
for policing uh diving for for uh
recreationally for lobsters what they do
is they look at this as part of their
overall regular policing activities so
when they do a board and they're looking
at a boat they're checking for permits
they're checking if you're going for
scallops they're looking at the size of
scallops if you're diving for lobsters
they're looking for the size lobsters if
you're fishing they're checking for all
all that stuff so the point is that
you know they
i don't think it's going to be that much
of a burden um to local enforcement but
the other thing i wanted to add was that
um with regards to the comment on
poaching in massachusetts yes there are
bad eggs we know that um
in even here in new hampshire um they're
usually
isolated individuals that are diving
alone that
um that are just doing something they
in general they're stewards of the ocean
they're they're typically policing each
other you're usually as you know diving
not by yourself but with buddies and
you're constantly in the water if you're
going to see someone doing anything
illegal approaching a pot uh taking
lobsters i mean we'll be the first to
to report
those types of activities
on the issue of of safety
you know as
house representative greg hill pointed
out there have been really no uh
incidents
um documented of accidents uh
recreational divers um while uh diving
for lobsters i
use the example of uh
of a commercial officer and pulling up a
chain of pots and a diver getting pulled
up
these are things that typically the
divers tend me personally when i'm going
out especially with my family if i see
if i'm not going to choose to go on a
dive site where people are fishing where
known
fishing activities in place for that
reason because we don't want to you in
general with diving you just don't dive
where they're boats it's just a common
sense so you want to try and stay away
from that area so um
one of the things that i'm trying to
also point out is where we dive we
purposely try to dive in areas um that
that there's no boat traffic so if you
look at the coast of new hampshire it's
very similar a lot of similarities to
cape cod it's very shallow and to get
any depth you have to really swim out
far
um that's where the boats are so where
we would be
diving would be in intertidal areas if
you think of the new hampshire coastline
places like off of odeon point um
at high tide you're lucky to get maybe
um eight nine feet where boats are not
going to be uh fishing if you're diving
there are sections in the um
like for example the piscataqua river
there are deep sections yes
but where commercial lobstermen are
probably fishing but are fishing but and
dropping uh lines and trawls but we're
not
in those sections because we're very
close into the shore where the boats are
not going to be hauling up lobster pots
so
i just wanted to
make sure that everyone understood that
where we dive is in an area where um
where there's there's generally not a
whole lot of boat traffic
the other thing is i also wanted to i
know that we do have the ability to get
lobsters with a tent pot
you have to have a boat and many of us
don't have a boat and this is something
that we feel is a resource that should
be enjoyed by um by
just as i could as a
uh scuba dive for uh scallops or or
other things um
this is something that i just wanted to
to point out about the uh uh
that i think it's something that
should be considered what we're putting
forward is kind of a compromise is kind
of you'll see at the end of this period
um
the amount of uh incidents that are
going to be enforcement issues or
accidents and so or the
impact to the populations could be
negligible
the other thing i just wanted to also
talk about is
this is very important there was a lot
of discussion about damaged lobsters and
the claws being pulled and so on i
wanted to let everyone know that scuba
diving for lobsters is less passive in
my opinion than lobstering with pots
with minimal
disturbance the environment um if i have
a tent pot license or a one pot license
when i'm pulling up my lobster pots out
of the water those pots are being
dragged um and disturbing the rocks and
so on um on the on the bottom as they're
being pulled up the other thing is that
as i bring up my pots if i see shorts or
if i see egg bearing or v-notch uh any
ones that we cannot keep we have to
throw them back so uh i would be
throwing them back into the water and
during that period they'd be susceptible
to
predators such as
striped bass and and then there's the
time that they would need to find to get
to a safe area um me as i uh my
experience diving for lobsters the which
when you're in there you're going to
find a lobster you're going to see one
um
if you're going to see that it's it's
short you're not going to take it if
it's if it's a short but even if you
pull it out and you see that it's uh egg
bearing you're going to leave it where
it is you're going to put it back it's
it's going to be back in a safe area
um
anyone that typically dies for lobsters
you're not picking up um as we heard the
testimony picking up rocks and lifting
up rocks and it's just not the way it's
done because the moment you lift up the
rock that lobster is going to swim away
and i don't know if you know but they
can swim pretty fast with a couple kicks
of the fin they're like 25 30 feet by
the time you can get to them they're
already in another
safe hole or something like that
you don't grab them from the claws
that's the last thing you want to do for
that reason because you're going to pull
the claws off and you know even me as a
diver bringing up a lobster with the
claws off the you know the
the claws eventually degrade by the time
you get home it's they're just not as
good so it's just something we just know
not to do um the way that we safely die
for lobsters and you know we use things
like tickle sticks so you try and coax
it out from behind um
and try and get it out and take and look
at it grab it but the last thing you're
going to do is just you know pull it
from the
rock so
um
so that's really all i just wanted out
is just to kind of um refute those
comments but i i just
you know again this is something that
it's something that i would envision um
in my lifetime being able to do you know
as a family activity and and uh i think
it would drive more uh revenue to the
state in terms of uh business for dive
shops for get more people open water
certified
more training buying more gear
um
i mean candidly it's not
it's not a cheap activity i mean if you
think of the gas and the the you know
bank for air the rental gear etc it's
probably cheaper to go to market basket
we're not talking about coming home with
when i do go diving with my family it's
probably at the most two to three
um you know over the course of a day
thank you very much mr figueroa uh
represent has a question for you
thank you chairman and put an amendment
that would set the dates and season
seasons and bag limits in the control of
i'm open to it this is something the
diving community is open to work with to
um because we recognize that this is
something that we want to demonstrate at
the end either a limited season
or a number catch um that the data is
going to show that some of the concerns
that are are being brought are our mood
point
um so
we're flexible with uh
with looking at uh you know any type of
proposals that you think are fair
thank you further questions from the
committee
there being none thank you very much sir
i appreciate it our last speaker on this
bill is
weldon bosworth
um from guilford and he's in favor of
thank you mr chair and members of the
committee i uh this isn't the main
reason i came down here today but
because it's a subject near and dear to
my heart i did want to testify to it
my background is i'm a marine biologist
with 50 years experience
in ecology marine ecology and
environmental impact
in addition to that i've had over 100
hours hundreds of hours actually diving
along the new hampshire coast when i was
running all the
biological studies for seabrook station
i had almost 25 divers working for me
who collectively over the years had over
30 000 hours of diving so i'm listening
here i'm hearing a mountain being made
out of a molehill this bill proposes two
months
out of a year
and i don't know what the diving
community is now but i doubt there's a
hundred people in new hampshire
that would get involved in diving for
lobsters
using scuba or free diving
i grew up in the 60s down in
massachusetts diving for lobster so
everything the previous speaker said
the
the thing that i really want to i guess
emphasize is that there is not a safety
issue
and these
hundreds of thousands of hours of diving
we only had one incident over 20 years
of somebody getting bent people who dive
in these kind of climates and there's
very few that do
are well aware and cautious about safety
and they're not going to be diving
around boats and lobster pots and things
like that first of all if you've got
bubbles near a lobster part
the uh lobsterman already presumes that
you're down there poaching which is not
the truth and i've
certainly seen that happen
last time i looked lobsters are a
species held in public trust by
all citizens in new hampshire
and i think the option
to take lobsters using either traps
or by scuba or skin diving
is a choice made just like in hunting
one can go after it with firearms or bow
and arrow in some cases crossbow
so
anyway that's my say on the situation of
diving for lobsters thank you mr
bosworth appreciate your testimony is
there any questions from the committee
for mr busworth
there being none mr basra thank you
again for coming for the fish and game
committee that concludes our speakers on
this bill
um given its topic i'm not going to
consider going into an executive session
we'll give time for members to see if
they want to work up an amendment on
that
541a rule-making authority maybe
and see how we want to progress and
we'll meet on the 25th to discuss it
further with that i will close the
public hearing on house bill
next up is house bill 1299 i'm the prime
sponsor so i'm going over there
um
the public hearing on
hb 1299 is open
and
representative tim lang is recognized to
all right hey guys if you take your
conversation outside no i'm not the
chair i'd appreciate that so we can have
a good public hearing and everyone can
hear what's being said all right so i'm
the prime sponsor of house bill 1299 my
name is tim lang i represent the towns
of uh tilton and san bernardino iv
uh and i'm presenting to you a bill that
would um that's relevant to the process
of importation of wildlife and then
creating an appeal process
this bill is before you based on a
constituent request
i was contacted by a member of the
new hampshire citizen who was trying to
work through a process for importing
reindeer
and through that process we're hitting
some hurdles and we're having a more
difficult time and as i read the law
that he was citing
i realized i didn't like it and so i
presented i was bringing a bill forward
if you read the statute as it exists
right now the statute defaults to no for
our citizen instead of defaulting to yes
for our citizen
um and so i felt that that was an
inappropriate default for our laws that
we should be encouraging our citizens to
participate and do whatever they want in
their in our community with it if it's
within our reasons so the default answer
i felt should been yes so you'll see
that i strike the language where it says
no person shall import and i change it
to a person may import
um but there's still a permitting
process right so we still want to give
fish and game the right
to
make sure that there's no conflict or
problem with the importation of whatever
kind of animal the person's trying to
import
um and so we give fish fish and game a
30-day window from the time the person
asks for the permit to respond if they
don't respond within 30 days the default
answer is yes if they respond within 30
days and deny
then there's the person can either
accept based on the reasoning that fish
and game gave the person for the denial
or i created the new appeal process
because there is no current appeal
process for a denial unless you want to
go to superior court and start involving
lawyers so i created a simple appeal
process that allows an individual
citizen who disagrees with the decision
of the executive director to be able to
just appeal to the fish and game
commission and file an appeal saying i
think i was denied i was denied this
permit unduly i want to present my case
to the fish and game commission and let
the fish and game commission which is
the ruling body of fish and game two and
policy body efficient game to make a
ruling on whether or not the executive
director's decision should be overturned
that's the bill
that's what it does
um there is an amendment to the bill
which you all have um i made one change
which was basically i granted um 541
rule making authority which i left out
of my original bill to give fish and
game the ability to write rules around
uh the process
and i'm happy to take questions again i
i felt it was
it was a disservice to our citizen to
not have a good process in place to not
have a ability to appeal a bureaucrats
no offense cut but a bureaucrat's uh
fiat ruling and there should be a
process to appeal that that a citizen
can take and not have to go to superior
court and open a case and do that so the
uh so i established an appeal process
with the fish and game commission
and with that i'm happy to take any
questions
thank you chairman lang for your uh
introduction of the bill are there any
good afternoon my name is matt leahy i'm
the public policy director for the
forest society um
so we are concerned with the bill um and
i'll be quick but you know one of our
excuse me uh priority concerns is the
you know impact and effect that um
nate are
non-native plants
pathogens pests are having on the forest
resources and i understand the bill
before you
deals with wildlife species
um but you know we just view that all of
that stuff out in the woods is connected
um and so you know we are concerned that
you know the state has to be you know
very careful about
trying to avoid the introduction of you
know additional you know non-native
animals or other things into our
out into our forest and other places so
um
so for that reason um you know we again
thank you for your testimony uh is there
seeing none you're excused and thank you
next up would be michael flanagan
for representing his family
and
good afternoon again
excuse me thank you very much to me
giving me an opportunity to speak for
various obvious reasons
it wasn't here it doesn't belong here
and i support the fish and game
department and it's posing this bill
thank you very much
well thank you for your quick testimony
are there any questions from the
committee
seeing none you're excused thank you
elise letizia
representing the bha i see you have
written testimony and you oppose the
bill so if you've got written testimony
please uh
where did our assistant go
well we'll get it from you
oh do you have copies for the whole
committee no just this one okay thank
you
good afternoon my name is elise letizia
and i'm a resident of claremont i'm a
lifelong avid outdoor enthusiast and as
of three years ago a hunter today i'm
speaking on behalf of the new england
chapter of backcountry hunters and
anglers which i'll be referring to as
bha i'm a volunteer on the new hampshire
state leadership team and presenting
comments for this bill on behalf of the
chapter
bha is the voice of our public our wild
public lands waters and wildlife we seek
to ensure north america's outdoor
heritage of hunting and fishing in a
natural setting by supporting land
conservation public access to hunting
and fishing areas and sound management
of fish and wildlife in their habitats
the expertise of the new hampshire fish
and game department is critical to
securing our outdoor heritage and
protecting and managing our fish
wildlife and their habitats hp 1299
would change the rules by which the
department approves or denies importing
possessing selling exhibiting and
releasing species in new hampshire the
proposed changes would hamper the
department's ability to protect our
native species this role is more
important now than ever and we should
seek to strengthen it rather than
abbreviate it
release of non-native species
well-intentioned or otherwise can have
enormous negative impacts on human
health ecosystems and economies hb 1299
and rsa 207
14 identify the potential risks as
direct and significant disease genetic
ecological environmental health safety
or welfare risks to persons marine
species or wildlife
these risks are real and there are
dozens of examples of injurious
non-native species in the united states
including japanese snot weed carp
feral pigs
just to name a few
moving native species can have similar
risks as importing non-native species
particularly with disease transmission
for example some native amphibians in
the us have been decimated by
chytrid fungus transported as infected
native species are moved from place to
place
for the moose and deer so important to
new hampshire hunters and all others who
cherish our native cervids chronic
wasting disease or cwd
is one of these potential disease
disasters cwd has already taken hold in
other parts of the country and it makes
big gains when people move infected
animals and tissues between states
cwd is always fatal to the infected
animal and many hunters have serious
concerns about feeding meat from
infected animals to their families
as cwd prevalence increases in a state
it can depress hunter participation
which in turn affects hunting license
sales and revenue for state wildlife
management agencies
given all these examples decisions about
the activities in hb 1299 should not be
made lightly or in haste science-based
decisions can protect and manage our
native habitats and wildlife however the
information required for these decisions
isn't always readily available and the
department will need time to determine
whether a proposal qualifies for
approval or denial
there are many reasons why this could be
the case depending on the biology of the
species at issue and the risks to new
hampshire's wildlife demand we give the
experts the time and discretion they
need
the default answers to requests for
import possession release etc of species
in new hampshire should be that it is
prohibited unless allowed by the
department the current language gives
the department the appropriate time and
discretion to make the best decision for
our fish wildlife inhabitants for these
reasons on behalf of vha's members in
new hampshire we ask that you oppose
this bill thank you all for the
opportunity to speak today and for
taking our comments into consideration
thank you for your testimony
can we get a copy of that so that we can
make copies for the committee thank you
i have a question for you if nobody else
are you aware that under the way that
the bill's written a fish and game can
actually still deny the permit under all
of those reasons that you mentioned okay
they it just gives a hearing as a
requirement and a default answer of yes
next up i have dan bergeron
you do have uh 20 copies for us
good afternoon chairman and members of
the committee
um so yes i'm dan bergeron the chief of
the wildlife division for fish and game
i'm here opposing the bill
for the department and the commission
so the department has several concerns
about this bill
negative impacts to native species
and their habitats in the state so
[Music]
so this bill again it does not only
relate to importation uh but also the
potential possession sale and exhibition
and release of wildlife
or their eggs or progeny
so currently the current rsa
and the existing administrative rules
which are in part fis 800
those rules were were created using the
best available science
to minimize the risk of
introduction of diseases or escape
of
invasive species
so in those rules there are categories
that are outlined for the different
types of permatease
the different categories of species so
there are certain species that are
considered controlled
non-controlled species or prohibited
species and depending on what category
of permatea you are or the category of
the species
that dictates what you're allowed to
bring in and then what you're allowed to
do with it
once it gets into the state
and again those categories are already
based off of research that was done on
the risks associated with these
so again i mentioned it briefly you know
the big concerns are introduction of
wildlife diseases
or invasive species but also loss of
genetic diversity to some of the state's
threatened and endangered species
one of the concerns at least i have i
haven't had a chance to read the
amendment
but with the original
language of this bill but we had
concerns of what this might do to our
authority
to
to enforce these 800 rules
the language in the bill
currently
again i haven't had a chance to review
the amendment but the language removes
part of the existing rsa that gives the
executive director and i quote the
authority to determine the time period
and any other conditions governing the
issuance of this permit um and those
other conditions are largely what make
up the the bulk of our 800 rules which
were
are very extensive rules that kind of
guide this process there's um
you know it makes sure we're required
we're following federal guidelines um
there's information on there on housing
for different species so it's an
extensive set of rules that guides our
decisions on these
on whether or not we issue a permit for
we have
we have some concerns about the appeals
process as well
when the commission voted on this they
voted unanimously to oppose it
and they stated at the time that they
did not feel that they had the they
should have the authority to adjudicate
these hearings
in part because they did not feel they
had the expertise or experience to do
such
currently
the commission does not have the
authority
um to hear any other sorts of hearings
so license revocation hearings for
example the commission does not does not
have the authority to to hear those
i did notice that that was specifically
written into this bill to allow that but
but the commission took the position
that they did not feel that was in their
preview
we also feel that this would
increase workload
on behalf of the department
um again the rules in place are fairly
streamlined um
you know depending on your the permit
category that you're applying for and
the type of species you're looking
to import
decisions are somewhat already made and
the science and the background research
was done on that already
this
i could foresee turning into a situation
where we are litigating individual cases
when when permits are denied despite the
fact that we have already based these
the risks again if something were to
to get through
and i do feel like this bill increases
the risks are pretty substantial to
native wildlife in the state and their
habitats
disease transmission is is one of the
big ones chronic wasting disease was
mentioned there are other diseases like
bovine tuberculosis
there are a number of diseases that
impact reptiles and amphibians so
chytrid fungus was mentioned
ranavirus snake fungal disease
still there's a number of other diseases
that impact fresh water and marine
species
so both our inland fisheries division
in our marine fisheries division has
very big concerns about this
some diseases can be zoonotic
which means they have the potential to
impact both wildlife and humans
a good example of this and forgive me
for mentioning covet again
but but the recent discovery of covet
antibodies in whitetail deer
as well of a number of other wildlife
species and domestic species mink for
example
i think highlights how disease ecology
is constantly changing
and responding to
responding to introductions of diseases
is very costly so
for chronic wasted disease for example
states spend tens of millions of dollars
to try and contain that disease
increased monitoring and surveillance
because it's an always fatal disease
virtually no jurisdiction has been able
to eradicate it once it has arrived it
is essentially a process of slowing the
and again it was mentioned in previous
testimony but
when some when new diseases
when new diseases arrive there can be
resulting decreases in license sales and
loss of revenue in that that respect as
well
an escape of invasive species is another
big concern
likewise with with dealing with disease
introductions invasive species
mitigation it's rarely effective at
completely restoring natural systems and
there was a study in 2005 which
estimated that the united states
spends about 120 billion dollars
annually to combat impacts from invasive
species
um again there's a number of species
that are on the the prohibited lists
that we currently have under our 800
rules
um and again these species are on that
list because there's a well-documented
history of the of their
potential to have negative and invasive
impacts so things like zebra mussels
snakehead fish
so again the department feels that the
current rsa and our administrative rules
are an effective and efficient method of
permit issuance
that the current rules were developed in
advance using the best available science
to make decisions on which species
should be allowed in the state
or be exhibited or sold or released
and they provide an efficient and a
streamlined process for permanent
issuance for the department
so with that i thank you for the
opportunity to testify
thank you any questions from the
committee members
representative laflamme
thank you representative spelaine uh mr
roger i have one question and possibly a
follow-up
um would you be involved
in any sort of um a
judging whether or not a request was
valid or yeah so it would depend on the
species but whatever species was in
question we'd likely have to pull in
staff that specializes in that species
to help
to help inform the commission on the
decision
follow up follow up agree do you feel
that this permit has to be issued within
30 days do you think 30 days is a long
enough period for you to effectively
evaluate
whether or not you should be grinding a
permit
i i think it would depend on the species
in question
and again not knowing exactly what this
will how this will make will force us to
change our current 800 rules um it's
tough to say
uh our law enforcement division um
does a lot of the permitting but in
large part because we've already done
the review when we set the guidelines
for for again which species should be
should be allowed in so if there's a
species on the prohibited list it simply
is not allowed to be imported
so it's very simple that way
if a species is on the controlled list
then based on what permit category
you're in whether or not you're going to
propagate that species or just exhibit
that species or if you're going to sell
that species then that changes what
you're allowed to bring in and what
you're allowed to do with it so again
there's there's a lot of framework in
place to make this a very simple process
to permit
and and the other benefit of having this
this this
this detail in our administrative rules
is that we can change things and adjust
things through through the
administrative rules process as new
science becomes available so if there's
evidence that a species um
is a greater threat we could put it on a
prohibited list
if there's a if there's
evidence that maybe something's not as
big of a risk we could move it to
control for example
so it allows us some flexibility too
through the administrative rules process
to adjust this thing as new science
representative smith
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
your testimony i just took
the line 18 where it says the permit
shall be granted within 30 days of the
request
um if that permit can't be issued within
30 days because it's some exotic
species that you're unfamiliar with
and it's going to take you 45 days what
would you do
in that situation would you then deny
the permit if this bill passed
or
is there an ability for you to extend
beyond that 30 days that you see
um
so i'm not sure i'm not sure i follow
that so under this bill we would we
would be required to respond within the
30 days correct
but if it's going to take you 45 days
so are you asking if we had 45 days
would that be sufficient
no i'm asking
it says the permit shall be granted
within 30 days of the request if you're
not capable of completing the
application within 30 days what is your
recourse at that point yeah
well to be safe probably to deny the
permit
i would i would assume that within that
period of time we could probably make a
decision um in large part because again
a lot of this background research has
been done on these species uh i i see
the time frame is less of an issue
thank you
any other question
representative craig
thank you mr chair thank you mr bergeron
perhaps you mentioned this and i missed
it because i was reading the bill
how many permits
applications does the department receive
our law enforcement division issues most
it varies depending on the species
um
yeah colonel do you have a calling for
yeah or or bob but our administrative
lieutenant who who issues those permits
is fairly new to the position okay
the former administrative lieutenant did
and i have him doing other things so i
issue those and we do issue a great
number of them uh representative craig
we do issue a great number of them so
and they vary from
uh rattlesnakes to deer or elk or things
of that species of that nature so
there's a lot that goes on there's a lot
more than i thought once i started doing
the permits
follow-up
uh and how many of those would you
consider
hard judgments are problematic are a
good percentage of them
fairly automatic or
rejected out of hand how does that go
so a lot of them we've established with
the help of of uh
the sole work of the wildlife staff
we've established what is safe and what
isn't so
uh the only thing that comes in so
typically if someone puts in for
something for instance a reindeer where
we have real concerns about cwd hitting
the state
um
through that
uh that we deny that so that's been
established
so
we review each application you know as
they come in but we've got a pretty good
a pretty good handle i think on what is
okay and what it hasn't been what's
controlled and what isn't and even on
the on the things that we allow in their
control there are certain other
requirements health certificates
for stuff being imported and propagated
cage size and design treatment of the
animal all of those things have to be
all those standards have to be met or we
don't we don't issue the permit
so it's an involved
you know i'm sitting back there
listening to this 30-day window it's an
involved process sometimes uh you know
and when you've got to send an officer
out to inspect an enclosure with the
demands on their time now that's a that
any other questions from the committee
i have one um there's a lot of of um
discussion that you had um
about about the the complications of the
different levels of the permits and such
but it seems to me that a lot of that is
already set out already defined
and that you already have rules and
process that this doesn't touch
it seems to me this bill is mainly just
requiring that you be responsive as an
organization
and either give a hearing or give an
appeals process and that this is only
trying to ensure that
that some response is given and some
adequate amount of explanation and
hearing is allowed
again i haven't read the amendment
i
do have concerns about the removal of
some of the the current language in the
rule um
that allowed the executive director
authority to set out different um
criteria for for the issuance of these
permits um i'm not sure if the amendment
addressed that
um
the
i think if there were an appeals process
i i guess the department would question
whether or not the commission is the
appropriate body to hear those appeals
thank you
any other questions from the committee
next i have eric anderson from the new
hampshire commercial commercial
fisherman's association
opposing the bill and you say you've got
okay you only had 10 copies though
we'll make copies
we'll make copies no problem
thank you mr chairman and house
committee members um
we have reviewed this bill
and and stand in opposition of it
um in essence this legislation would
allow the imputation and release of live
marine species or wildlife or eggs or
progeny thereof obtaining a permit from
the executive director
our opposition on this part of the
legislation legislation is for
introducing a foreign native species
into the
habitat and ecosystem of our native
species can have very controversial and
negative effects that are irreversible
or uncontrollable
i use one example that maybe you're
it it it was was by accident but it was
a non-native species
introduced in this area and that's green
crabs
um they pretty much were introduced by
accident
but the consequences have been
uncontrollable they have been
irreversible um
they've caused great you know
controversy and great ring um
in the great bay estuary down in hampton
seabrook uh and they've overrun
and you know because they um
they destroy eelgrass
um
so anyway that's that's an example of
how something can develop without the
proper
knowledge and then
turn around and become such a negative
of additional concern in this
legislation is the process of appeal as
described
i think i think you might have
understood from the previous testimony
that the appeal would go to go through
the um
fish and game commission
and it's with no malice to that
commission but is beyond their authority
i mean i think it's pretty well stated
in the legislation that's where any
appeal would go and it's just strictly
because
um with respect to that commission
it's beyond the orthotic it's beyond
their
knowledge to
grant any type of appeal process
so we join our opposition with the new
hampshire fish and game
department
the new hampshire fish and game
commission and the advisory committee
commissioner on marine fisheries thank
you
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions from the committee
gino marconi
from marine fisheries committee
thank you mr chairman uh considering the
hour and the testimony you've already
heard
the committee has charged me to come up
here and officially
enter into the record their support for
new hampshire fish and games position on
this
and their opposition to the bill
and thank you
thank you that was quick any questions
from the committee
jack flanagan
supporting the bill
thank you
thank you mr chairman and i it's like
being a dinosaur you'd never forget one
once you see one but
it it is thank you very much and
committee members i really enjoy seeing
a lot of you a lot of faces that i
remember and and you never know i might
be back even our democratic friends
um
it's great it is great being here i've
got to say
but anyway this bill
is really about power
or authority
in other words there's one man in the
fishing game that's saying yes or no how
high you jump how
whether you jump and things like that
but is this not a unique process
the real estate commission
the the managers the directors there you
can appeal it to the real estate
commission any decision that they make
the liquor commission as it relates to
revocation can be
heard in front of the liquor
commissioner and i personally had to go
in front of the timber tax committee
because of various processes that took
place at even at a local level so this
is not a new concept of having an appeal
process going to a commission or a
committee
all right so everybody seems to be
saying well you know we're afraid of
this this this disease or this illness
and we're really only talking about
giving somebody a step before
they have to take it to a superior court
someone also brought up the issue about
them not knowing well
a judge who adjudicates any case
doesn't know everything about everything
until it's been explained to them
so that's really the process that we're
dealing with here we're not specifically
talking about breed and illness
so so i just wanted to make that clear
we're talking about an appeal process
and that's it
okay
and rightfully so it could be denied by
the committee all right so it's just a
process that the citizens of new
all right
i support the bill because i had
personal experience dealing with
importation of animals from out of state
a good friend of mine that i've known
for over 30 years he's with me here
uh put in a request for reindeer and by
the way colonel
oh i love you to death there's only been
one known case of cwd and reindeer in
the entire country
so just i just want to clear that issue
okay so when you say that there's a
whole host of cwd cases
one okay then that doesn't include of
course the number of cwd cases and
regular deer elk and moose that are done
nationwide
i just want to clear that up okay that
was that was that was stated earlier
um
so as i said my friend rick who i hope
you asked to testify next because he's
got a wealth of knowledge has been
through the process
um
we with no success in dealing with um
getting the importation of two reindeer
okay not a herd and
the conditions of the import was a
multiple fenced-in area drainage and he
can provide more information but it
wasn't like he was just going to let
them walk
and roam free okay
but literally it was
and actually to make matters worse too i
heard through the grapevine you know
because i know people in concord and the
political system it said
pretty much said let it die
and that's the wrong thing to say to me
okay and i'm sure a number of you here
okay because you're in the position of
serving the citizens of the state of new
hampshire so letting it die
just fell on deaf ears so so what do we
have
we have a process in place that
a group of fish and game people for
whatever the reason
have decided that they didn't want to do
it because of conditions with another
species of
prion
is that the right word thank you brian
thank you
and denied somebody else and basically
said let it go
all right and there is a process in
place but it literally comes to an end
there's no recourse
okay
and that's what this bill does it gives
someone a recourse to basically say
you know this
this this is just not the right way to
approach the situation because of the
science and with that i'll take whatever
questions you have but i encourage you
to invite mr zillfelder a matter of fact
it was a great meeting with you
at the meeting but even his own words
mr zielfelder knew more about cwd than
any of the biologists in the meeting
so i welcome you to ask questions of mr
zielfelder too
thank you
uh honorable flanagan for your testimony
are there any questions
go ahead
you talked about it going to appeal
but the body that it would go to appeal
to the fish and game commission
doesn't want it
so
that seems to kind of
well thank you for the question
representative
i don't know many agencies in the state
or better yet let me rephrase that that
follow-up
as a follow-up i believe they felt that
they didn't have the expertise
well i as a and thank you again for the
question i'll be more than happy to
answer anyone's question is that um
if i understand it correctly the way it
works in any adjudication process is
each side would present their best case
argument so mr bergeron may attend or mr
mason may attend based on what they know
and of course in the case that i'm
citing of my friend mr zielfelder is he
would present the evidence and then the
commission would be the trier of fact
being that well he makes more sense than
the other person so will either deny it
or accept it and if we accept it
if we accept it we can conditionalize
the exception acceptance on double
fencing on veterinarians you know
inspections every six months whatever
the case may be
okay but
the the process in place basically is
you know
we
should be basing it on science and not
on conjecture
i hope i answered your question
thank you any other questions from the
committee
i have one with best possible follow-up
if you'll entertain me anytime represent
excuse me mr chairman
are you aware of corbyn reservoir
quabbin or corbin
no i've never heard of that it's an area
designated in the middle of new
hampshire for hunting it's a private
club oh yes yes i've heard of that yeah
okay
they have a lot of species that don't
occur naturally here and they've got
their high fencing and things and
to your knowledge
if they were
under our system right now with the lack
of appeal
could they exist no they could not
that's the group where they charge like
thirty thousand dollars to be a member
of the club and they bring in animals
and they should but it's in a controlled
environment and that may have you know
certainly but at some point in the past
they had to in they had to import their
breeding
correct members and at this point with
their lists and denyings
well it's interesting i i had lunch with
mr zillfather and we were talking about
a number of issues and i think there's
currently issues on importation of
uh
like game that was shot in other states
that he might want to share with you
some of the information that he's got
from he this man went through the ringer
and i hope i don't take any wind out of
your sails rick but he went through the
process he went with
lieutenant murphy
this is what you got to do and next step
next step and then bam
sorry
that's it we're not letting that happen
well you know why would you have all
these procedures but
some interesting dialogue came out of
that meeting and i don't want to take
away from his fire but i'll take more
questions mr chairman that's all i had
for you any other questions from the
committee
you're excused thank you sir
thank you good to see y'all and next is
rick zellfelder
representing himself in support of the
bill
um
i just want to clarify that uh
cwd without question is a hot topic and
i know everybody's ready to stand up and
fight
about their position on cwd and i would
love the opportunity to talk
about prion disease
but we'd be two days on that information
and this supposedly is not about cwd
it's about the process here in new
hampshire correct
is it appropriate to ask a couple of
questions before i begin
you can if we can answer them we will
if you had a son daughter wife husband
or loved one that was seriously hurt or
died in a medical malpractice incident
would it be fair or just that the jury
consists of only doctors that worked in
the same hospital where the incident
well consider that as not needing an
answer but continue on you got my point
would new hampshire would new hampshire
legislators shut down a new hampshire
turnpike without doing a traffic study
again i'll take that as a rhetorical
question for the committee to consider
my first call to new hampshire fishing
game about reindeer
in december of 2018 i was referred to
heidi murphy
when inquiring about importing reindeer
i was told all about fencing
requirements in the state of new
hampshire that i would need a usda
exhibitor's license that i should speak
with cindy heisler at the department of
agriculture
would need to be familiar with agr 2100
paying specific attention to 2116.01
and 0.02 we also spoke about charlie
hutchinson
i left that call feeling like she was a
very nice lady but i had some serious
if she had only said this is not
possible currently because of the
state's cwd concerns we would not be
dana merrill the road to nowhere
i assumed that i would be the only
reindeer owners and breeders association
member in new hampshire other than
nicholas staley of santa's village
in scanning the roba membership i
stumbled across dana merrill from
deerfield
i called him to ask if he did in fact
have reindeer he explained he was
looking into importing reindeer from
that point i was copied on emails as he
was given the same routine that i had
been through
from these emails i see statements from
state officials about how and why
service importation will not happen
why was i not told about this and my
calls with the department of agriculture
and fishing game
confusion
in preparing to apply for permits i
started studying as much as possible
about cwd
and then prion disease in an expanded
view
i quickly learned the state's
state of new hampshire's deer program is
full of what appears to be double
standards when it comes to cwd
management
at first i didn't i didn't know
how someone can be this naive but over
time it has become clear that hunting
and or revenue is more important than
why aren't there more eyes on what's
actually going on versus the nice and
now
at this point i could give you example
after example after example and we could
spend hours debating what's right and
wrong on prion disease but it's not the
place
department of agriculture meeting in the
summer of 2020 the honorable mr flanagan
organized a meeting with mr jasper mr
crawford mr flynn again and myself we
discussed the importation of reindeer a
short time
a short time after
that meeting
it was suggested that i create the
importation permits as they did not
why did heidi murphy give me a to-do
list when there is no way past the gate
why did mr crawford not bring up the
built-in loopholes regarding usda
cwd herd certification
especially when he has such a strong
view about the program not working again
this comes from the emails that i was
copied on but they're all things that
were kind of hidden and never discussed
usda does have opinion about a bunch of
those comments as well
their responses make a tremendous amount
of sense after visiting current servant
next section
heaven sent
on november 2nd 2020 my final my family
finds a dead deer below our barn it's
covered in grass with no risk no visible
reason for its death
i call ron arsenault and tell him about
our finding he states it's probably a
bobcat kill
because of my concern with cwd i asked
if we could have it tested
he stated we don't do that in the state
i told him his response shocked me
especially since i was scheduled to meet
with mr mason on november 10th
about cwd
crickets
after reviewing game cameras ron
arsenault was 100 right it was a bobcat
kill seems like a knowledgeable and
fish and game is concerned with cwd yet
the november 10th new hampshire fishing
game meeting with mr mason dan bergeron
mark ellingwood mr cross crawford mr
jasper mr flanagan and myself
in my opinion mr mason's mind was made
up prior to the meeting
he was disengaged and looking out the
windows it appears we were there as a
gesture gesture of professional courtesy
to mr jasper
i brought up my call with ron arsenault
and dan bergeron ran him over with the
bus
he is an enforcement and has no idea
what he is talking about
i tried to initiate a debate was shut
down even when bringing up some of the
double standards that currently exist in
new hampshire's cwd management approach
it was clear mr mason was standing by
his voice
to this day
i have never been allowed to present my
plan
regardless of my plan being built from
input by the usda
national animal disease center dvms phds
and the leading prion disease
researchers from all over the world i
published sampling information is
deceptive
[Music]
in a march 10 2021 email dan bergeron
acknowledges not having completed cwd
he he will blame it on lab issues i
called the lab twice and told they were
never shut down during covet and they
were deemed essential and never got
behind beyond seven days
he said she said we can argue about that
regardless there is no sense of urgency
i assumed logic was used universally
here's a four page list of aphis
right around this point right around
let's go back to ron arsenault his
enforcement and doesn't know what he is
talking about
in early november of 2021 a new
hampshire resident called and spoke with
dan bergeron on strange deer activity on
his 27-acre property
this made him really nervous about the
deer he just targeted harvested
being cautious he asked if he could have
the deer tested for cwd
dan reassured him that deer activity was
nothing to be concerned with and no they
in my seat seems like ron arsenault was
a straight shooter and his statement was
accurate
hunting and known cwd states
i have an employee that hunts in known
cwd states he has had successful elk
hunts he has me processed puts it in his
truck and drives back to new hampshire
his uncle
is hunting white tld whitetail deer in
outdated and incomplete rules exist
rules were put in place years ago using
information that is no longer current
the existing rules are incomplete
as acknowledged by emails by our state
vet
the rules don't encompass all cwd risk
and activities
it is my belief that the entire realm of
information available was not and is not
in this state you will only hear about
cwd being extremely
infectious in singular form
you will never hear about different
strains
atypical or spontaneous cases
you won't hear about susceptibility or
transmissibility
regarding cwd management in the state of
new hampshire it is also my belief that
there is not anyone versed in this
enough in this material to act as a
check and balance or hold people
accountable when making agricultural
i'm done
thank you for your testimony and your
handouts
um are there any questions from
representative
ellis
chairman um if
someone hunted a deer in iowa and then
they
brought the meat to new hampshire then
it wouldn't be inspected is that what
that's currently the case
any other questions from the committee
members well one other comment on that
too so
dan talked about
using science and that's that's actually
a very good comment
and it's true
but i would ask you to think about dna
testing
and in the 80s when dna testing came
around
you needed a lot of material to test and
you were very very limited on what test
could be done
today
you can take an extremely amount
of
extremely small amount of dna
continue to build it and process it
and then perform an array of different
tests on
dna material
cwd science is very very similar
uh what we know
today
versus what went on in 2015 and 16 are
worlds apart
any other questions from committee
members
seeing none you're excused and thank you
before i take back overs anybody else
wants to testify on house bill
sorry
uh 12.99
not seeing any i'm going to hold this
mr chairman i had a question
for you willing to answer it yes if he's
how you doing good i believe you've left
your laptop on the uh
it's just a
question i have in my mind on the bill
that's being
presented
under section one
it says upon petition and within 45 days
yeah the executive directed to deny a
permit requested under rsa 207 and a
pawn a majority vote of a quorum of
commissioners
may reverse such decision
by written ruling issue within 14 days
of the hearing
at the current time
can the fish and game commission
overrule anything that you
not just you know not just these
wildlife permits but as a general rule
can the fish and game overrule you
um careful because they didn't want to
when you read through i apologize first
of all my name is scott mace i'm the
executive director of new hampshire fish
and game
um when you read through fish and game
law
it's kind of like
grandma's patchwork quilt
and and there are certain authorities
that the commission has and certain
authorities that the director has
sometimes i need to tell them what i'm
doing sometimes i need to ask permission
before i do it
and sometimes there's something
somewhere in between that we have to do
um but it all depends on what the issue
is and it depends on the
follow-up yeah i just asked a question
this year's red yeah
so every year the fish and game laws
change and i would just answer the
question because i didn't know if they
if this was granting them some new
authority that they didn't already have
that's all
normally any of the appeal processes
that take place um
you know like we just went through a
whole new rule-making process on aot
um
it's you know my biologists are making
the initial decision on aot i'm not and
then they then there's an appeal process
that brings you know if somebody wants
to appeal the decision of the biologist
they then bring that to me as the appeal
hearing officer it's the same thing on
license suspensions
um what takes place there is you know a
ceo
gives out a citation and an honor or a
fisherman loses their license that
person can appeal that decision to me so
i'm not part of i'm not usually part of
the initial decisions on these items and
then
then i end up being the appeal officer
for fish and game is the way most of our
representative jack thank you can i
raise one thing uh the department
brought up uh it's on line 13 of the
original bill and line eight of the
amendment the loss
of the any other conditions language and
the colonel
gave the example of
it would be fine to import this animal
if we get a medical clearance and
the question be if the sponsor intended
to lose that
it seems like
they would then have to deny the permit
because they don't have the ability to
ask for it and it may be something you
want to consider before you
before you execute the bill whether you
want it whether you would want to repair
that in any way
i'm hoping we'll just hold this bill
until the 25th and there i know we had
some conversation around the 30th time
the 30-day timeline maybe we have an
amendment there that would maybe make it
more reasonable for people so i'll take
that advisement and and consider it
and if you have an extra copy of
something that the committee needs to
see
we can get copies made
i see you holding it up
would probably be of interest to the
committee and we'd welcome it
we've got our we've got our person
any other
people wishing to testify
or
questions
all right
there being no further testimony we're
gonna hold this bill over to the 25th um
and we can have some discussion if
anybody's interested feel free to reach
out to me if you think there's a place
we can have uh some accommodation and
i'll be happy to draft that amendment to
deal with people's concerns with that
i'm going to close the public hearing on
house bill 1299
next up is house bill 1356 an act
relative to the taking of grey squirrels
and with that i am going to recognize
the prime sponsor of the bill
representative amanda bolden um to
introduce and speak to the bill
she might be out in all
in a room
can yeah can somebody run out in the
hallway that i know the unfortunately
the line for testimony goes all the way
down the hallway um on these next two
bills
and again if anybody's wishing to
testify please make sure you turn in
yes after this bill we'll take a bio
break so people can get up and move
around a little bit and we'll come back
feel free to take the uh whatever you
call that witness stand and um
just introduce yourself
and you are the prime sponsor of this
bill
hello
sorry for being outside i figured you
guys had a really long day ahead of you
and i was just getting comfortable
um
my name is amanda bolden i represent
hillsborough district 12.
and um
here to discuss with you
the baby squirrel bill
um
so i don't serve on this committee and
i've never testified here before not
that i recall anyway i can imagine the
kind of testimony that you typically
hear
and i wanted to present to you something
totally different
so if you'll oblige uh a little i have a
little short story for you and i'd like
to know what you think
so in 1988 the legislature
ceded control
over hunting season dates to the fish
and game commission
the argument that was made at the time
was that the commission would be better
able to adapt to changes in population
that makes sense we do things really
slowly in this building
when the grey squirrel season was set by
the legislature prior to when control
was seated to the commission
the season began on october 1st
and as you know
as i assume you know given the committee
that you serve on
the fish and game commission currently
sets the season to begin on september
1st so a full month earlier
when the fish and game commission was
given authority to set the dates back in
1988 1989 it maintained the same
starting date of october 1st until 2004.
when um and it was in 2004 when a
proposal came forward to change the
starting date to be the last saturday in
september
um
i feel like maybe this is the most
boring topic in the world but
i don't know what other bills you've
heard today
so
so i've provided packets to you that
showed documentation of conversations in
the commission where there was a
proposal to change the date for the
grey squirrel the cotton caliber rabbit
and the snowshoe here to the last
saturday in september which is just a
few days prior to the october first date
that was originally set by the
commission so it seemed like they were
only in 2004 they were only trying to
change it by a few days
um
when the new rule was formally adopted
the only the snowshoe hair and the
cottontail rabbit were given a starting
date of the last saturday in september
and strangely the gray squirrel was
inexplicably given the starting date of
september 1st
interestingly when i put in a research
request here at the state house to find
out more the research department wasn't
able to find anything
there's no paper trail showing that any
motion was actually made to change the
date for the great squirrel to september
1st
it genuinely seems like this might be a
typo
in fact the state house researcher
reached out to
mike morrell at the administrative rules
division and learned that these kinds of
typos have happened before
and that he believes that the date is
set at september 1st maybe by accident
it could just be a
um
so
all of this is in the packets that i
gave to you they're really short also
the first page the packet is some data
from someone that i think is not
testifying today in case you're
interested in what the wildlife
and i know that you're going to hear and
i'm very sorry
that if a lot of time is spent today
hearing opinions that i know that you've
heard before opinions for and against
hunting opinions about
you know the right to hunt
or the rights of animals and that's not
what this bill is about
um
i genuinely believe that there's just
been a clerical error
if you can find
like i said this is a mystery if you can
find
documentation explaining why the date
was set at september 1st after the
entire discussion
revolved around
the last saturday in september i'd love
to see it our researchers couldn't find
it
um
so it seems like the intent on the part
of the commission originally in 2004 was
always to keep it pretty close to
october 1st
and
you know
i think it's pretty obvious the intent
of a hunting season is to preserve a
population
and if your limit is five squirrels a
day but some of those squirrels have
young comes back to the nest
you're back
more than five a day effectively and
that's a problem because the purpose of
a hunting season and limits on hunting
is to ensure that the population remains
for future hunting
and it's that sort of potential
mismanagement that works against
the entire
goal of a hunting season and limits on
hunting
i feel that this date of september 15th
is a reasonable compromise i think that
it preserves the need of the fish and
game commission to have
the ability like that open-ended ability
to set dates in accordance with
population changes i hope that it
strikes a balance between what the two
teams in this room kind of are wanting
and i also want to mention
to kind of
underscore the possibility that the
september first date is just a clear
clerical error
in maine the season begins september
25th which is pretty close to the last
saturday in september in massachusetts
the day floats a little based on
holidays but in one zone in the state it
begins september 13th and another zone
it begins october 15th so it's a lot
later and in rhode island it begins
october 16th so i think that generally
there's always been an intent for the
beginning of the squirrel gray scroll
season to be around
the first of october and i think that
the if you look at the documentation
you'll see that it appears
that september 1st is just a mistake
and
that's the whole point of this bill
thank you i'll start any community
members have any questions
i just have one were you aware you could
file uh official requests or open
rulemaking as a state legislator to the
department and especially citing the
administrative rule uh to have them
reopen rulemaking if they felt it was
appropriate and did you follow that
process
thank you it's my understanding that
after the petition that was made in 2019
to change um the opening of the season
failed that that's where that
conversation ends and that this is the
next step
any other questions from community
members
thank you representative bolden
appreciate it
next up is representative howard pearl
speak in opposition to the bill
and just for community members i'm going
to forward representative pearl sent
some photos in but we only have one copy
so i'm just sitting around so you can
look at it and he can explain what they
are
thank you mr chairman and i thank you
members of the fish and game committee
for the record my name is representative
howard pearl from loudoun i represent
merrimack 26.
so uh as the chairman has stated i sent
around some pictures that you'll see
the kind of damage that gray squirrels
do to the infrastructure that i work
with in the maple industry
you'll see that there's some pieces of
tubing the plastic tubing that we use
that are
very very much destroyed
and
in the i also sent a picture of one of
my
buildings that houses some of my maple
equipment that they we have to keep warm
the squirrels got into the building and
just destroyed it so
i am here um opposing shortening the
season in fact i'd very much recommend
to the committee that you lengthen the
season or completely abolish it just
like we have with any of the other
rodents in the red squirrels or
chipmunks or any of the others they do a
tremendous amount of damage that we deal
with in the agricultural industry on a
very regular basis
grey squirrels probably cost my business
well in excess of ten to twenty thousand
dollars a year in the damage that they
do in the in the woods in the in the
lines that we use for the maple
collection and again in my buildings
the um
i recognize that uh
many people think that gray squirrels
are pretty and they're cute and they're
fun to look at
in that they probably all are but i can
tell you if you've spent the thousands
of hours in repairing the damage that
they do and i wish i was exaggerating
just on my own farm i spend literally
thousands of hours
repairing what they destroy and i can
tell you that all throughout the state
we have a vast collection of maple
producers who would very much back the
feeling that these are
these animals do a lot of damage so i
would encourage the committee certainly
not to shorten the season and if you
really want to do something that would
benefit agriculture you'd consider
abolishing the season and let them
letting us deal with them in the manner
that we need to to
sort of protect the
infrastructure in the business that we
have in place
they do a tremendous amount of damage in
the fields in my crops too in the squash
and especially winter squash because
they're chasing the seeds as we approach
winter so we have a lot of damage
between them and the field nice as
they're chewing the product and making
it unsalable for us
i won't take any more of your time i
know you've got a ton of people that
want to testify and you've got a lot on
your next bill but i'll certainly
entertain any questions
thank you representative any questions
from the committee representative
thank you mr chairman
thank you representative pearl
um
quick question sure based on your
testimony i just had a question for
myself
it's a hunting season do you know of
anybody who hunts grey squirrels or did
they just kill them because they're
eating pipes
so there are a few people that do hunt
and it's a great question and thank you
for it there are a few people that will
hunt and we certainly encourage
anyone that's interested in wanting to
to you know come out and take care of
you know wanting to do that hunting but
there's not a lot
these animals are very prolific and we
eliminate what we can of them reasonably
to try and protect our infrastructure
but we fall behind every year i mean the
again i can't
i can't tell you the vast amount of
damage that that they do on these
systems
they may chew every six inches on a
piece of pipe at times and i have more
than 450 000 feet of pipe on my farm
and they just they will literally chew
10 000 20 000 holes in it in the season
it's amazing
and frustrating all the same but thank
you for the question
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question are you aware that
the hunting seasons do not impact a
landowner or farmer's ability to do pest
management
for the very reasons that you've already
laid out
certainly thank you for the question i
am aware of that but the problem is
there's one of me and i'm only allowed
to do a certain amount if i want to have
other folks help me then they have to
abide by the hunting rules in order to
thank you uh representative kanye for a
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative howard for taking my
question
uh
let me give you a little bit background
then i'll post that question you know
while i was preparing for this testimony
uh my wife
asked me to tell everybody that we have
to pear tree
and i i am a big follower of leave and
let leave but we have two pear tree we
cannot have one pair in here you know
everything is gone at the end of the
season the main reason is
there's a solar panels we have in three
houses in our neighborhood they all live
under the solar panel if they live in
the trees and other places is no problem
but they have a really big concentration
of those things so do you believe that
while we are doing this those
you know solar panel has to be you know
changed so we we can live peacefully and
they can live peacefully in their
habitat
thank you for the question i i honestly
don't know a lot about
you know their habitats uh in in that
particular
instance but i can tell you that they
habitate in my buildings especially and
they do an
awful lot of damage
to
many of the outbuildings that i have
so i'll stick to speaking just to what i
know about but thank you for the
question
any further questions for representative
pearl
they're being done thanks representative
pearl thank you
i'm going to bring the general public up
next and then we'll move to the various
people are representing so next up is
good afternoon uh can you hear me okay
let's put the mic a little closer so you
can hear
okay thank you
uh yes my name is christina snyder and i
i originally um i did
send in electronic testimony i did
verify from one rep that it was received
but i do have copies here if you'd like
to see that as well
i i was the member of the public that
petitioned fish and game department in
2019 to
push back the start date of the great
eastern gray squirrel season
from september 1st to september 15th
and i came about that petition after
looking at other states in new england
and when their dates were
and three are later and then
i also was seeing several posts about
orphan baby gray squirrels that were
being brought in to wildlife
rehabilitators
which led me to believe that if the
mother squirrel is being hunted then
there are the orphaned babies left in
the nest
so i was seeing and i got in touch with
several wildlife rehabilitators
and they they confirmed that and that
was in my testimony that i sent in and i
also saw that there was a post
excuse me let me go back um so with the
petition
i went through the process
and then when the biologists decided to
go against the petition they cited
studies from 1994 and 1977 from
massachusetts in new york and by the way
massachusetts actually has a later start
date for the gray squirrel they have
two zones in zones one through nine it
starts 9 12
zones 10 through 14 it starts
mid-october so
one of the states they use the studies
from is actually has a later
season start
and
what happened with with the process was
that in in my view and in other views
that observe the process and i will say
that i know that there are a couple of
commissioners here today but they were
not on the commission when this petition
happened
so
what happened was
the
the biologists went against the petition
however it came about that the
commission itself never received all of
the testimony that was in support of the
petition which was from the wildlife
rehabilitators and a couple of the
commissioners said i don't want to vote
i'd like to table until we see that
information
the chair of the commission at the time
said nope we're going to deny this let's
vote now and he made a motion to deny
the petition or say no
and that was the prevailing vote so i
actually had legal counsel come up to me
and apologize and say that was my bad
and and
the
chief biologist at the time said as well
that he was sorry it was his mistake so
the the commission never even saw all of
the information
so that's why this kind of came into
legislation because and then by in the
rulings and in the hearings i kept
bringing up this information and it was
just disregarded
so
you know
it's very clear because even fish and
game in 2011 put a post out on facebook
saying that they were receiving many
calls
that there were high winds and baby
squirrels were falling out a nest in the
trees and that was on august 29th and
they said they didn't say baby squirrels
they were seeing them they said they
were falling out of the nest on the
trees they were helpless and they
referred them to wildlife rehabilitators
well it also came to my attention
that wildlife rehabilitator testimony
and and data and stats on the grey
squirrels was never even looked at or
considered when they made this decision
to go against a petition or when the
squirrel season should start or not
start given the reproduction rate of
of the grey squirrels
so
they did they did refer to nuisance
trappers and i i did hear uh
what was just testimony before me about
the nuisance and however nuisance
trapping
and nuisance permits are allowed all
year round
and i you know i i would think that if
the department was getting so many
nuisance calls about squirrels
then they might relent on the predators
a little bit and they might put a cap on
the foxes
so that the foxes could hunt the grey
squirrels but unfortunately they allow
an unlimited take on the fox and i know
that uh it's good to know a little bit
that there might be this nuisance
because then at least we know that the
bobcat if that comes up again can help
take care of the squirrels and we won't
need a season on the bobcat
so
nuisance there is nature predators can
take care of the nuisance this just has
to do with the baby squirrels it has to
do with them being orphaned
and if the hunter kills
the mother squirrel the babies will die
and if the season was extended on the
tail end it was extended from december
31st to january 31st so it still would
even be two weeks more and if you have a
five-take limit and there's 130 days of
the season that still allows every
squirrel hunter 690 squirrels that they
can kill
and if you wanted to you know if there
was such an issue with the nuisance why
does fishing game why isn't it
petitioned to take off the limit of five
and put unlimited
it's really it's the timing factor
that's important because they do
consider reproduction and when animals
are dependent on their their mothers for
other seasons or other animals that they
they dictate seasons for so why is the
squirrel any different they even say so
themselves that there are dependent
squirrels this time of year
it's just two weeks
it's not a big question it's it's it's a
very good compromise
and it just seems that it's not a lot to
ask and the evidence is all there and
the wildlife rehabilitators that they
refer these animals to they're not
referring trappers they're referring
these orphans to the wildlife real
rehabilitators they're not seeking their
input they're not seeking their
testimony and the wildlife
rehabilitators they know the most about
the reproduction
and what the needs are of an orphan
squirrel and how much they need to be
dependent on their mother
so that's why we're here today
thank you miss schneider any questions
for miss snyder
seeing none thank you for coming before
the fishing game committee and thank you
for your testimony
next up is robert kessling who is
representing himself from manchester and
hi my name is robert kessling thank you
for hearing my testimony good afternoon
i'm proud to support hb 1356 which seeks
to delay
the season uh for just two weeks
although this may not seem like a lot of
time these 14 days make a huge
difference for the population
as you heard wildlife rehabilitators are
seeing more and more orphaned squirrels
after the start of the current
season these offspring are still in the
nest and dependent upon their mother and
i think if you can imagine a uh
a year old human baby how completely
helpless they are now imagine the
squirrel baby
takes him a little less time to get out
of the nest but they still need the help
of their of their mother before they can
do so
delaying the start of the hunting season
by 14 days while having a minimal impact
on hunters as as stated so far would
provide more time for the mother to
teach crucial
survival skills to their offspring
so two weeks goes by and flash for us
i'm sure coming out of the holiday
season you can look back and see two
weeks gone in no time but for a baby
squirrel uh that amount of time can mean
life or death so
i encourage you to protect the the
eastern gray squirrel babies
and the population please vote yes on
this bill
is there questions for mr kessling
thank you very much for your testimony
next up oh i'm gonna mess this one up
tone
tone let's just do that
you can you can say your last name when
you get up here
thank you for having me here today this
is going to be very short and sweet
for me to say i am in here in support of
bill 1356 because quite frankly
squirrels can't speak for themselves
uh and if
i don't speak up for them i'm not sure
who will
there's many of us out here who care but
um i'm like to put my voice out there
as a civilized society i believe we need
to minimize the suffering
of
not just human babies but non-human
babies as well
i don't think you need to be a mother or
father to recognize why leaving orphaned
babies in the wild to languish and
suffer with little to no means to feed
but you do need to have empathy
this is extremely poor management and
treatment of our wildlife
so i ask you to please vote yes on this
bill thank you
thank you very much any questions can
you tell me how you say your last name
groshala crochet any questions mr
rochelle
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you for coming for the fish and
game committee thank you
next up is dan berceron new hampshire
fish and game in opposition to the bill
um just let people know we have six more
speakers at least based on the cards i
um so
dan birdron chief of the wildlife
division for new hampshire fish and game
here representing the department the
commission in opposition of hb 1356
so gray squirrels have a hunting season
in all five new england states in new
york
as is as has been mentioned in previous
testimony
hunting seasons vary there are a number
of states that start later than new
hampshire
there are a number of states that start
the same time so new hampshire vermont
connecticut and new york
all have similar start dates of
september 1st hunting seasons vary
from state to state on a routine basis
some of it is based on biology some of
it is just based on tradition of where
the seasons typically took place
so it's not unusual to have variation in
the start dates or end dates of hunting
seasons
some of it deals with the amount of
hunting pressure and how that might vary
environmental factors there's there's a
number of reasons why season start dates
or end dates might vary between states
the department tracks both hunter effort
and hunter observation rates of
squirrels
through our small game uh hunter survey
data from this survey indicates um that
there's very low hunting pressure on
grey squirrels approximately nine
percent of small game hunters pursue
gray squirrels
squirrel observation rates
that we get from this hunter survey so
that's the number of squirrels seen per
100 hours of hunting
have been stable or increasing
in the state over time
squirrel populations are largely driven
by natural food availability and weather
patterns
and annual fluctuations in their
population levels are common
it's believed hunting mortality
is is minimal
as it compares to other sources of
mortality
part because hunting pressure is low
and squirrels are a highly productive
animal
to demonstrate this point um
our squirrel observation rates we
noticed a decline
um in 2000 uh or following 2018 um i'm
sure you all remember the year of 2018
there was a large scale mortality event
of grey squirrels
it was very evident they were all over
the roadways there was media coverage
about it
this mortality event was the result of
abundant natural food availability
for several years in a row that caused
the squirrel population to peak
that was followed by a complete failure
of natural foods
when natural foods
when natural foods aren't available
animals
move and disperse more to find food
sources and they come in contact with
vehicles more often they get pretty pond
more often
but it was very evident um department
biologists conduct surveys of different
wildlife food sources on an annual basis
and it was very clear through the
results of those surveys um that that
main
food sources for squirrels namely acorns
and beech nuts um we're at a we're at a
historical low
resulting in this this large scale
um
so
and again this this petition um the
petition to change the start date of the
squirrel season followed that large
mortality event um
i'm i'm sure that there were a number of
um orphan squirrels that showed up at
rehabilitators um following this year um
and and i think it's important to note
though that large-scale mortality events
like that are not the norm
in response to the petition that the
commission received at the time
department staff reviewed information on
hunter effort on squirrel observation
rates
you'd heard reference before two studies
one from massachusetts around 1976 1977
and another from new york in 1994.
these two studies
showed
so the massachusetts study um they they
took hunter harvested squirrels checked
lactation status to get an idea of how
many of these squirrels might still have
dependent young
it's true uh at that point when the
study was conducted the start date for
massachusetts squirrel hunting season
was the second monday in september
what they found was approximately 1.3
percent of the squirrels that they
looked at
were
lactating and then the new york study
and in new york the start date was at
the beginning of september similar to
new hampshire's
also found a 1.3 percent
of harvested squirrels were lactating
start dates of the seasons were
different but these very low percentages
indicate that the number of squirrels
that are still lactating by september is
we we did not consider the department
did not consider information from
rehabilitators
in part because the information that we
receive from rehabilitators
is not always complete so they don't
necessarily indicate
whether a squirrel is dependent young or
not it might they might just indicate
that they accepted a squirrel so it's
it's it's not a representative sample of
the overall population um
so it's difficult to make assumptions
about an overall population based on
animals that come into rehabilitation
centers
again a lot of these animals are likely
coming from homes
if someone trapped an animal
um or or did
did work to keep them out of their house
then that's where people are likely
coming in contact with these animals
um
we've heard comments um suggesting that
the studies because they were um
conducted in the past should not be
considered
um and we've also heard comments
recently that squirrels are changing
their their timing of their breeding
because of climate change
um
biological staff
did a research
review
we could not find any research that
indicated that the timing of breeding is
changing as a result of climate change
what the research does show is that the
main cue for reproduction in squirrels
is photo period
or length of day
this is a common reproductive cue in
wildlife species
it is consistent and it does not change
over time
so from year to year it triggers hormone
production and then reproduction
and it is used specifically because it
is consistent
as an example deer are another species
whose reproductive cue is photoperiod or
day length
the department has conducted studies on
reproduction of deer in the state
we conducted a study in the 1980s and
then a similar study in 2013 and we
found no significant difference in the
timing of reproduction so
historical studies on reproduction of
species that are that are cued by
um so so given these findings um you
know that squirrel reproduction is
triggered by photo period
that these two studies found very low
percentages of squirrels that were
lactating in september
the fact that hunting pressure on
squirrels is low in the state that
squirrels are highly productive and that
observation rates indicate that the
squirrel population is stable or
increasing the department does not feel
that the continued
season framework of the start date of
september 1st will have a negative
impact on the state squirrel population
thank you
any questions for fish and game
representative
spelling
thank you mr chair i just have one
have grey squirrels ever been endangered
as a population in new hampshire no
thank you
any further questions
representative reed
thank you for taking my question i
understand that given all the evidence
you just gave your determination is that
it doesn't appear the september first
start date doesn't appear to be having
any kind of bad impact on the population
and i understand that but considering
that this may have been a clerical error
um i guess my question is why not change
it to mid-september
better safe than sorry what is there any
harm in changing it to mid-september
yeah so i i would
i would have to do some research on
whether or not this was a clerical error
i would i would find it hard to believe
that it was a clerical error
in in part because
not only when we go through the
administrative rule process not only do
we file the rules
um we file the rules through jail carr
and legislative services
they don't do all their reviews there
but i mean we give presentations to the
public where these dates are posted all
this information ends up going into our
hunting digest and online so the
likelihood that the date would have been
missed in all those different places
seems unlikely to me
2004 was before my time so i can check
on that but i would find it hard to
believe that that it was missed in so
just a simple follow-up because i'm i
serve on jalgar doesn't your rules have
to be reaffirmed every 10 years
um i believe so yeah
so the 2004 rule would have been
representative
uh thank you mr chair um do you have any
thoughts on the advisability of as was
suggested by previous speaker
of permitting hunting gray squirrels
year round
um we
so we feel that the current season
framework is a good compromise um
between between individuals who who just
enjoy squirrels for intrinsic reasons
and hunters
there are mechanisms for individuals who
are experiencing damage to
to to combat those issues so we feel the
current season framework is a good
compromise between multiple parties
thank you
any further questions from the committee
there being then mr bergeron thank you
so we have four more speakers
um
yeah
well the first thing i'd say well
mr chair members of community the first
thing i'd say it's really unfortunate
that this kind of issue has to be
brought before the legislature but
considering that in my opinion new
hampshire fish and game dropped the ball
on
the rationale for denying the petition
i think there's a process here that is
we were just told the reasons
there i've looked at those reasons i
think the first thing about where our
neighboring states start the season is
totally irrelevant to what new hampshire
does it's different
seasons change depending upon the
latitude
and
if anybody is
i guess interested in what the seasons
are going all the way down the eastern
seaboard you'll find that as you go
further south of seasons or later i
think a testimony to the fact that uh
it's not just photo period that triggers
squirrel breeding it's also warmth in
fact the southern states have less light
climate change is a thing that is uh
obviously controversial controversial
from political standpoint but our fish
and game has been considering the
effects of climate change on wildlife
since 2005
as part of the wildlife action plan and
one of their former
fur bearing biologists has lectured
around the state over the last 10 or 12
years about how that is affecting
wildlife
i think from a deductive reasoning if we
say you know the fact that
seasons get later as you go south that
have more warmth that you'd see that the
argument that the
season should be later
up here in new hampshire as
the season as the climate changes
is supportable
the um so i i think uh the testimony
that i submitted that and ms snyder
submitted would give you the idea of
when
season should start if one wanted to
protect the young and the nest
who are basically dependent on the
mother for the first seeks with six
weeks up to ten weeks
the other uh
thing i want to take a little bit of uh
i guess
exception to is the other reasons
submitted in the denial of the petition
one is that
the game survey that showed only nine
percent of the small game hunters hunt
squirrels what does that mean nine
percent does that mean
a hundred or a thousand it has no
relationship to the pressure put on the
the
so-called literature that was cited in
the denial of the petition are
essentially internal progress reports
that are on not peer-reviewed at all in
fact
the number of two percent lactating
is basically khan is contradicted by the
massachusetts report that shows that
squirrels
in september and october have uh i i
provided this as part of the thing the
percent of adult females with enlarged
teats ranges from 60 to 100 percent
suggesting that they are lactating all
the way through oh maybe the end of
october
so that wasn't taken in consideration
either so i think for those reasons
although the
legislature should have to make these
kinds of decisions it should be sent
back to fish and game for them to do a
thorough research on squirrel biology
here
and the last thing i'm i will say
to those who are worried about being run
over by squirrels and other rodents
it's not
our ability it's not our role to kill
all the rodents is it
if only we had a good healthy population
of predators
unfortunately
that's another
thing that we don't have here in new
hampshire because the
populations of furbearing predators have
decreased
50 or 60 percent over the last two
decades which is irrelevant to this bill
but it is relevant to man's role in
controlling their environment thank you
very much
thank you mr bosworth any questions for
mr bosworth
seeing none thank you very much sir
thank you for coming for the fishing
game committee
next up is joseph mullen who was opposed
to the bill
he's from the congressional sportsmen's
foundation
good afternoon chairman lang and
honorable members of the house fish and
game and marine resources committee my
name is joe mullen i'm from grafton
massachusetts and i'm the northeastern
states assistant manager for the
congressional sportsman's foundation i
appear before you this afternoon to
express my strong opposition to house
bill 1356
i plan on supplementing my testimony
with a letter of opposition so i'm just
going to provide some of my primary
arguments against this bill
simply put house bill 1356 would subvert
the new hampshire fish and game
department's authority when it comes to
setting the gray squirrel hunting
seasons
the first and likely most obvious case
for not stripping the department of this
role
is that the department is in the best
position to make sound science-based
management decisions
for over a century
and a half the department has been
driving force behind new hampshire's
on-the-ground efforts that have resulted
in flourishing wildlife populations
the department is composed of a force of
highly educated and widely experienced
staff which includes a multitude of
biologists policy experts and support
and enforcement personnel
all of whom have instrumental roles in
determining the appropriate seasons for
not only gray squirrels but all game
species
should the department decide to make any
rule changes for a particular year must
follow the established rulemaking
process that provides a wealth of
transparency at all points it's also in
a unique position where it is able to
react to changing conditions in real
time
through evaluating the many variables
that go towards setting a grey squirrel
hunting season and utilizing
inter-departmental collaboration
it would be able to shorten or expand
the season relying on current data and
observations
i'll wrap up by reiterating my
opposition to house bill 1356. i thank
thank you mr small any questions for mr
mullin
seeing none thank you sir for coming for
the fishing game committee
next up is
elise
sorry i can't
sorry elise letizia i'm a resident of
claremont
i've been a lifelong outdoor enthusiast
but i only took up hunting three years
ago and i actually started hunting with
grey squirrel it's a great way to get
introduced to the sport
i love squirrels i think they're
fascinating beautiful awesome cool
creatures i also like to use them as
part of my meals and i try to use as
much of the animal as possible the fur
the tail and i have my squirrel foot
handmade earrings that i made on today
but i'm not speaking personally i am
speaking on behalf of bha again i've
condensed this a little bit because
a core principle of back country hunters
and anglers is its support for the north
american model of wildlife conservation
under this model we've empowered the
department with a set of tools including
the ability to set season dates and
lengths bag limits and appropriate
methods of take which combined with
current science and biological evidence
allows them to effectively manage the
state's game species
hp 1356 imposes a limitation on when the
gray squirrel season starts which
essentially removes one of these
wildlife management tools from the
department and puts it into the
legislative realm going forward this
would hinder the department's ability to
fulfill their mandate maintaining that
solely the department has the ability to
set season dates and also helps to
ensure that changes are motivated by
biological evidence and management needs
as opposed to public opinion and
preferences
for these reasons on behalf of bha's
members in new hampshire we ask that you
oppose h.b 1356 thank you all for the
opportunity to speak today and for
taking our comments into consideration
thank you elise any questions for elise
seeing them thank you again for coming
before the fish and game committee
last speaker is kyle baker of the new
hampshire wildlife federation in
good afternoon again i'll be very brief
since most of my points have already
been
make sure you're up to the mic so people
can hear you most of my points have
already been taken but i'm kyle baker
here on behalf of new hampshire wildlife
federation with concerns about this
particular bill our main concern doesn't
deal with whether or not which date the
season should be set at it's how the
season is set um we strongly believe uh
similar to speakers before us that
the best place to have discussions about
setting the seasons um is within the
fishing games biennial rule making
process
so
that is pretty much all i wanted to
touch on we would say that if the
committee was interested in moving
forward with something similar to this
we think a more appropriate method would
be to then direct the department to
reopen this role making process and look
into it
providing opportunity for continued
stakeholder input
thank you sir for your testimony any
questions for mr baker
representative reed
thank you mr chair and i actually tried
to ask a question last time but you
brought up the same issue as the
previous speaker so i'll ask you instead
um and i don't have the bill right well
it probably is right in front of me but
i cannot find it right now
but i believe if i'm not mistaken that
the bill
sets a limit but allows the department
to set the date later isn't that the
case and if it is the case doesn't that
also mean that the department still has
that kind of discretion to set the date
sure and thank you for the question yes
the the bill does just set a sort of a
dead stop you know you cannot start
before this particular date uh it would
be the one and only unique um situation
where we've essentially stripped the
authority of the fish and game
department to determine whether or not
uh whether it's september 1st september
15th or august 15th depending on what
the what the current and most up-to-date
any further questions for mr baker
seeing none thank you mr baker
appreciate your testimony today thank
you for coming for the fish and game
committee
so anybody else wishing to testify in
house bill 1356 of
an act relative to the taking of grey
squirrels
there being none i'm just gonna have a
couple minute conversation with the
committee um
so
i'm inclined to hold this till the 25th
but i'm also you know
mindful of the fact that in every other
instance we've defaulted to the fact
that we allow fish and game the right to
manage their season and this flies in
the face of that i'm pretty sure fish
and game got the message loud and clear
about what the will of the people are
and they may they may take it up on
their own um after this but um i guess
i'm you know do we do we think we need
to move you know uh continue this bill
or do we think there's an itl motion
that should be made
uh representative reid first then
representative spelaine
thank you mr chair um and while i
understand your point that we've sent a
message and we're hoping that the
commission will uh react to the will of
the people i can
and i apologize for this but before you
were on this committee i can attest to
the fact that messages have been sent
about this very type of issue about
people
expressing their opinion that ignored
we should hold on to this bill a little
bit longer
representative spelaine thank you mr
chair i think that um
i would entertain a motion to itl this
and think that that would be the proper
disposition today to allow us to move
forward with the next bill and get it
off our plate
i don't think that anything is going to
change between now and the 25th
i moved to itl the bill uh we're not in
executive session we're just in
discussion right now so there's no
motions on the floor i'm i'm gonna i'm
gonna hold the bill to the 25th i think
it's reasonable for the members to have
further discussion about this and again
again about that policy we generally
have about leaving hunting seasons and
taking seasons to the purview of fish
and game and not starting putting them
in statutes that lead us down the road
i'm not sure we want to go
talking about the every species and what
the hunting season should be
and whether we leave that with fish and
game but i'll leave it to the 25th and
with that i'm going to close the public
we're going to take a few minute recess
let's come back at 405. so you've got
about 13 minutes uh use a bio break take
stretch your legs and we'll come back
and we'll take up the final bill of the
all right if members can start making
their way to the sea we've got about 30
seconds here before we're ready to kick
it off i will tell you we have 20 20
cards of people who wish to testify on
this bill
and because of that i'm going to ask i'm
going to limit testimony to two and a
half minutes
give people time to testify but try to
tight that does not that does not apply
to the sponsor
and does not apply to the department who
is generally answering all of our
questions as as uh as the expert in the
field so those two agent the agency
itself and the sponsor will be able to
speak for as long as necessary as they
need to answer our questions and give
testimony and then but everybody else be
held to a two and a half minute mark and
we'll give you
you know that mr the vice chair over
here is going to keep the timer and
he'll put his hand up when he got 30
seconds so you have time to wrap up your
thing people are settling themselves i'm
going to hold up something
that is a picture of the snowshoe fair
done in a book that my husband was given
when he was eight years old
about wild animals
in the united states
and of course it shows the snowshoe hair
in the winter being white
in the summer being brown
and i think it's a beautiful picture
it's certainly one of the things that
makes and impels me to speak today
all right
uh we're back and we're live and uh i'm
gonna open up the public uh hearing on
house bill 308 prohibiting to capture
possession propagation of hairs rabbits
and hunting for hunting dog training and
field trials
so
i recognize the prime sponsor
representative edith tucker
and either if you please introduce your
bill and tell us about it thank you very
much mr chairman thank you for all
putting in such a long day today
and i'll try to compress my remarks
somewhat but i have spent quite a lot of
time researching this topic about which
i knew very little when i began i want
to start my introduction
i'm a representative from coast county i
live in randolph i represent whitefield
jefferson carroll and randolph
district five and i want to explain that
i was just appointed recently to gelcar
the
joint legislative committee on
administrative rules i'm still an
alternate
which means i don't get to vote unless
there's a vacancy on the committee that
particular day but one of the first
meetings i attended voices of wildlife a
non-profit organization which i had not
run into before of volunteers
sought to repeal the fish and game
provisions for beagle clubs and snowshoe
hare that are addressed in this bill
jelcar decided however that if such
changes were to be made it should be
through the legislative process and not
by just changing rules linda dion who
had testified on behalf of voices
asked if there were any jail car members
who would like to help with bill making
legislative process gel carr chairman
senator john regan of deerfield and i
both committed ourselves to doing so
so i made that commitment because i
believe what new hampshire fish and game
currently allows
the live trapping and transfer of
snowshoe hair
away from their home grounds
to use be used by in
large
uh
for state beagle clubs for training
their hounds by running them in large
enclosures
as well as in competitive field trials
sanctioned by the american kennel club
is an out-of-date
outmoded practice that reflects very
poorly on a generally well-regarded
state agency
as a north country reporter for some 25
years i've covered the outstanding work
of many conservation officers and
biologists and i wanted to work to align
this important state agency with current
breast best management practices
based on our greater
and growing respect for and
understanding of wild animals
after all
no one would advocate for live trapping
and transporting
a wild bear
so it could be used to train bear hounds
and no one would propose that game bird
dogs such as the one my husband and i
owned be permitted to live trap
the hunters would be permitted to live
trap and transport wild grouse and
woodcock
to train
their dogs
bear hunters and game bird hunters train
their dogs in the wild
and snowshoe hair hunters can do the
same
when this bill was discussed at the
december 14
2021 fish and game commission meeting
chairman eric stoll
a former district
1 state representative
who earlier served as the agency's
region one lieutenant
the ranking officer
said that he is not opposed to the
passage of this bill
according to the
meeting minutes he said quote
i do not believe in taking an animal
out of the wild for training purposes
a wild animal belongs in the wild
the other nine commissioners on hand
however
voted to oppose the bill
the agency's mission statement
states clearly as the guardian of new
hampshire's fish wildlife and marine
resources
the new hampshire fish and game
department
works in partnership with the public to
conserve manage and protect protect
these resources
and their habitats
inform and educate the public about
these resources
and provide the public with opportunity
to use and appreciate them
the department's email address
is
wildlife.new hampshire.gov
certainly highlights its top priority
wildlife
the beagle clubs exist to improve the
genetics
of a domesticated purebred animal and
not to enhance or improve the lives of
wild snowshoe hair
and or rabbits
you will hear testimony today on the
history of field trials
as reported by the american kennel club
in a history website that they have
online
and i have the address and you will get
it on the handout
beagles have won best in show
twice in the last 20 years at the akc's
most important annual event the
westminster dog show at madison square
garden
there are dollars to be earned by
breeding showing and selling purebred
dogs
including beagles
you'll also hear testimony
based on reports developed by the
beagles clubs themselves as required by
law
that the captured snowshoe hair has not
produced as many kits
or leverage as had been anticipated
when the be beagle club rules first went
into effect and i think those statistics
are very telling and they are compiled
and sent in by the clubs
in conformance with the requirements to
the fish and game department every year
it's particularly important to remember
that the snowshoe hare is a keystone
prey species
critical to the survival of fox
coyote
canada lynx
hawks and owls you will hear testimony
on the challenges that climate change
with shorter winters
in the granite state poses to the
snowshoe hare
as well as
the threat of transmitting and spreading
new diseases that are coming in from the
west that have the potential to
adversely affect granite state hairs and
rabbits there appears to be no
problem with the number of snowshoe
hares
at the moment but we need to be prepared
for the future
there have been many people
both ford against this bill
who have provided me with information
and insights on the beagle clubs
as well as the live trapping and
transporting of snowshoe hare
i'd like to thank them all
for their great generosity
and i mentioned this because i
spent some time on the phone with
someone in gorham new hampshire in the
town next to me
who
has been active in a club
in the milan gorham area
and i was spent some time
at the generosity of people at the
claremont club who might have been a
little hesitant to have me come to their
club and welcome me and answer all my
questions
and i think that's outstanding so with
that i would take questions
thank you representative tucker members
of the committee do you have any
questions for representative tucker
seeing none thank you representative
and next up is representative dennis
thompson
and the town two and so you have two and
mr chairman and members of the committee
i thank you for hearing me today
in support of the bill
um i provided you all with tesla with
written testimony and i'll i'll make it
as short and sweet as i can
um
hb-1308 for many years i was a hunter
mostly rabbits
mostly in the north country
meridian hill my special
i would
in all my years of training using my
dogs for the purpose of hunting i would
have never considered capturing holding
or using
rabbits as bait
for training my dogs and let there be no
no
misunderstanding
rabbits are bait
used in this particular instance
it's no different than putting a worm on
a hook and never catching a fish
you've still
killed the worm
propagation of these animals would
likely cause them to become somewhat
domesticated and not wild animals
which is what hunting rules were
intended for wild animals are not bait
putting donuts and scraps out to bait a
bear or corn out for a deer i understand
this
but raising one animal to train another
it just isn't right
unless you're
you are not just an expert in handling
domesticated rabbits but you also have
done a lot of wildlife rehab work with
wild rabbits especially younger ones
then your chances are so low of trying
to raise them that could be argued it's
inhumane
they're one of the hardest wild mammals
to raise and rehabilitate they over
stress easily because of how much faster
they grow than domestic rabbits and they
also go downhill faster in health issues
when they emerge
should you import these animals should
the import of these animals happen and
it most likely will
there is a possibility that rabbit
rabbit hemorrhagic disease rhd as it's
known
also known
as viral hemorrhagic disease vhd i know
we've gone into a number of hd's today
it's highly infectious in a lethal form
of viral hepatitis
that affects european rabbits some viral
strains also affect hairs and cottontail
rabbits
mortality rates generally range from 70
to 100 percent
this disease has been found in
southwestern in the southwestern united
states and has made its way as far east
as illinois it can affect pets as well
as humans my source of this information
is from a usda study which is ongoing
in closing i urge the committee to vote
otp in this bill it's not only the
humane thing to do moreover it's the
right thing to do i want to thank you
very much and i'll take any questions
thank representative any questions for
the committee
there being none thank you sir for
coming for the fish and game committee
thank you very much
next up in support of the bill is linda
dion
good afternoon chairman lang committee
members um my name is linda dion
i'm here giving support for hb 1308
and the first thing i want to say is
this is not an anti-hunting bill
as some opponents have said you'll hear
some proponents say that today it is a
conservation bill it
oh
who's that
anyway it's not an anti-hunting bill
as some opponents will say it's a
conservation bill
it's a bill to conserve the keystone
also
some some people may claim that there
are plenty of snowshoe hairs out in the
wild
but there's no data to back that up
um but however signs point to the fact
that snowshoe hairs are in trouble
they're mainly in trouble because of our
milder winters and for the
characteristics
that they're famous for that we know and
love
the color change in the winter to white
which doesn't help much when there's no
snow out there and the big feet
that act like a snowshoe that allows
them to escape from prey
so anyway it's not an anti-hunty bill
and we don't know how many are out there
in the forest
john levitis he's a wildlife biologist
and a supporter of snowshoe hunting he
supports the spill and he wrote
in an article in northern woodlands an
article entitled a white hair in a brown
forest
i think that speaks for itself a white
hair and a brown forest
that means that the milder winters are
going to affect this animal being white
they lose their ability to camouflage
so that's john levitis
a supporter of the bill who also hunts
snowshoe hares
there's also been habitat loss for the
snowshoe here
the new hampshire snowshoe hair
assessment report in 2015 conducted by
stated that
the snowshoe hail lost over 150 000
acres of land between the years of 2001
and this is a trend that will continue
as we all know
habitat loss is the problem
for many of our wildlife because of
development
okay so that was that was
sure one more second just right okay
um
another article was matters my hair and
that was in the wildlife journal
and it was um written by fish and game
biologists
and it
well i was going to read this part okay
it states no shoe his change color from
brown to white in the beginning of the
winter and back again to brown in the
spring a transformation triggered by
changing daylight recent
research has shown that hairs are
experiencing
more mismatched scenarios in which the
snow melts early or comes late and the
hairs are unable to blend into their
surroundings
interestingly hairs do not seem to
recognize when am is matched
which seems kind of cute to me can you
just see the little white hair
not realizing that the predator can see
him he thinks he's camouflaged so linda
you reached your time oh i have i'm
sorry well i've referenced it
you can submit your testimony if you
have if you haven't done it you can you
can give it to the committee assistant
okay i just want to stand right there
and he'll take he's got it and he'll
give pass it out make sure we all have
it so thank you very much for your
testimony appreciate it
thank you next up is tony granola
can never say your name sorry tony come
on up and try this again
good afternoon and thank you chairman
and members of the committee for giving
me the opportunity to speak my name is
tony groshala and i live in milford
i support bill 1308 because i oppose
taking animals out of the wild for what
amounts to a recreational endeavor
this denies a living creature the
comforts of its natural habitat and we
should not be in the business of putting
wildlife into captivity
furthermore removing them from their
natural habitat
threatens the lives of the other
creatures who depend on them among them
bobcats red foxes great horned owls and
the already threatened canadian links
this does nothing more than disrupt the
delicate food chain again for nothing
more
than a recreational endeavor that
exposes the hair to unjustified
suffering
thank
you you tony any questions for tony
seeing none thank you tony for
testifying in front of the house fish
next up is richard hood
thank you richard
moving on
and everybody else in the room thanks
you
uh joan o'brien
joan here
okay
okay thank you chairman lang members of
the committee my name is joan o'brien
i'm from amherst new hampshire i support
there are lots of good important reasons
to support this bill but i'm just going
to focus on one
and that is that the beagle clubs are
primarily interested in improving the
breed with hunting being of a lesser
emphasis
when the hampshire fish and game first
introduced the rule
allowing the clubs to capture the
snowshoe hares which was an exception to
their directive that wildlife should not
be taken out of the wild
it was justified as needed to support
the tradition continuing the tuition of
hunting
with dogs
yet at the new hampshire beagle clubs
the field trials in which the snowshoe
hares are used center around maintaining
and raising
american kennel club standards for the
beagles
from their field trial rules manual
the holding this is a quote the holding
of field trials at which purebred dogs
may be run in competition
has been found to be the best method by
which the progress which has been made
in breeding be shown
while it's the beagle dog club's
prerogative to pursue this goal it's not
an appropriate use of new hampshire's
wild hairs for this agenda
consider this quote from a beagle owner
i have a few young males that i hunt
with i have never done any trialing but
i thought about getting into it one of
my males sticks out especially and i
would someday like to have pups from him
i think i would like to get some points
on him before breeding him though
this is a person who is already hunting
with his beagles
he's looking to field trial competitions
as a way to get his dog a ranking that
could make him a a valuable stud dog
the point is that it seems it's not the
sport of hunting hairs that new
hampshire fishing game is underwriting
with the with the with the snowshoe
hares but rather the sport of perfecting
the beagle breed
highlighting how important the
competition aspect is the most shared
photos on social media are pictures of
winning dog lineups
it's worth noting that the akc earns
revenue whenever dog owners compete and
when breeders bring new dogs into the
world
according to the akc's 2018 annual
report the most recent version available
on the website the organization took in
33.5 million in registration fees and
11.7 million in event and recording fees
last year i'm sorry in 2018.
the akc does not earn money when
somebody takes his two more seconds
casey does not earn money when someone
grabs his dog and goes out into the
woods to hunt on his own
once again that's the club's prerogative
to hold these events
um but it should not take place at the
expense of our wild snowshoe hares
thank you for your testimony thank you
any questions
no questions to the committee thank you
for your testimony
next up is
uh
i think i just did that you're joan
next up in support of the bill is kurt
ehrenberg from the humane society united
i'll be extremely brief my name is kurt
erenberg i'm the state director of the
humane society of the united states
we're here to support
this bill
i just say that the practice we're
talking about here is barbaric it's
cruel it's inhumane
and it is totally unnecessary
so we support the passage of this bill
thank you very much
thank you kurt any questions for kurt
seeing none thank you again for your
testimony in front of the fish and game
committee
next up is robert kessler
chairman lang members of the committee
thank you for hearing my testimony my
name is robert kessling uh i'm speaking
on behalf of voices of wildlife in new
hampshire in support of this bill 1308
have some uh stuff to hand out to you
i'll try to get some help because
otherwise it'll be really awkward and
i'll try to move quickly
we
are recommending that you pass this bill
that prohibits capture wild hair and
relocation of them into captivity we
believe this practice
should be ended because it is
unnecessary and unnatural it is
unnecessary because beagles are
instinctive instinctive scent hunters
this is spoken to in an article on the
handout recently published in the union
leader by an experienced new hampshire
hunter who says that beagles do not need
to be trained to detect and pursue
rabbits instinct alone drives these
skills
this practice is also unnatural we agree
with commissioners commissioner stoll's
statement
that a wild animal belongs in the wild
the unnaturalness of this practice is
also evident by the low propagation and
survival rates that the clubs themselves
report there's a
a summary of a huge stack of paper of
reports that we got through a request
for information i
i'd like to just speak to one piece of
it first
the snowshoe here is a prolific reader
as mentioned in the article already
referenced matt as a march here
the biologist that wrote that article
estimates that hairs have three to five
what do you call litters a year and
produce six to eighteen labyrinths total
each year
however the propagation rates from the
clubs themselves do not come anywhere
near these numbers
to take one for example i don't want to
call them out i don't think they're
doing anything in particular different
from anybody else it just shows to show
this practice is not good for the
species
they relocated in 2019 20 hairs to their
to their club
four hairs were kept to be bred
they reported having 10 babies as a
according to the estimates provided by
the biologist the number should have
been 24 or much much higher
you can see in the uh
the the results that even the survival
rate is low this same club the following
year
said that they saw maybe 16 hairs as
they were out in the in their enclosures
so where are these hairs going this is
evidence that this practice does not
even allow the sustaining of these
populations uh even with hairs being
brought in in intentional propagation
so uh one point of procedure we did try
to bring this to the commission 10
seconds left thank you we tried to bring
it to the commission j.l carr
recommended we bring it here because
that went nowhere uh finally i'd like to
point out that opponents of this bill
will argue that we are trying to end a
time-honored tradition and with due
respect to tradition we disagree
this will not end running beagles this
will not end uh hunting snowshoe hare
however it will end the practice of
capturing wild animals putting them in
captivity thank you this is
fundamentally about the wild here not
the beakle clubs thank you very much
thank you for your testimony any
questions
representative laflamme thank you mr
chairman
mr kinsley you mentioned a low survival
rate
of the hairs that are in these do you
know if the low survival rate is due to
sickness disease or predation
uh thank you we
thank you we took a look at the reports
from the hair uh the beagle clubs
there was not much in the way of uh you
know some clubs report losing five maybe
ten hairs uh to different reasons there
was nothing that said uh anything about
uh disease in there but uh predation is
uh mentioned uh didn't seem there was no
numbers to
that stand out to me as significant
there
any further questions
seeing done thank you very much sir for
your testimony if you want to leave your
box over by representative horrigan we
can make sure it gets passed out to the
committee
next up is weldon bosworth again from
guilford
okay
next up is
angela ferrari
good evening i think we're at almost
evening now
chairman and members of the committee
thank you for hearing my testimony i am
here speaking on behalf of dog owners of
the granite state who monitors
legislation to keep an eye on pet owners
rights
we have we were founded back in 1991 so
we have been around for a while
and we are in opposition of hb 1308 we
believe it's a stepping stone to ending
all training of tracking and hunting
dogs in new hampshire
there's a few things that i did want to
clarify from some of the testimony
you've heard so far
the
beagle is a small sturdy hard-working
scent hound
their ability is focused on following
ascent
not capturing or killing game
so we've heard things words such as
barbaric and about the death of the
snowshoe hare and that is not the role
of a beagle in this sport
and that bill has been driven by
management of rabbits and hair used for
beagle training so i'd like to touch on
a few of those points
i have testimony for you that i'll hand
out if someone is
able to pass that around
that includes some q and a's that i'm
going to cover for you
so how are the hair captured they are
captured or taken in a large catch cage
or live trap similar to the types of
traps used for catching stray animals
when the trap is triggered a gravity or
spring driven door closes keeping the
animal inside of the cage such traps
cause no injury to the animal trapping
is a licensed regulated activity with
each beagle club requiring a license and
oversight
how are the hair kept in captivity when
you do get the documentation that's
going around there's a nice picture of
one of the new hampshire hair enclosures
and habitat you will see that it is
basically a large area of woods
30 seconds okay we're talking up to 55
acres or larger of natural habitat and
you can find more information
we also heard talks about being able to
just hunt in the wild without training
on a designated area they run on beagles
run on fenced acreage because their
ascent hound an inexperienced dog may
run a stray on scent trails from other
game
so that would be difficult to do proper
training
if you would please take a look at why
they also cannot use domesticated
rabbits and need to use the wild rabbits
that's in there as well lastly two quick
points
i personally have a beagle he isn't a
hunting beagle and i just wanted to let
everyone know that he could not probably
find a snowshoe hare out in the wild
without proper training he has the
instincts to hunt but he would probably
superior and i would never see him again
is very important
last piece real quick
hunters versus preservation breeders
we've heard things about
being in it for the money wanting to be
at the westminster dog show breed their
dogs
there is a bit of a difference there
between the preservation breeders who
aren't necessarily hunting and i just
want to make sure that it isn't being
confused that that's why they're out
there hunting to try and breed their
dogs thank you for your testimony any
questions from miss ferrari
thank you for taking my question um
and i i hear that you're saying that the
the hairs are necessary for training the
dogs
but i didn't hear anything in your
testimony that is getting at this main
question and that is
i would like a pet raccoon but i have
been told my whole life i'm not allowed
to go into the woods and catch a raccoon
and bring it home
i would really like one so why is it
that you all
get to capture rabbits
because you enjoy doing something with
them but i can't take a pet raccoon home
because i would enjoy it
thank you for your question would you be
maintaining that raccoon on 55 acres of
land for his habitat
because that is how we manage the hair
that are kept in captivity they also
have monitored feeding stations that
make sure that they have the food that
they need and with it being a fenced in
area they're actually safer from
predators than out in the wild so it's a
very nice situation that they get to be
in
thank you any further questions from the
committee
they're being done thank you angela
thank you very much
next up is dan doubleday of northfield
i don't have a lot of scientific
information
i've run beagles my entire life i hit my
first beagle when i was eight years old
um
when i was eight years old you could
turn a dog loose anywhere in the
southern part of the state and train or
train a dog
i recently joined the beagle club
because
there are no rabbits much south of
franconia notch there's a very large
i'd go north of the notch as often as i
can
i try to keep my dogs in shape
we run them at the club
the average speed of my dogs is under
two miles an hour
so there's no way that my dogs will ever
catch a rabbit
but i need to i i want to keep them
exercised in november i had the
i was had a six six and a half year old
dog
died running
rabbits
and
you know i wish they were running more
this this summer to keep him in better
shape
um it could have been a
lyme carditis is what the vet seemed to
think it was
but
i mean i enjoy the dogs it's hard for me
not to tear up even talking
about
this particular dog but
it's an event that i
really enjoy
and it allows me not very i don't have
to travel
hundreds of miles to run my dogs
um
and the other thing is you know we hear
a lot about
wild animals in captivity
what's clark's trading post
they've got
bear
there
and that's certainly only for commercial
purposes
so
i mean i i oppose this bill because i
believe it's the first step
in stopping
running dogs with the
on on snowshoe hair
and they also
are not
not all beagles are created equal
they don't all just show them a rabbit
and they run 10 seconds it takes it
takes a lot of time and a lot of
practice
to do this
and i am not a field trialer either i'm
simply a rabbit hunter
thank you thank you very much mr
doubleday for your testimony does
anybody have questions for mr double a
seeing none thank you very much sir for
your testimony in front of the fish and
game commission
next up is susan price she is one of our
fish and game commissioners however
she's here speaking on her own behalf
commission and a half minutes ma'am
thank you mr chairman
um
the gentleman that made the statement
earlier that uh dogs know how to hunt
that is true
but you have to be able to train your
dog to hunt
otherwise such as the woman from
the green estate dog
they will just run around in the woods
you'll lose your dog
so you need live game and in this case
snowshoe hare as the gentleman before me
attested
i'm a bird hunter i need to have my dog
safely trained
the prey instinct in these hunting dogs
is so
strong
that if you do not train them on live
game
you will end up shooting your dog you
have to be able to control your dog when
it has this prey instinct and i think
there's this false narrative that this
can somehow just be done magically
a lot of people are surprised that these
dogs you don't train a hunting dog on
treats
i've never used a treat to train my
honey dog i have a relationship with my
hunting dog
she wants to please me she wants to find
upland game birds for me
i had a beagle dog when i grew up as a
little girl my dad did not properly
train the dog
it got shot by accident
he told the dog
to stop the dog kept running and he shot
the dog by accident the dog lived
but
the point is that there is this repeated
false narrative that
hunting dogs don't need to be trained
when they have to be trained for safety
no other reason than safety second
secondarily for the success of the hunt
but the primary reason i use live game
birds on my dog when she was younger was
to produce a dog that would go steady to
wing and shot and not jump after a bird
and face mortality thank you
thank you questions for
commissioner price or mrs price
yes
thank you mr chair thank you
commissioner for taking my question
i was actually concerned when i heard
previous testimony that somebody had
said that
bird dogs are never trained on live
birds that are captured or
kept in pens because i know for a fact
i've seen some bird dogs
that are trained on caged pheasant and
caged gross i just heard you also
explain that you did train on live birds
that is something that's done just much
like the beagles are trained on hairs is
it not
yes and
pigeons are actually captured
to minimize the training costs
um
so
pigeons are actually captured by some
trainers in some states they're allowed
to to capture pigeons and use those um
they train them to come back
like any further questions from the
um first of all i guess i want to
welcome the honorable susan price back
she's a former state rep from uh from
barrington if i recall correctly so
and also that's survey this is somewhat
would you believe i grew up with two
beagles i don't know whether they're
properly trained although they were
trained fairly well to survive on
east 79th street in new york city so
like
so would you um
so i just thought i'd uh just thought
i'd you probably i guess you probably
wouldn't believe that but just so they
would have been totally hopeless if they
saw a snowshoe here i'm pretty sure they
would have run the opposite direction
like so
thank you representative horgan i'm not
sure there's a question there
but it is true i was a representative
from strafford county but i retired to
good old mountain borough
any further questions for the chairman
or the commissioner being then thank you
very much again but i'm not the
commissioner in this seat i understand
i'm still showing respect
all right next up is uh aj derosa um the
you have two and a half minutes sir
thank you for the time and uh for
disclosure i'm the stratford county uh
new hampshire fish and game commissioner
but i am here to testify as a member of
the public
um
in my private life i work in the pet
industry um primarily uh as a managing
partner of northwoods collective which
is engaged in this creative agency um
hunting dogs is a cornerstone of our
business we own hunting dog confidential
magazine which entails a gentleman named
craig kaushik which is one of the
foremost authorities in the world for
historians on hunting dogs
as we've heard everybody's debated many
things around
the rabbit itself i think that
the state has went out of its way to
make sure that the health of the hairs
and that the hairs that are uh
being used in these capacities are being
satisfied and i know they're the full
standard of random checks and whatnot
what i want to speak to is the actual
history i own a german i'm sorry i own a
wire here pointing griffon
if you turn back the clock less than 60
years ago the breed was almost extinct
most dogs that we know today were almost
extinct after the second world war which
did almost eliminate most breeds there
are extinct dog breeds that we know of
that are no longer here
this bill further passed the care of the
hair which has been satisfied is about
responsible breeding practices in the
state of new hampshire and we as a state
should make sure that we're abiding by
responsible and ethical breeding
practices to pass on tradition that
people have done
for literally hundreds of years in this
case i feel like we're targeting a
vulnerable aspect of our of our state
that isn't a minor that isn't a majority
that is a minority and saying just
because we don't necessarily like the
way you do your heritage and the
importance of the beagle and what the
beagle means to our human history as
hunters is being negated through the
process
thank you
thank you mr derosa any questions for mr
derosa
seeing them thank you very much sir
next up is dan bergeron on the hampshire
thank you i think at this point i've
been up here more than colonel jordan
i'm wondering when i get the
distinguished uh category in about 20
years
um
so thank you dan bergeron chief of the
wildlife physician
i'm here to represent the department in
the commission in opposition of this
bill
thank you
um
so our administrative rules part fis
806.05
are what regulate the live capture of
snowshoe hare
these these rules were developed um
to ensure the safety of the the um of
the snowshoe hare population of the
state and with the
safety and
condition of the hairs that are trapped
in mind
so i'm just going to go over
some of the regulations
around this practice because it is
so under these current rules
they can snowshoe hair can only be live
captured um by licensed trappers who are
members of a designated club
and there's there's only five clubs in
the state that are
permitted to do this
um clubs must also hold a valid
propagation permit which is also issued
by the department and they must follow
all the requirements that are associated
trapping can only take place
during the open season for hunting
snowshoe hare and it can only take place
on private property with lit and written
landowner permission
we've set restrictions on the type of
traps that must be used
how frequently the traps must be set how
much food must be placed in the traps
and that all traps must have a
weatherproof top
so there are no more than 20 hair that
can be trapped per club per year so that
would equate to a maximum that can be
trapped per year of 100 hair statewide
we've also taken further precautions in
the southern part of the state where
there is less abundant snowshoe hair
habitat
some of our wildlife management units
you cannot capture
more than 10 hair from those areas where
habitat is not as abundant as it is as
you move further north
in the past three years that we've we've
compiled data for so for 2021
we haven't gone through and entered all
that data yet so
for so for the past three years 18 19
and 20 a total of 168 hairs
have been captured
the department also tracks hunter effort
and again hunter observation rates
similar as reference to grey squirrels
long-term trends in the observation rate
of snowshoe hare have been stable
again like many wildlife species there's
populations annually or fluctuations
annually in the population over time but
the long-term trend for snowshoe here in
additionally clubs are required to
submit annual snowshoe hero live capture
summary reports
and that includes information on the
number of traps that are set
trapping effort
the number of hairs caught by sex town
and wildlife management unit
the number of hairs retained by the club
any non-target wildlife species that are
captured any mortality that might occur
during the trapping process
and also the number of hairs that were
propagated by the club the preceding
year
these rules were further amended in 2021
to require conservation officers to
visit the clubs at least once annually
to select a hair for veterinary
inspection by a licensed veterinarian
to date i reviewed all veterinary
inspections we've received
and all veterinary inspections indicate
that the animal that was examined was in
good physical condition
there's certainly no doubt
that this practice creates an emotional
debate
but the department feels that its
current administrative rules
are sufficient to to safeguard the
overall population in the state
we do not feel that the continued
practice has a detrimental effect to the
overall snowshoe hair population thank
you very much
questions for mr bergeron
representative spelaine go ahead
question and a follow-up if necessary
thank you mr chair
uh thank you mr bergeron for taking my
question um since
the uh
entire program has been expanded to be
statewide for the live trapping how
important has this
life trapping been to your data on the
so
we haven't i don't think we've really
gotten much
in regards to the the new england
cottontail
i don't know is there any data
that would have benefited us through the
management of that species has come out
of it
how many hairs can be killed by a hunter
in a given year if they're not being
colonel what's the what's the limit on
or
sorry
the daily bag limit
three so three a day three a day
that's a lot of hairs that could be
killed
yes thank you
representative kittridge
is recognized for a question and a
follow-up if necessary
yes does the department examine these
enclosures which are 50 to 100 acres
that
uh are trying are the training grounds
for these snowshoe harris so the law
enforcement does have the authority to
do that
and likely they would see these
enclosures when they go there to select
a rabbit for inspection do you check
them for uh
you check them for appropriate habitat
for
hairs hiding and so forth you know
yeah so i i believe out of necessity um
to to make sure that these hairs survive
in there the habitat is is
from what i understand from people who
visited these there's sufficient cover
for the hair
thank you for your testimony thank you
mr chairman chair recognized
representative craig for a question and
necessary a follow-up
thank you mr chair thank you mr bergeron
uh
we know that
hairs are
very susceptible to changes in
the local environment due to logging and
other
pressures do you find that
these enclosures
are maintained
better for their survival
than if they were just in the wild in
land that might be logged or burned or
grazed
um
so so
so you know wildlife will seek out you
know the most appropriate habitat in the
area
i would say that the again i've never
visited any of these facilities i'd just
like to to say that um my understanding
is that uh from from individuals who
have that there is adequate cover in
these um in these facilities again these
enclosures from my understanding are
there are all sorts of things that
impact habitat for a number of wildlife
species throughout the state
you know it was referenced earlier that
there was loss of habitat for hair that
that is true in southern portions of the
state um you know we routinely lose
habitat to development um there's less
forestry practices that go on um
you know the northern part of the state
is certainly where the primary snowshoe
hair habitat is
but but again my understanding from
individuals who visited these sites
there is adequate cover for the hair at
further questions from the committee
i have i have a couple
so when i look at line five in this bill
do you have a copy of the bill in front
of you
so i'm concerned about about three words
in this bill that may cause a problem
for fish and game and one of them is and
the words are in this state
which means that you can't
you can't
take live snowshoe hairs or rabbits from
the wild in this state does that create
an importation problem and potential if
we allow importation because we don't
allow capture in our own state but you
can capture in another state and bring
them in would that
i would have to review our current
importation rules and see what category
um hair would fall under
whether or not they were controlled or
prohibited and
nice
thank you my second question goes to a
little bit of constitutionality is in
the last part of this again from seven
to ten
um
we have a taking of property occurring
where we're taking a private citizen's
property being the snowshoe here after
they've legally captured it and they've
they're taking care of it
we're taking that property and creating
retrospectively a law against that
against that property do you think that
potentially causes some liabilities or
some issues with us with creating either
a retrospective law or the taking of a
person's property without due process
um
i could foresee an instance where it
certainly could
you know
i'll preface that with my backgrounds in
wildlife management so that's not my
area of expertise but i certainly could
foresee that happening
thank you any further questions from the
committee
seeing them thank you very much thank
you
next up is i think it's george cook from
jefferson
give me one second my clock up here so i
can uh you have two and a half minutes
and there you go you're ready to rock
and roll
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee uh my name is george cook i am
from jefferson new hampshire and i am
here
as a member of dog owners of the granite
state in opposition to the bill it's
interesting because i got my start in
purebred dogs uh as a child with beagles
uh and i was fascinated by their natural
ability to be able to track and trace
hair this is out in the state of
california
that is
excuse me led me on to
what has become my lifelong
pursuit of another performance bred
animal which is siberian huskies which i
have trained and raced
uh basically all over the united states
and canada
i'm here to speak to the fact that a
well-trained dog
regardless of the breed is an asset to
its owner
and that the
time that is spent by the beaglers in
the attempt to train their dogs is an
admirable
aspect
not only for
the preservation of a historic breed the
beagle like the siberian husky it's a
very fundamental
uh early
well-known breed and needs to be
propagated
for its original intended purpose
i'll throw out another
aspect
i
have a certified tree farm in jefferson
so i'm operating a temp timber operation
the three basic tenets of
force proper forest management planning
timber value
wildlife improvement and erosion control
we don't want to do anything in this
state which is so heavily involved in
the
forestry industry to do anything to
degrade
the
support for
item number two the wildlife management
aspect of forest management planning
there's a good reason that the hairs are
up in northern new hampshire
tree farm operators like myself we spend
a lot of time tweaking our forest
management plans to provide for wildlife
practice as regulated currently by the
gel car rules
has worked for a long time it's not
final final point uh no one has yet
referred to the protections and the
regulations are contained in rsa 644.8
the cruelty statutes i think you'll find
that none of the beagle clubs have ever
been run afoul of any of the criteria
within 644.8 which protects uh wild
animals in captivity thank you very much
thank you for your test testimony mr
cook are there any questions for mr cook
seeing none sir thank you for coming
next up is matthew mckenis
mckernes um who is opposing the bill
hello my name is matthew mckearney i'm
the president of claremont beagle club
and i am here to oppose 1308
i would like to talk to you today about
the importance of hound trials and the
effect that they will have on the state
and the beagle breed if they were no
longer able to continue
a little back story is the first beagle
trial was actually held in hyannis
massachusetts on november 4th in 1890
there was a total of 18 entries and
since that day the popularity of these
trials has grown exponentially
at claremont club we will see upwards of
200 dogs spread across four classes in
two days of competition
with a total of over twenty four
thousand dogs competing in akc
sanctioned events in new hampshire
during the 2019 season these events draw
a large number of people and their
families to new hampshire multiple times
a year
and while doing so they add an influx of
money to the local economies
including sales of gas as they dine out
and the rest of the hospitality industry
these people also travel back to the
state during the hunting seasons again
paying for guides gear lodging
non-resident hunting licenses that i can
tell you from experience are not cheap
in 2020
10 887
non-resident hunting licenses were sold
in the state of new hampshire generating
a massive income for the state and its
conservation programs
while also providing jobs and a source
of income for residents of the state
in a beagle trial a group of hounds is
cast into the grounds to be judged on
how well and accurate they can track the
desired game
this type of trial is a tool used by
breeders and handlers to ensure that
proper traits are being passed down
generationally with the ability to
compete our hounds with one another we
have are able to view any faults or
negative traits while also nurturing the
positive ones this is very helpful when
it comes to the selection of dogs deemed
fit for breeding to ensure that we are
furthering those positive or desired
traits to continue bettering the breed
through selective breeding
dog trials are popular events all over
the country with ribbons and sometimes
small trophies or plaques being awarded
to the five placing hounds and while
these things have no monetary value they
do signify a large amount of hard work
along with the ribbons the placing hound
is awarded points based on how many
hounds were entered in the trial and
their placing in akc it takes three wins
and 120 points to earn the title of
field champion and this is the ultimate
goal of any trialer the pursuit of a
title or what is known as finishing a
dog is what has us up before dawn
traveling and competing
beagles are long distance endurance
runners and it is not uncommon for these
hard-working dogs to willingly travel 20
miles in a day in pursuit of their
quarry a wild rabbit or hair is the best
test of a hound's tracking ability that
cannot be replicated ten seconds sir
thank you
rabbits have a unique ability to travel
at a fast rate of speed through tight
and difficult terrain truly testing a
hound's merit and ability while breeders
and handlers strive to produce the
absolute best hound we can even the best
dog can be outsmarted by these creatures
thank you for your testimony sarah
questions for matthew
seeing done matt thanks for coming in
testifying today in front of the fish
and game committee
next up is
robert ferrante
from the claremont beagle club
good afternoon members of new hampshire
fishing game and marine sources
i am in opposition of uh passage bill
sir can you just speak into the mic so
everybody could hear you better
okay
i am in opposition of the passage of um
hb 1308 which says it is a bill
prohibiting the capture possession and
propagation of hairs and rabbits for
hunting and training a field trial
this is not a bill about saving hairs it
is a bill about ending try tracking dogs
hunting training and field trials in new
hampshire
providing all the rules and licensings
of all it is not illegal to hunt in new
hampshire it is not illegal to hunt with
dogs it is not illegal to train hunting
dogs and it is not illegal to use live
animals in training
so the issues addressed by this bill are
not the training
of all hunting dogs not the training of
dogs with live animals
not the holding or all sorts of all
sorts of hunting and sports events
not the trapping or relocation of hairs
and not the use of very large habitat
pins to use hairs or rabbits
the only intent is to prohibit one group
of hunters from safely training their
dogs and hunting in new hampshire
rabbits are hairs and under and are
under predator pressure your entire
lives
the difference between wild predators
and tracking dogs is that wild predators
intend to kill and eat the rabbits while
the dogs simply track them
and there's no unpleasant endings to
those animals that attract
this bill appears to be a discriminatory
measure aimed at a certain segment of
the public of the hunting public with
the intent to ensure that these hunters
and only these hunters have no safe
place to train their dogs into and to
prohibit the dog clubs from holding
field trial competition
loss of habitat in the southern
two-thirds of new hampshire has resulted
in a majority of the snowshoe hair
population being in the northern three
counties of the state
moving a small portion of these hairs to
enclose habitats in more southern areas
of the state may well prove to be an
advantage in attaining the population
should any disease or disease strike
those northern three counties
sporting dog clubs provide an enclosure
habitat suitable for the relocation of
hairs to live in a and reproduce
in more southern new hampshire locations
while you could call it a pin
15 to 120 acres really is a natural
territory and is managed in a mere
managed habitat for these rabbits ten
seconds sir
okay
the reality is that here
are not a species that
is not going to be
we're not going to lose the species if
we continue to be able to propagate them
in these pins this bill is designed to
unjustly apply unequal treatment under
the law to specific subset of hunters
please vote this bill and explicitly to
the legal attempt to allow us to be able
to trap these 20 rabbits and be able to
continue what we do and love thank you
sir for your testimony mr any questions
for mr ferrante
seeing none thank you again so every
testimony coming for the fish and game
commission
next up is keller rob i believe from the
claremont beagle club as well ma'am you
have two and a half minutes
thank you um i have submitted a forester
report from our club
to everyone and i also submitted a
petition with over a thousand signatures
my name is calla and i'm the secretary
of claremont beagle club
new hampshire has three species of
rabbit the new england cottontail the
eastern cottontail and the snowshoe hare
snowshoe hair or varying hair as they
are also called are an interesting
animal they are not actually rabbits but
a different species all on their own
they only weigh three to five pounds and
aren't social animals other than for
breeding they are not born in nests like
other rabbits they are born with eyes
open covered in hair with the ability to
move around from day one because that is
what they have evolved to do they are
also smart and wary of their
surroundings hair
are one of the only animals that can
survive on their own excrement in the
times of the year where feed is hard to
find hair is also very good at hiding
and will hear you or your dog coming
before you get within 100 yards of them
this is why they have those big ears
hair are also mostly active at dawn and
dusk these things combined with the fact
that they are only one of seven animals
that will change
to the color white when the day length
changes in what makes them evasive
only one to thirty percent of hair
survive their first year of life in the
wild this is why hair are avid breeders
having two to four litters per year with
an average of three per liter
they can jump up to 10 feet in a bound
and travel up to 28 miles per hour
snowshoe hare populations cycle in 8 to
eight to eleven year periods and
densities may fluctuate five to twenty
five percent during a cycle this means
the population of hair is always in flux
at claremont beagle club snowshoe hair
are very valuable to us
we have two 100 acre pens that are
managed to fit the needs of the hair as
well as to protect the hair from outside
predation we do everything possible and
legal we can to protect the hair but
live trapping hair allows us to bring
new dna to the existing population as
well as restock from losses due to
predation
snowshahara live in a specific habitat
which is young coniferous forest that
have dense thickets and are usually
swampy
at the claremont club we plant trees
everywhere as well as select cut to help
manage the growth the growth of these
tickets in 2020 we planted over 2000
trees and another 500 in 2021 to ensure
the hair have proper habitat we have
done this with guidance from county and
state foresters
we are also the only state that has
specific trapping laws for rabbit and
hair 20 hair per club with already
strict restrictions
you've already heard all this
trapping hair is an easy task with the
abundance of live traps set and checked
on a daily basis it does not guarantee a
catch you have 10 seconds left in our
summaries
um i just want to say that
they we can only trap on private lands
also and some places up north have also
deemed
that the hare our nuisance animal to
them because they do eat the bark and
destroy some trees which also causes
habitat loss and
economic loss to people's businesses
thank you very much keller any questions
for colin representative spelaine sorry
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question uh you've done some
impressive conservation work on 200-acre
uh areas there would it be fair to say
that that would probably cease if you
could no longer use those as habitat for
representative
uh thank you mr chair you may have um
mentioned it
i just
may have missed it how many hair do you
keep in your facility
it is
very hard to keep track of them if you
walk out into 100 acres and you walked
around especially if they're always
moving with them hearing you
it's very hard to count them we do
count as many as possible but we don't
know if they are the same hair or a
different hair we do have feeding
stations
and by
judging on the amount of feed they eat
we can kind of keep that as well as in
the wintertime you can look at tracks
and you walk around
between the five and 25 acres of
a kind of a where they breed in their
natural hab like in the wild if the
habitat is prolific for them a hair will
only take up about five acres so
conceivably we could keep 20 hair or
more you know in a club thank you
anybody else
seeking no questions thank you very much
kyle thank you thank you for coming to
next up is david price in opposition to
thank you everybody for staying late
tonight i oppose this bill
seeing how that
the population of hairs in the state is
doing well and it's fine and we've been
trapped in these hairs for quite some
time now and there's no
sign of us decreasing the population out
there in the wild so it's just
sustaining what we are doing now so i
believe we should continue on what we're
doing now
in a safe
area to run our dogs is key to keep our
hounds safe and our people safe
and i believe that's good and you have
fact sheets out there we have a vet come
to a club every year
and i've since 2016 i gave you all
copies that we have great bill of health
from every time a vet has come and
checked our hairs in captivity so
there's no issues there whatsoever
having them in cactus captivity
and i've been a new hampshire um
thank you mr price and we have any
questions for mr price representative
howard
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
would it be fair to say that if you
tried to train a dog in the wild it's
happened to run
say a deer and then once they start
running deer it's very hard to break
them of that absolutely absolutely once
they get a scent and and they take that
scent it is hard to break it they're
very very stubborn dog
so it's key to have them on
the right game when they're young and
keep them on that right game for quite
some time so that way that's all they
track i could bring my dogs into a deer
yard now and they will not touch the
deer
they will run just the hair that are in
the same yard thank you you're very
welcome
any further questions for mr price
seeing them thank you mr price for
coming for the fish and game committee
next up is sorry
uh stacy ober
of the american kennel club and stacy
you have two minutes
two and a half sorry
thanks mr chairman members of the
committee my name is stacy ober i am the
new england representative for the
american kennel club happy to be with
you here today and to express our strong
opposition to house bill 1308 the
american kennel club is a not-for-profit
corporation we've been around for 135
years
and we're recognized as experts in
canine breeding training
and responsible dog ownership
we do have over in the country we
represent more than 5 000 clubs and
there are 14 here in new hampshire four
of which are beagle clubs and you've
heard some of the numbers and how
popular
our events are where
individuals enjoy bonding with their
dog house 1308 would overturn a 2020
vote by the new hampshire fish and game
commission
to reject a voices of wildlife petition
by statutorily prepared by permit
holders
and unfortunately by way of petition
social media and now this legislation
new hampshire citizens have been
consistently misled as to the beagle
members activities when training their
dogs and conducting conducting akc
license field trials
we feel the request to file house bill
1308 is a challenge to the commission's
authority and integrity and we're
strongly opposed to 1308
i know you've heard a lot today and
happy to answer questions but i did want
to state that the ethical
ethical hunting demands that when
hunting game animals which here are you
make every effort to achieve the most
quick and efficient harvest possible and
you're abiding by state hunting
regulations the best conservation tool
is a well-trained hunting dog to
i'm here to answer any questions i
believe
other testimony has
a lot of the myths and the
mischaracterization of how these
activities have been conducted
i can say on some of the flyers
information for instance i've seen kind
reaction by claiming that dog club
members put a dog in a crate with a hair
which scares the hair to death and you
know other suggestions of cruel behavior
which is absolutely unfounded so i
wanted to assure you of that i think
that's why you heard earlier the comment
about these clubs are not engaged in any
kind
any conduct that would be deemed in
animal cruelty in new hampshire state
law which covers both domestic and wild
animals thank you
thank you miss ober any questions for
thank you miss over for your testimony
appreciate you coming in front of the
next up is kyle baker of the new
hampshire wildlife federation in
you have two and a half minutes sir
thank you again
for having us here today uh kyle baker
here with the new hampshire wildlife
federation and opposition to this bill
uh most of the points that i want to say
have already been covered um again just
wanted to provide background that this
exact bill came before the fish and game
commission um and what they did instead
of denying it was struck a compromise uh
position last year which which is why we
have the new rules in place
requiring an independent veterinarian
examination of a hair at the club's cost
every single year so again we feel that
that compromise provides adequate
protections for the hairs being held for
these activities but we
that's pretty much all i wanted to say
so happy to answer any questions
thank you mr baker any questions for mr
baker
seeing none thank you mr baker for your
testimony in front of the fish and game
commission today
next up is robert miller from supreme
mr miller you have two and a half
minutes
chairman members thank you for um
letting me speak today um robert miller
brentwood because you're speaking to the
mike center we could hear you
robert miller from brentwood um
i'm a dog owner i'm a dog breeder and
i'm a dog trainer i do sporting and
non-sporting dogs
my sporting dogs hunt birds i'm an
upland bird hunter um
it is one one comment i want to make
about
breeders only being in it for the money
that's a comment made by somebody who's
never raised a litter of puppies because
these dogs have an innate these hounds
and many other breeds have an innate
ability to scent humans smell parts per
million dogs do parts per billion
they can smell you and tell you your
mood
so
what does that mean you have a dog here
you want it to engage in certain
activities
so
you take that innate ability and you
train it um i've trained my dogs with
live wild birds that's what they need to
do
because that's going to mimic what they
do in the field when i'm hunting them
to
there aren't other ways to do it and you
do that early you instill that scent
that drive
and you have a successful dog you have a
dog that's
somebody mentioned before you have a
relationship with that dog they want to
please you they want to go get the game
and bring it back to you
in the off season i take all of my dogs
and engage in scent a lot of scent
activities
it keeps their mind going it keeps them
stimulated
it improves the quality of life for your
dogs
and that's
not doing so um really it's mismanaging
your dog it's mistreating them um you
know the 10-minute walk when you go home
that's really insufficient to to keep
your dog healthy and active and people
have already also addressed here that
that human canine bond that's been been
around for thousands of years and you
instill that by doing things with your
dogs and you do things that your dog
loves to do and then they love to be
with you um and having that
that bond
benefits the dog it also benefits people
because there's innumerable studies that
will show you
the benefit to having a dog the
emotional the physical all that stuff
having a dog
will do for you um i also wanted to to
to bring up a topic that hasn't been
mentioned before it's called epigenetics
if you take a dog and you
for wha you do things that are prevented
from doing things that it's been bred to
do it's been developed to do
after three generations that dog won't
know how to do that
so why would you want to do that to all
these specific dogs that have sent
hounds and what have you that have
been developed over hundreds of years
to take care of that
um
that's pretty much it for me
any questions for mr miller
seeing them thank you very much
we're on our last pink card of the day
um we have uh joseph mullins of the
congressional sportsman foundation in
opposition to the bill
good afternoon chairman lang honorable
members of the house fish and game and
marine resources committee
for the record my name is joe mullen i'm
from grafton massachusetts i'm the
northeastern states assistant manager
for the congressional sportsman's
foundation
i am here to testify in opposition to
house bill 1308
now
as many of you may already know new
hampshire is known throughout the region
for its wide array of hunting
opportunities many of which rely on the
use of well-trained dogs while the field
and two such pursuits are rabbit and
snowshoe hare hunting in preparation for
these seasons a dog is commonly trained
over live captured hairs under
environments that simulate situations
the dog will see in the field
the use of these hairs is also an
important component to field trials
during which a dog's ability to perform
under hunting conditions is tested
now as someone who has spent countless
hours training a hunting dog i can
attest to the value and ethics behind
preparing your dog for the conditions it
will see in the field which includes in
my case tracking and retrieving
something that cannot be adequately
replicated without the use of live game
this is something that miss
price and mr derosa have discussed and
they hit the nail on the head with it
by prohibiting the use of wild hairs for
training dogs
stocking a training site or in field
trials house bill 1308 will send under
trained and underqualified dogs into the
field in the pursuit of game those of us
who enjoy hunting and competing with
dogs in the granite state encourage your
swift opposition house bill 1308 i thank
thank you mr mullen any questions for mr
mullen
seeing them thank you sir for your
testimony thank you for coming for the
fish and game committee today
that is our last pink card of the day
um i we will hold this bill for the 25th
and have to have uh further discussions
then i encourage all members
and with that i'm going to close the
public hearing on 1308
i'm going to encourage any members we
retain six bills that we're going to be
talking about on the 20th on the 25th i
should say
if you have ideas for amendments i i
recommend you get with the sponsors of
those bills and hammer out the the
amendment that you think you want or
with other members and please bring the
mem bring it before the committee on the
25th so we can have intelligent and
thoughtful conversation and not be
reading reading amendments
for the first time
with that this meeting is adjourned
you